hey everyone welcome to simply loans
youtube channel in this session you will
be learning about excel advanced full
course but before we begin i would like
to take a quick confirmation from our
viewers if the screen is clearly visible
and we are clearly audible if yes kindly
type yes in the chat section and if
there is anything that we could
improvise then please do let us know in
the chat section
great i see a lot of positive responses
from our viewers so i think it's clear
that we can get started so before we
begin i would like to tell you guys that
we have daily updates on multiple
technologies if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for latest technological
trends then consider getting subscribed
to our youtube channel and don't forget
to hit that bell icon to never miss an
update from simply learn now without
further ado let's get started with the
agenda for today's session
at first we will get started with a
basic fundamental understanding of what
exactly is microsoft excel and
spreadsheets in excel followed by that
we will start with some advanced
fundamentals in excel that is how to
protect or lock cells in excel followed
by that how to set up your print page
then we have gold seeking excel charts
in excel and followed by that we will
understand some conditional formatting
and data validation in excel later we
will dive deep into the lookup functions
where we will learn about the hlookup
vlookup and x lookup in excel then we
will try to implement the vstat function
in excel which is the latest function
followed by that we will understand the
power query in excel then we will try to
understand how to convert the pdf data
into the excel form of data
then we will understand the round off
functions in excel then how to combine
multiple cells in excel and how to
create a combined data spreadsheet in
excel followed by that we will learn
about excel round off formula next we
will learn about combining data from
multiple sheets
then we will learn about dated diff
function in excel and next we will find
how to change the date format in excel
once we are done with the date format in
excel we can get started with pivot
tables in excel followed by the
fundamentals of pivot tables in excel we
will understand how to create pivot
tables using multiple sheets in excel
then we will get into slices in excel
then we will understand sumifs in excel
followed by that we will understand how
to create a drop down list in excel
then we will go through the budget
template in excel followed by that we
will understand the mis report in excel
next we have excel macros and vba then
we have the user form in excel then the
regression in excel followed by that we
will learn how to recover unsaved excel
files and then project planning in excel
once we are done with the excel advanced
functions we will get started with tips
and tricks in excel which will make
things easy for you while working on
data analytics using in excel
followed by that we will cover some
interesting and most frequently asked
excel based interview questions and
answers so i hope i made myself clear
with the agenda now let's get started
with our first topic so over to our
training experts
what is microsoft excel
so microsoft excel is a software product
designed and developed by microsoft for
storing data in an organized way that is
rows and columns
and
microsoft excel is also capable to
manipulate data through some
mathematical operations
followed by that
microsoft excel is also used to extract
the insights from the data and represent
it in the form of visually appealing
graphs and charts
now we have a basic understanding or an
overview of what a microsoft excel
software product is
now moving ahead we will understand the
fundamentals of microsoft excel
so following are some fundamentals that
you need to know before getting started
with microsoft excel so basically when
you install the microsoft office in your
computer you will have various microsoft
products out of which microsoft excel is
one of the product so we will be dealing
exactly with that particular product
that is microsoft excel so when you get
started with microsoft excel this is
what you will see in the first page
so this particular page is called as
microsoft excel homepage where you will
be having various varieties of sheets
microsoft excel will give you some
suggestions based on the type of sheet
you want to work with we will see this
in a better way through the practical
session so once you get started with the
sheet you will have some more options so
this particular option is called as the
toolbar menu you will have the file home
insert draw page layout formulas data
review view and help so these are the
tools that you will be using to work on
your data using microsoft excel
furthermore we have a toolbar ribbon so
when you select some or the other option
from the file home insert draw page
layout formulas data review view and
help buttons you will have a ribbon so
for example you can see that i have
selected the home tool here so when i
press on the home tool this is the
ribbon which microsoft excel gives me so
this ribbon has some options in it which
can perform various operations now in a
further more detailed way we will have
toolbar groups
so when you see in the previous slide we
have a complete toolbar ribbon so this
particular ribbon is segmented into
groups so you can see the first group as
paste cut copy format painter etc etc
and the second group is the font the
size of the font and to increase the
size of the font to decrease the size of
the phone bold italic underline etc etc
and here you can see the text alignment
so each and every group has separate
functions
so each set is called as a group
and i think you can see a small arrow
option over here so this arrow option is
used into the toolbar groups when the
group is not able to fit all the
operations or all the functionalities in
one single provided section so when you
click on this particular arrow mark you
will have another dialog box so this is
called toolbar more options so you can
see that when i clicked on this icon you
can see a new dialog box which opens me
a new set of operations which are not
able to be fit in this particular group
so we will also see more about this in a
better way in the practical session now
moving forward we have cell and address
so when you open a microsoft excel sheet
you can find boxes so each and every box
is named as a cell and each cell has its
own address for example the highlighted
cell over here has an address b3 so b is
the column name and three is the rule
name
and apart from that you can have the
sheet tracker in the bottom left corner
of the excel sheet where you can
navigate through different sheets
and in the bottom right corner you have
an option of increasing or decreasing
the sheet size so these are the basic
fundamentals of microsoft excel that you
need to keep in mind before getting
started so we will have more on this in
the practical session if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
so now we enter the demo inventory in
microsoft excel so we will be using
microsoft excel to create a sheet of the
employees in a company
so basically an employee in the company
has employee id name and designation
salary etc etc so we will be trying to
create the same table using microsoft
excel but before that let us understand
the fundamentals of microsoft excel
through the practical demo first so i
have started my microsoft excel and this
is how the home page of microsoft excel
looks like
so you have a blank workbook over here
if you want to create a new workbook you
can select new option
so excel will provide you with various
variety of sheets you can see money in
excel adjustable meeting agenda
streaming shows small business cash flow
and many more if you're not able to find
what you're looking for then you always
have an option of selecting the
particular type of sheet what you're
looking for so you have various options
if it's business if it's personal if
it's planners and trackers lists budgets
charts etc etc so let's imagine that you
wanted something from business so just
by clicking at business option the excel
will load a variety of sheets related to
business options so this might take a
while so you can see that the excel is
loading few types of sheets
so you can see that excel has provided
us with some online varieties of sheets
for example any calendar business
expenses channel marketing budget budget
summary report blue product list etc etc
you can see construction proposal
invoice you name it excel has got it so
excel will provide you with some variety
of options based on your requirement now
for this session let's get started with
a blank workbook which looks something
like this since this tutorial is based
on the fundamentals we'll go with a
blank workbook
now over here you can see the toolbar
that we discussed earlier that has the
file home insert draw base layout
formulas data review view and help so
this is the toolbar and
under the toolbar i have selected home
and you can see this is the particular
ribbon what we discussed about this
particular ribbon belongs to home page
and when you select file option you'll
get back to whom and if you select
insert option you'll have another
different ribbon with different groups
etc etc so every particular tool has
different ribbons in them and remember
the extra options that we discussed when
you press over this arrow key this is it
so when you press the arrow key you'll
have few more settings which cannot be
fit in this particular section of groups
so you can have some variety of options
over here of changing the font changing
some effects to the text font size and
font style etc etc
apart from this we have also discussed
about the cells in every sheet so this
particular cell has an address so you
can see the address over here which is
b3 so b happens to be the
column name and three happens to be the
row name
now we also had a discussion about the
sheet tracker right now we just have one
sheet if you want multiple sheets you
can just feel free to select on the plus
option which will always create you some
extra sheets
and you can navigate through sheets just
by pressing on the sheet name
and when you get back to the bottom
right corner you have an option of
increasing and decreasing the cell size
or the sheet size now let's keep it
default with hundred percent
now these are the few fundamentals that
you need to keep in mind before getting
started with microsoft excel now that we
know the fundamentals of microsoft excel
let's get started with a practical
session which is about the employees
details in a company
now let's select this particular cell
let's type in
employee details
yeah we have the cell
now an employee details table will have
the information related to employees so
the information will be about name
it will be about employee number
it will be the designation
and maybe salary
and maybe blood group as well
and
let's take another one which is phone
number
yeah
so so far so good and uh you can see
that we have some problem with this
particular column
the designation the name uh the the name
of the designation is practically
good but it is not visible so when you
when you're not on that particular cell
you can see that the name is incomplete
over here so you can always fix that you
can just you know manually change the
size of the row or cell or you can also
feel free to you know double click on
that cell which will automatically you
know set the size of that particular
cell
and same goes to the blood group just
let's try to double click on that and
same goes to phone number
great
so you can see that the employee's
details are just confined to the first
two cells it's supposed to be somewhere
in the middle right so no problem we can
do that as well we can select all the
cells
and
we have an option of merging
them you can just select this one which
will help you with merging and centering
that particular data to the center part
so that's how we do it
now let's get started by adding the
names of the employees
oh let's add the names joe
john
uh
mary
mark
susan
and then
jennifer
let's type in mike
let's open them
jeff
jeffrey
yeah we have a couple of employees now
let's type in the employee numbers
here we have the employee numbers now
let's type in the designation okay let's
choose uh joe to be the ceo of the
company
and john as the software developer
and mary as tester
mark and finance
susan also in finance
and jennifer and testing
and mike in
marketing
same goes for two
and again jeffrey into software
development
and
morgan into testing again
now let's click on a c so that it gets
you know resized according to the length
of the text
now it's done so let's get into salary
uh
ten thousand dollars
and fifteen thousand dollars
[Music]
nineteen thousand dollars let's increase
the salary of a ceo so let's keep it one
lakh dollars
and finance again twenty thousand
so yeah the salaries are allocated again
the blood group
here we have the
blood groups now let's type in the
mobile numbers
[Music]
yeah now we have typed in some random
mobile numbers as well
so uh yeah this is how you can add in
some data into your table
and now let us imagine that you forgot
to add or
remove a column so let's imagine that we
wanted to add a serial number as well
but somehow we forgot to add it now you
can always add a new row or column for
example here we wanted to add a new
column so we just have to right click on
a select the insert option
here we have a new row now
now let's type in serial number
and let's type one
now can you see the small box option
over here if you just drag it you can
you know copy paste all those over here
and now let's right click
and
fill series now we have the employee
number starting from 1 to 10
that's how you do it and apart from this
you can also you know change the font of
the entire row you can change the font
to
say uh
roni
and you can always also change the font
and same goes to the employee table you
can select it bold it and you can also
increase the size and again select a
color for the text
maybe a different color green would be
better
and
you can also select the entire cells and
align them to the center
looks more good
and you can select or double click the
row names so you'll have the proper
spacing between all the rows and columns
so we have double click on the column
right yeah so basically that's how you
make things happen
now let's save this
so i'd like to go to the save option and
amt data
let me save this in my local location
and just save it's done
so that's how you work on your excel
file with some basic data
and to learn more don't forget to get
subscribed to simply loans youtube
channel and don't forget to hit that
bell icon to stay updated so you are the
first person to get an update on any
technology not just excel
now we are on the microsoft excel and
this particular spreadsheet is related
to employee details
yeah now the screen is visible a bit
better now let us imagine that this is
our confidential data
and you want to edit only two columns
that is the designation column and phone
number column now let us imagine that
the company has finished one annual year
and now there are some promotions
happening in the company and let us also
imagine that the phone numbers of the
employees provided by the company have
undergone some changes
so now the minor edits that you want to
make are related to the designation
column and phone number column now you
can see that all the columns that is the
blood group new salary salary hike
current salary and name of the employee
serial number employee number everything
is editable so in such kind of scenarios
when you pass on this data there might
be a possibility where your colleague or
subordinate might end up making some
mistakes right so you want to avoid that
so you can do that by locking the cells
now let us rename this sheet
now the sheet has been renamed
successfully so now you can log the
cells by the following process
so in this process you have two major
steps first one is to log the cells and
the next one is to protect the cells by
a password
now when you select all the cells in
this particular sheet you can just click
on this edge here and you have all the
cells selected and now right click
somewhere on the sheet and you can see
an option called format cells
so in this particular option you have
some options provided which is number
alignment font and you want to go into
the protection part so you can see
by default excel
keeps all the cells locked
now we want the phone number and
designation to be unlocked okay so let's
cancel it for now and get back to the
sheet and select the columns d
and i
and now let's right click and
go into format cells and in the
protection option make sure that you
uncheck the logged icon
now select ok
and
now okay so you cannot include the
merged cell fine we have a cell here
which is merged okay let's remove that
okay now again select the entire column
right click
get into format cells
and uncheck the lock option select ok
now we have finished the first part that
is
locking all the cells which you don't
want to get edit and unlocking the cells
where you want to make some edits now
the second stage is protecting the sheet
now right click on the sheet name and
you can see an option called protect
sheet click that and now here you can
see select log cells and also select
unlock cells so let us provide a
password here so
let us use some simple password so that
we don't forget that so i'll be
selecting 1 2 3
and now select ok
re-enter the password to proceed now let
us type 123 again now select ok and now
the sheet is protected
now we have successfully
locked and protected all the cells in
excel
now let us verify that the cells you
wanted to protect are really protected
and locked or not so we have unlocked
phone number and designation and
everything else is locked now let me try
and edit the blood group so when i
double click or try to edit this
particular sheet then i'll be receiving
a warning from excel it says the cell or
chart you're trying to change is on a
protected sheet
to make a change unprotect the sheet you
might be requested to enter a password
so
it says that this particular cell is
locked and you cannot edit it now let us
try to edit the phone numbers which we
kept as unlocked
so you can see i can really edit the
unlocked cell here now let me try to
change this phone number let me enter
some random phone number
so you can see the cell is editable
now let us go through the designation
column and try to
edit this particular column now since i
said that there is a promotion happening
in the company so the deputy ceo is now
the current ceo of the company
and software developer happens to become
the senior software developer
and the tester as well
let us imagine that he will become the
senior
and so on
okay so this proves that this particular
sheet is editable not the entire sheet
but only the sense that we kept in the
analog mode
okay
now this is how you lock and protect
your cells in excel
page setup nms excel
so to understand the page setup in ms
excel we will go through a demo
inventory in excel where we'll be
considering some restaurant data
now without any delay let's get started
with the practical demo
now we are on the excel sheet and this
is the data i was talking about the
restaurant data where we have the first
column that has rank and next we have
the restaurant name followed by that we
have the sales happening through that
restaurant and then we have the segment
category that is what kind of service
does that particular restaurant offers
now this is the list what we made and
what if we wanted to represent this data
in the form of a printed paper right so
i guess you can see all the columns and
rows here so you can see that we have
almost like 250 rows
so there is no chance or there is no way
to print all those 250
rows in one page of course it is
practically possible but
when you try to read the content it will
be so tough to read because all the rows
will be clubbed together so closely so
that you cannot read it
so you need to print them page by page
so and you need to also take care of the
data is aligned
properly according to the page size
everything and even you need to take
care of the margins of your page right
so that's what page setup basically
means
so we had a detailed overview of our
data and what actually we are trying to
make now let us see how paid setup is
possible in ms excel
so to go to the page setup menu or go to
the page setup options we have three
methods let's start with the simplest
method so the simplest method is by just
clicking on file and go to print option
and you'll see all the page setup
options right over here
and
you can also go to print menu by
pressing a shortcut method that is
control p
so you'll directly end up on the page
setup options
now let's look at the second method so
the second method is you can see the
toolbar over here right which has file
home insert draw page layout formulas
data review
view and help
so the second method we can use page
layout option from the toolbar
and you can see when you click on the
page option from the toolbar you have a
new ribbon over here so this ribbon is
all about page setup options so it will
offer you margins it will offer you
orientation size print area breaks
background print tiles etc etc right so
all these options or menus in this
ribbon belong to page setup
now let us look at the third method so
the third method is something similar
you have view option on the toolbar so
just select a view
and you can see we have few page setup
options over here as well the normal
page break page layout custom views
and we have grid lines formula bar
heading zoom and zoom out select to zoom
free certain panes right so all these
are also the page setup options so we
have the three methods to enter the page
setup options now we are familiar with
those now let's get started with the
practical mode on page setup for that
let me use the simplest method that is
holding the control key and pressing p
which navigates me to the print option
now we have various set of options here
we have no scaling normal margins letter
portrait orientation collated print
active sheets and note one for windows
you can see this option is the printers
option for example if you are connected
to a printer
which is the hardware printer then your
ms excel will show the printer's name
here so other than printer you can also
make some other arrangements where you
can just directly print your complete
data in the form of pdf and then you can
export your pdf to your recipient that's
also possible
okay now let's get started with the
first option that is print active pages
okay to understand this better we need
to create a new sheet
not a problem
so you can see that we just have one
sheet over here
so let us kind of select all the items
and create a new sheet and try to paste
it over here
or let's try to paste it over here
okay
now let's try to extend these
yeah this should be fine now let's
rename this sheet
sheet
or
let's rename it as
restaurant
sheet 2
for our reference now let us get back to
the print sheet option so i'll use the
shortest method that is holding the
control key and press p
now you can see that here we have six
pages in total from the active sheets so
the current active sheet is
the top 250 sheet so this particular
sheet is the current active sheet so if
we print the entire data in this
particular sheet then we will end up
printing six pages
now let us select the other option where
you have to print the entire workbook
right so now you can see that there's
the change in the number that is 12
pages so what is a workbook so basically
workbook is the collection of entire
sheets in your excel homepage so in this
particular excel homepage you have the
first sheet that is top 250 and the
second sheet that is the restaurant
sheet 2 right so the combination of
these two sheets make up a workbook
so when you select the entire workbook
option you will have 12 pages so that's
how we use this setting where you select
the active sheets the entire workbook
and there is another option where you
can only print a selected item
so if you want to do this then let's get
back here now
what if your customer or what if your
client wanted the top 10 restaurants
only so you can select the top 10
restaurants
by
doing this
now you have the top 10 restaurants
let's go to print
so you can see excel has automatically
selected the selection only print the
selected content only so you can see we
have only the top 10 restaurants or top
11 restaurants that we have selected in
our sheet and it is ready to get printed
so this is how we use the first option
now let's get back
let's not select that and let's make the
pages normal now get back to the print
option again
now you can see the next option that is
collated
right so in collated you have different
different options that is one two three
one two three and one two three and the
next one which is uncollated one one one
two two two three three three so why are
these numbers present here and what does
correlated mean anyway
so this is your question right now the
answer for this question will be a
little
similar to your examination hall okay
let us imagine that you are an
examination hall and you are the
invigilator and you have 10 students in
your room
so you wanted to provide question papers
to all the 10 students
okay so you have your question paper
distributed into three sheets that is
you have marked questions and your
questions are fit into three papers
right in this scenario we have 250 rows
and all the data is split into 6 sheets
that is sheet 1 or page 1 page 2 page 3
page 4 right now if we wanted to print
10 copies
then the arrangement of papers will be
page 1 page 2 page 3 page 4
page 5 page 6 in continuous order
right that is collated if you wanted 10
copies of different different ways where
you wanted to print the first sheet
first then you wanted to print the
second sheet second and the third sheet
third that is you'll have 10 copies of
first page 10 copies of second page 10
copies of third page and so on that
particular approach is called uncollated
approach and if you're printing the
pages in continuous order for 10 times
then that particular approach is called
as collated approach so this is what we
had to learn about collated and
uncollated now let's get back to the
third option
now let's press again print now we have
our data over here
there's something wrong
select all the elements control p
yeah now we have our data pack now we
have the third option that is the
portrait orientation
okay so when we click that we have two
options that is portrait and landscape
so you might be having a good idea like
when you try to click a picture in your
phone we have two modes as well that is
portrait mode and the landscape mode so
when you click on the portrait mode this
is how your data will be looking
now to understand the difference
let's click the landscape mode so when
you click the landscape mode this is how
your data representation will change
you'll have a wider page to print so
this is why we use the page orientation
for now let's keep the page orientation
as portrait orientation
and we have now the fourth option so
what is the fourth option we have
various sets of options in here that is
letter and a4 size there are also some
more page options over here where you
can select
the page types you want to print
so basically you'll be having few more
options that is a4 a5 a3 etc but here we
just have two that is a4 and letter so
basically you'll get those options and
followed by that next we have margins so
here you can see we don't have any
margins for our data
okay so now we can add some margins by
setting up this one as an option like
last custom setting or you can also
choose normal wide narrow
right so your page will be changed
according to your margin size
right so this is how you can change the
margins now let's keep it as default
let's set the
normal one
now we have the next option that is
scaling option
so here you can see we are trying to fit
the page so when you are trying to print
these sheets using no scaling then the
actual size of the page will be printed
now you can also modify that you can fit
and print the sizes so you can remember
the first option that i said of printing
all the 250 rows in one single sheet
this is how you can fit it so fit the
sheet on one page where you can see all
the 250 rows are fit into one page but
the data is not readable so but we don't
want this type of an approach right so
let's keep it as the default one which
is no scaling so these are the variety
of options in print
now if you wanted to print the all the
six pages into the pdf format and mail
it to your client you can also do that i
think i have explained it in the first
place so you can see we can do it by
just selecting this option where you can
print all the
six
pages and into pdf format and then you
can mail them to your client
and you can also select the number of
copies you want you can increase the
copies to 2 3 and any number of
copies you want for now i'll keep it as
one copy
[Music]
now let's print this
now let us select the
location
rename it and publish
now let's get back to documents and see
if the page is printed or not
here you go here we have the restaurant
data in the form of pdf
so we have our entire six pages of data
in the pdf format
now we are back on the home page now we
had some limited functions in the print
functions over here
we have tried to export the data so you
can also export the data or try to print
it from the print option over here you
can just select that as well
yes the pages are printed now
there you go we have the restaurant to
ptf data
so that's how you can print all your
data you can either choose
the export option or you can either
choose print option
now when you see into the print option
we have limited number of paid setup
options over here
now let's check out what we missed
so we are in the page layout here so we
had gone through the margins we had set
all the margins and then we have also
gone through the portrait and landscape
now you can see this size when we were
in the print menu option we had only a4
and letter but here you can see there
are a wide variety of options that is
other than letter we have tabloid legal
statement executive a3
right we have a5 and many more other
options and if you want some more paper
options you can go to more and you can
always select few more options that's
how you do it
and yeah we didn't had the break option
so remember when we had been through the
print option we did not have the break
option there
let's select this to normal a4 so you
cannot see the break option over here
right so here we have the break option
so what does break option does
right you can actually break the page
remember we spoke about the top 10
things or the top 10 rules you can
always do that so you can just keep the
top 10 restaurants in your first page
and then break the remaining after set
page breaks you can select the cell now
i need the top 10 so i'll select this
particular cell which is in the 11th
position
and now i'll try to implement the page
break insert a page break and now you
can see on my sheet there is a thin line
which is separating the two pages that's
how you can see the indication of a page
break implemented onto your page now how
do you say it you can see it by
selecting control p where you can see
the first top 10
restaurants being printed on your sheet
so there you go we have the first top 10
restaurants printed on our sheets so
that's how you use the page break
now let's try to eliminate all the page
breaks so you can select
breaks and reset all page tricks so the
page break has been eliminated
now you can always choose a background
for your data as well you just
if you want you can add a picture to
your background i think that's not
available for now
okay you can work offline as well
let us select this one
so you can see that we have added a
background to our data
we can select all the
text files and then we can change the
color so that the text becomes a little
visible
yeah that's how you do it now if you
don't want the image to be added on your
file you can also remove that delete
page background and there you go all the
images are gone
now the next important part that is the
print titles
now why do we need print titles for that
let's try to print this
so now you can see the first page in the
first page we have the title rank
restaurant sales segment category but if
you go to the second page you don't have
that title right you don't have the
title rank name of the restaurant sales
and their service category so if we want
that then we need to add titles
now for that let's select the print
titles option
now let's select the rows to repeat on
top
now for that we need the first row
select the first row and this particular
row will be repeating into all the pages
now let's try to print it so yeah now
you can see the titles are being added
to all the sheets you can see the page 2
page 3 page 4 page 5 and page 6. so you
can see the titles added to all the
sheets
so that's how you use the print titles
option
so now we are on the excel sheet and you
can see that in this particular excel
sheet we have some student details we
have the serial numbers names row
numbers class blood group and some
subjects like math science computer
statistics social gk and the final marks
obtained percentage and total marks
right
so let us imagine that
a company has come for an interview
so all these students are going to
attend an interview and the minimum
percentage to attend the interview will
be like 75 percent so you can see that
we have 75 here and all the students
have got above 75 except for the one
student which is mike
right so for mike to attend the
interview he needs 75 percentage or apa
so
he can make some modifications in one of
these subjects right so there is always
an exam after the exam called as
improvement exam so if you can
like to score some extra marks in the
subjects which you have scored less so
that you can make up to the percentage
what you're expecting you can do that so
here in this particular sheet
mike has six subjects right and in six
subjects you can see he has scored 76 91
45 71
94 and 62. so out of these he have
scored less than one subject
compared to all the subjects one subject
is really low that is computers
so
what if he can give an improvement exam
and increase his percentage to 75 right
so that can be done
so if we can do some brute force methods
like we can change the marks like 55 and
then check this particular one so it's
getting 74 right so using the brute
force method will be a little bit
lengthy
so
you can do this because it is just a
small table which has least number of
data and you just have one single cell
to modify so that can be done in small
tables but what if you had some table
with hundreds of rows or thousands of
rows that will be time consuming right
so for that we have some
inbuilt functionality in excel that is
called
goal seek in excel
so for now let's eliminate the marks
here
so we have eliminated the marks and the
upgraded percentage is 65 now we need
the target as 75
okay so let's
write it as
mike's target right we need mike so
mike's
new target as
[Music]
okay
now to make sure that we need a mark
here which can get mic to 75 percentage
we will use the data operation so here
on the toolbar which has file
home
insert etc we have one other option
called as data so when you click on data
from toolbar you'll have this ribbon and
in this ribbon we have various options
so when you come into forecast group we
have an option called what if analysis
when you click on what-if analysis
you'll have a set of options out of
which we have goal seek
now for goal seek we need to select a
table cell that is this particular table
cell that is m9
so we need the value 75 here right so
what is the cell that you need to change
here for that you need to select this
one and select this particular cell here
right and now you can select ok
now you can see that excel has
automatically run all the permutations
and combinations and has come up with a
number so that the overall percentage of
mic will be 75 percent right so the
expected marks that
mike should be getting in his computer's
improvement exam should be equal to 56
or greater than 56 to get the final
target as 75 so that he can attend the
company's interview so this is how we
use goal set or goal seek in excel
now let's quickly get on to the
practical mode where we will have some
data sets over which we will be trying
to apply the charts
now there are various types of charts in
w and those are the pie chart the column
chart the bar chart column versus line
pivot chart and sparkline charts so we
will discuss one after the other first
let us discuss about the pie chart
so as you can see we have a small data
set on my screen which i have personally
created and
this deals with the companies and this
deals with the shares of the automobile
industry so now for this let's create a
pie chart
select all the data and then get into
the toolbar and inside the toolbar you
can see various options and inside that
we're gonna use the insert option
and when you select the insert option
you will have a ribbon here and inside
the ribbon you can see groups tables
illustrations add-ins and here you go
these are the charts so now we needed a
pie chart so select on that icon and you
have various types of pie charts you
have two dimensional pie charts three
dimensional pie charts donut type of
charts etc right so i would like to go
with the three-dimensional pie chart as
it looks a little more appealing and
easy to understand
and now there you go this is the title
of the chart and these are the legends
of the chart and this is the chart area
and these are the values
now we can you know kind of add the
data labels as well so you can just have
to press the
plus icon over here and you'll have the
options you can add the data labels
which will give you a lot more
interesting values
and
you can also turn this around
as you can see we on double clicking any
part of the pie chart you'll get this
option which is called as format data
point and
let's imagine that you wanted to show
the information related to
this particular one which is a volvo
which has the biggest share so this is
in front right now now what if you
wanted to show the information related
to tata which is over here right for
that you can select this particular
arrow key and you can just twist it and
there you go it is coming in front
this will be a great way of presenting
your data to your clients right
yeah
and there is another option where you
can
directly explore this like you can pick
it out you can see this right point
explosion where you can split it out and
you can show that especially like you
can highlight it and show it so that's
the you know a great way of presenting
your data so that's how you can work
with pie charts in excel now let's
quickly move to the next one that is the
column chart
and in the column chart we have the data
related to some company and the profits
of that company based on a year so you
can see that the year has started from
2008 and it has gone until 2021 and
these are the profits of that company
year after year so since we are dealing
with column chart i'll tell you the
simplest way to create a column chat
there is a shortcut key for that
which is alt f1 and there you go you
have the chart right on your screen
now you can expand the chart just by
dragging it like that and
you can see that there is some problem
with this chart that is we have numbers
here instead of years right you can see
that the first column is the years which
is 2008 to 2021 but here you can see we
have one two three four which is not
proper right
so to change the
axis that is you can see the axis which
is one two three four from one two three
four to the years 2008 2009 2010 11 etc
you just have to make one change here
and also you can see i have pressed the
plus icon over here which will open
the option where you can
include the access titles
if you have and data labels everything
right so for now i think i'll keep it as
it is so you can include the data table
as well as it is here and you can
include that in the chart there are
various options that excel provides you
so now let's focus on changing the
access from one two three four to the
years for that you need to select the
chart design and inside the chat design
you have an option called select data
press that and here you have various set
of options you can see profits you can
see years now we'll select years and we
will remove that
and now you can see the edit option here
right
select that and now
it will ask you which
column to be selected for the access
range for that let's select this and now
let's select the ears here
and
press ok
and there you go
again press ok
so there you go you have the ears over
here instead of the numbers which you
had in the first place
so that's how you create the column
chart and we have the next type of chart
which is really simple
now you know you kind of change this
chart directly into bar chart there is
no big deal in that
so uh
for that you just need to select the
change chart type option over here
you're just changing the chart type and
you can get the paragraph over here
column and bar graphs are completely
same to each other only that you can see
these
uh bars in the horizontal way rather
than in the vertical wave and let's do
that
let's not create a new thing for that so
yeah there you go when you select the
change chart type option you have
various set of chart type options on the
menu bar over here so what we needed was
the bar chart now let's select that and
there you go
let's select okay and you have the bar
chart
right and you if you want you can
include the data labels which look a
little bit more interesting you can also
include the data table as well
okay for now i think we have to expand
the chart to get the clear view
yeah that's how you do it
right now let's move into the next type
of one yeah we dealt with the bar chart
so we'll directly enter into the column
versus line chart
so we have similar kind of data we just
had year and profits in the previous
part now we also have included the
expenses right we needed another column
to showcase the line chart compared to
the columns right so for that i've
included a new column that is expenses
all as well
now just let's select the data
and let's select the option
alt f1 to create our chart
right now automatically uh excel has
provided us the column chat we have the
columns of expenses we have the column
of profits and we also have years now
let's change the data as we did before
select uh here and remove it and then
edit
select edit and select the year
that is from here to
2021
select okay and we have the ears over
here
now what we needed to do is
change the chart type
right select the change chart type
option and since we wanted to create a
column versus line chart it is a
combination whenever you want
one or two types of charts included in
one single chart window then it has a
combo option so here we need to select
the comp option and inside that we have
various types of combination charts we
have clustered column we have clustered
line on secondary axis we have clustered
stat areas clustered column and the
other one is custom combination so let's
go with the first one that is clustered
line
let's select that and there you go we
have the line graph with the column so
that's how we create the column versus
line and if you want you can include the
data labels and you can include the data
table as well yeah
okay i think we need to expand the
canvas a little more to get a clear view
yeah
so you have legends over here you have
the data labels and accesses everything
and chart title you can always change
the chat title so for now let's uh
rename it as
profits versus
expenses
yeah that's that's how it goes
done okay i think i made a spelling
mistake here
yeah it's clear now
now the next type of chart we're going
to deal with is the pivot chart
so
we have dealt with pie chart column
chart bar chart and column versus line
now pivot chart is a little bit
different it's like you're going to
create some active chart which responds
to the variations you're making to your
data so to understand that better let's
create a practical chart over here
and select all the data
okay
yeah i have selected the data
now
to create a pivot chart
let's select
the insert option from the toolbar and
inside the ribbon we have charts group
and inside that we have pivot chart
now let's select the preview chart
option
and there you go
now it's asking for range and we have
selected the range over there
and
we are not going to create a new
worksheet for the entire chart we are
going to create the
uh chart inside the existing worksheet
itself so for that let's select the
area where we want to select the uh
chart to be present now for that let's
select this and
yeah select okay
okay there is some error
let's cancel this and try again
let's select the data
and preview chat again
we have selected the
range
here
that's how you select the range
and now select the position where you
want to create it existing worksheet we
have selected that and press ok yeah
that's that's the way we've got our
preview chart over here and you can see
our pivot chart is completely blank
right
now it will respond to the changes you
make to your pivot chart for now we have
serial numbers and uh these are the
names of the
guys who have
okay so these are the names of the guys
who who have some dealerships for
various car makes such as ford ferrari
honda kia alfa romeo bmw etc etc
so uh we're gonna exchange or we're
gonna see
you know we're gonna make some charts of
the persons who own the cars
or the car brands or dealerships in
various regions so we're gonna work on
that now let's drag in the name
and uh
let's drag region
and
cards
and the units
yep
so we have our
chart over here column chart which has
the different different names and
the dealerships and sum of cars over
there right so you can see that we can
also change some values over here what
if we wanted to know only
uh the details regarding jennifer you
can do that you can unselect everything
and you can just select jennifer and
press ok now you'll have the details of
only jennifer of having the car brands
so we have the regions as well so
jennifer owns dealerships in two
different regions that is south and west
and the sum of units and count of cars
as well
so that's how the preview charts are
used in real time
and now let's select sales and drag the
sales as well
yeah it's been dragged and you have the
sales of
jennifer
the details of her sales
and let's move the chart a little bit
and you have the plus icon where you can
include the data labels for a better
information
yeah so that's how you use the previous
charts
so we are on the last type of charts
which is the sparkline chart now to
create a sparkline chart we need to get
into the insert option and inside we
have the ribbon and inside the ribbon we
have the group that is sparklines
now
to generate a sparkline chart we need to
select this particular column and then
select the
type of sparkline you want to create now
let's create the column type of
sparkline chart
yep
we have to
club these
cells together first we forgot that
because we're gonna insert the sparkline
chart right above here
now for that
let's merge the cells
[Music]
yeah
so we wanted to create the
spark line chart of column type and now
it's asking for the location where we
want to create this part line chart so
this is the location now let's select
okay
and there you go we have the sparkline
chart right over here
now you can see that we have a negative
point here so if you want we can change
that from negative to positive
and it will automatically update that
and if you want to add the access to
this particular chart you can select the
options part line
and there you go you have certain
options like high point low point
and if you wanted to add some margin you
can also do that
and data type access and there you have
the access
show access yeah you have the access now
and you can have the high point and low
point for that as well which is the you
know the biggest change and the smallest
change in this particular
segment that is few furniture yeah
furniture had the highest sales in
january and homer plans had the lowest
sale and you can also change the color
and uh let's type of change
the color again yeah we have a different
color over here which resembles a little
bit more better or you can also go with
this one
and if you wanted to add the same to all
these tables you can do that just by
dragging it
and you have it for all the six months
now if you wanted to add some new data
in this row
or you wanted to add a new complete row
then you can do that as well and change
that and bring that change implemented
in these charts as well
now let us try to add a new row here
which includes the miscellaneous
we have that data right over here let's
select that
copy and
let's paste it over here
so there you go we have the extra row
here
so yeah now we have added the
miscellaneous row and right now we have
the sparkline chart for only four
columns or four rows that is furniture
technology home appliances and office
needs and miscellaneous is missing now
to add that as well let's select
sparkline
and inside sparkline just select edit
group location and data
and now let's select the entire data
and now select okay
there's something wrong
again
spotlight
edit data
select range
this should be helping
yeah there you go we have all the five
rows now including furniture technology
home appliances office needs and
miscellaneous
so conditional formatting is a method to
visualize your worksheet we already have
the charts in excel to visualize our
excel sheets in graphical form but what
if you had to see or visualize the data
in your worksheet as it is so that is
where the condition formatting comes
handy now let's get back to the
microsoft excel and try to implement
some conditional formatting
now we are on the excel worksheet this
particular data set is based on a store
now we have various columns in this
particular data set we have row id order
id customer name etc and finally we have
quantity discount and profits
now let's go to profits
uh let us imagine that we have provided
this particular store with a target of
minimum 15 percent profits now let us
find out the stocks that have hit the 15
percent target and the ones which did
not so for that let us select the entire
column
now you can find the conditional
formatting option in the home toolbar
and in that ribbon the ribbon with
styles has the condition formatting
option click on that
and you have various options over here
highlighting the cells top bottom rules
data bars data scales and icons so data
bars are actually the bar graphs which
highlight themselves on each and every
cell if you implement them and these are
the color scales if you want to
implement some colors you can go through
that and if you want to represent
yourselves with icons you can also do
that for now let's highlight the cells
so select that and inside this select
the greater than option and here you can
provide the percentage
that is 15 percent
and
the cells or the stores which hit the
target should be highlighted with the
green color
and select okay and there you go you
have your stores that hit the 15 target
and the ones which did not hit the 15
target now if we want to highlight the
ones which did not hit the 15 percent
target you can
highlight them with the color red
so
conditional formatting highlight the
cells
less than 15 percent
with color red and text dark
and there you go it's done
now let us consider another example so
this particular example is based on
train data set and here we have the
passenger id survived passenger class
name etc now we have a train accident
incident over here now one is indicated
that they are alive and zero is
indicated that they are not alive
now let us use this column and
conditional formatting highlight the
cells
containing the text as one
with color
green
okay
and
highlight the cells
that contain text 0 as the red that
indicates they are not alive
and let us select the icons
now we have the icons over here the x
indicates that they are not alive and
the green tick mark indicates that they
are alive
now that is how you use conditional
formatting in excel
so what is data validation in excel
so it is a feature by microsoft excel
where it can restrict data entry into
certain cells by using data validation
and it will prompt the users to enter
valid data in the cells based on the
rules and restrictions provided by the
creator of that particular sheet now
this would be a little confusing to
understand so to understand it in a much
better way let's get back to the
practical way where we will start
entering some data validation rules to
our excel sheet and try to enter data
into it now we are on the microsoft
excel and this particular sheet is based
on employee id employee name employee
department employee salary fiscal year
and work timings of the employees
now we will be applying some data
validation rules to each and every
column and try to enter data based on
the rows we have entered now for the
first one which is the employee id we'll
enter rules based on the employee id
number so to apply the data validation
you need to go into the data tab on the
toolbar
and inside the ribbon you can see data
tools group and in the data tools group
you have the option of data validation
now select the entire column
go to the
data tools group select data validation
option and you will have this particular
pop-up menu
and here you can see different types of
options
so since we are entering employee id it
would be a whole number so let us select
whole number option
and now here you can see the option of
between not equal to equal to not
between greater than less than etcetera
so let us select between
and
let us assume that your employee id has
five numbers and
it should be between 10 000 to eleven
thousand
so let us provide ten thousand
and eleven thousand
now select ok
and now the new rule has been applied
so now the minimum value of each and
every employee id should be equal to or
more than 10 000 and less than 11 000
and it should have five digits
now let's try to enter a wrong employee
id that is just one
there you go you can see that microsoft
excel is not allowing you to include a
wrong number
it says this value does not match the
data validation restrictions defined for
this cell so now you can press retry and
try to enter some number which is in
between 10 000 to 11 000.
now it is ten thousand nine hundred and
one and this will take the entry
now let us assume that
because i am the creator of this [ __ ] i
know what should be entered here but
what if i give this sheet to you and you
are the person who is trying to enter
the number and it shows the error and
you don't know what was the error
right to avoid this kind of confusion
what you can do is you can do some ways
where you can provide the message to the
user so that can be done by
okay let's select the sheet again
and go to the data validation and here
you have the same settings now here you
have another option saying input message
so before input message let us go to
error alert
now here
the error title would be
data entered
is
not valid
please enter this is the error message
please enter
emp id
between
10 000
to 11 000
press ok
now when you try to enter
the wrong number
it will show that particular error alert
message
see data entered is not valid please
enter employee id between 10 000 to 11
000.
now this is fine but
how long this will be you know what if
there is an option where you just hover
over to this cell and it automatically
tells you to enter the value between 10
000 to 11 000 without having to face the
error yeah even that can be done so you
can select
the entire column and go to data
validation and here this is the input
message this is where you can do that
so
here you can write the message name
valid data
please enter
data
between
10 000
to 11 000
now when you hover over to any cell in
this particular column it will
automatically show you this message
where you can avoid all the errors
just select ok see
when you select any cell in this
particular column it will automatically
tell you please enter data between ten
thousand to eleven thousand so here you
don't have to face any errors right now
let us try to enter the valid data
one zero
nine
0 2
and it will take it as the correct value
and again 1 0
9 0 3
now in case if you try to provide the
wrong number it will show the error
see
so that's how it is now we have finished
the whole number part now let's get into
the employee name where we have to
provide
the second type that is
text length
now let us imagine that uh
in your company you're trying to provide
id cards to your employees and you know
that id card is really small and inside
that id card you need to include the
employee photograph and your company
name employee id blood group phone
number address everything and also you
need to include the name of the employee
so what if there is an employer with
very lengthy name like 30 characters 40
characters yeah in india it is really
possible that you might have a lengthy
name so what you can do is you can
provide the text length where the text
is limited to like 15 or 20
characters so you can include that name
in the id card so you can do that by
allowing the data validation criteria
with text length
minimum can be anything so minimum can
be one and maximum here you can provide
15
and press ok
ok minimum will change it to at least
2
and
yeah let it be 1
so minimum is 1 and the maximum is 15
characters and press ok
and
let us also provide the input message
enter
character type character data
please enter valid name
and error alert
invalid data
please enter validator
okay please enter characters
less than
50
press okay
now let us try to enter a random name
okay
we'll enter characters more than 15 here
quality
yeah it's like 1 2 3 4 5
11.
okay now this is more than 15
okay i think it's not more than 15 let's
try to enter a little bit more
characters
yeah
now we have entered more than 15
characters and it is showing please
enter characters less than 15 so now we
can retry and try to enter some valid
mean
now we have characters less than 50 so
it will take as the property
now let us try to enter another name
i am just entering some random data
so another name may be
great
now the next type of data validation is
also done now let us get into employee
department employer department is
something really superb so i'll tell you
about it it's actually a list now
let us finish the
other ones first that is employee salary
fiscal year and work timings after that
we'll learn about
the list one
now let's come into employee salary so
salary is something where you have to
include decimal points so now let us go
to
data validation and inside the values we
have already dealt with whole number
uh text length
yeah now we'll deal with employee salary
that is decimal
now minimum is okay what is that a
minimum can be one
point zero zero
and maximum can be
one lakh
point zero zero or let us
put that as 10 lakhs
press ok
ok not not just them
enter valid
salary
okay now let's change it to minimum as
ten thousand
so the employee minimum salary will be
ten 000 and input enter valid salary
and
salary
between
10 000.
to 10 lakhs
let us include a comma here too
now error alert
invalid salary
please enter
between
10 000
to
10 lakhs
press ok
now
the
message
and the data validation conditions are
applied to this column now let us try to
enter some invalid data first
it will show the error
now we need to enter the valid data
yeah now it is taking the valid data let
us provide 20 000
and this has 35 000.
now the next one is fiscally let us
imagine that we wanted to you know work
on the employees for current working
year that is 2020 to 2021
and or you can consider 2021 to 2022.
not more than 2021 and not less than
2021 for that you can provide the year
option as well so for that you need to
select the entire column go to data
validation settings and inside here you
have an option of date
so
let us provide the date option as
between and start date is 0 1
0 1
20 21
and end date is
0 1
0 1 slash
2022
and input message
let us provide data as current
fiscal year
current financial year
enter date
between
2021 to
2022 let us copy this and go into error
alert
error message will be seen
invalid
[Music]
select ok
now the error message and
the data input message and the data
validation rule has been applied for
this column so let's try to enter some
date here
you can enter
0 2
of february
20 21
it will take as the correct data now
let's try to enter some wrong data which
is apart from 2022 0 2
0 2
20
22 it will not take this it will throw
error
so that's how it works now let us try to
enter
as 2021
and this is merge
it will take it
now another data
zero 4 this time and 20 21
so that's how your
date data validation will work now
coming into the next type of data
validation that is time
so we have time here let us imagine that
you are providing some
work timings to your employees that
should be from 9 am to
5 pm not more than that so you want to
keep your work life balance for all your
employees so you just want them to work
between 9 to 5 and that should be fine
and anything apart from that time should
be invalid so you can do that by
selecting the time option
between it should be in between and the
start time will be
0 9
0 0
and this should be
17
that is 5 p.m in the evening
and input message
please enter
time
between
9 00 am
to
5 p.m
this should be the
input message
now error alert
invalid time
error message
now
okay
work timings now
this should be okay
we can do this as two columns actually
let us
cancel
let us copy this and paste it here
you can do it as login
timing and this should be okay
this should be a log out
so this should be
okay so this will be considered as login
and log out times
now let us provide the login time
this should be the right time and
let's try to provide wrong timings
0 8 now it will not take it it will
throw as error
so it's working fine let us provide 10
now let us provide the log out time it
should be
below 5 pm
so let us provide 5 it will take it
ok
let's try to provide something just 1
minute less than 5.
59
okay
there is some problem in this let's
check it
okay it is taking
three that is including seconds
okay let's provide seconds as well
zero five zero zero zero zero
okay still there is some problem
[Music]
okay we have entered four we should we
are supposed to enter 24 hour timing
right
14
okay uh it should be 17 i think this
will work yeah
now we are following 24 hour timing here
so let's provide another timing that is
16
30 0 0 this will be valid and
15 30
yes this is also valid now we have
finished almost all types of uh data
validation things that is we have
finished with any value whole number
decimal date timing test length and the
last one is list so this is where things
get interesting now let's cancel this
now
select the employee caller now if you're
running a company then definitely you'll
not have only one department in it you
might have multiple departments right so
let us consider that you have a software
development company
so in that the basic departments will be
software development team and software
testing team
so
what you can do is you can provide a
list
so using that list you can just
hover over to that cell select the drop
down menu
and inside that you can select the
option so we will try to work something
like that if we have selected the entire
column
selection okay
yeah let us select the entire column
again go to data validation
the selection contains some cells
without data validation settings do you
want to extend it a validation to this
yes
now let us provide the list option
and
[Music]
here source you can provide as
developer and tester
press okay okay
now input message
select one
select one
error alert
invalid
data
select from drop down
only
press ok
now when you select the cell you can see
small drop down icon right so when you
press it you will have developer and
tester option
so you can select developer for first
one and for second one you can select
tester
right okay this is good for
one or two options maybe three or even
maybe like five but what if you have
more departments okay let's go to this
uh second sheet where we have the
department data so here we have like 14
departments no 15 departments or 15
employee type names so the first one is
ceo second base developer tester quality
analyst system analyst finance human
resource so so many options are there so
you cannot keep on typing all of them
right so here it is 15 what if you have
like 25 like 50 departments right it
will be tough so for this you have
another option so
let me select all this data and copy
this from this sheet to our employee
sheet
let us paste it somewhere
here
let's expand this
okay now we have our
list over here
now let us remove the data validation
from this column
clear all
okay now everything is clear
let's select ok now let us erase this
data as well
now let us apply the list data
validation again from scratch go to list
now here we can select the
source
select this particular cell
and drag it
until here
and it has been loaded
now
go to input message
data options
select one
from the menu or the drop down
copy
error alert
select only from the drop down menu
invalid entry
yeah
now let's select okay
fine
now you have the icon here you have all
the provided options
you can scroll down and select any one
of these you can select knowledge
transfer for the first one
and second one would be
system analyst
and the last one would be
human resources
now in the list everything is fine okay
this is showing you the menu options and
everything so but what if you provide
this sheet to your new joiner or new
employee in your company and by mistake
he messes up something like deleting
this
okay so we have deleted systems analyst
and when you click on the options here
you don't have systems analyst in that
place you have blank space right so
there is a way where all your
you know data can be messed up so to
avoid this what you can do is
you can actually
save this data in a different sheet like
i did here like department data
you can hide the sheet or you can
protect the sheet with password or
something so that nobody can mess this
up so now let us get back to the
employee data and select this column and
[Music]
clear everything
press ok
and let us also clear this
and this as well in this one too
now let us eliminate the
rows ourselves
we employ
everything okay now we have basically
removed this data from here
now let us try to apply the data
validation once again
now here
let us select as list
and
here let us provide the option
let us go to next sheet let us select
all these options
and press ok
okay let's provide input message
data options
are department options
yeah
now let's select ok
now let's hide this sheet
now the sheet has been hidden
and you still have the options
developer
or let us provide ceo
then we have developer
then we have
test so that's how you can protect your
sheets as well
now this is how you apply data
validation in your excel
what is excel vlookup
vlookup stands for vertical lookup
vlookup lets you search for specific
information in your spreadsheet
it allows you to search for a particular
value in a column and returns another
value from a different column but of the
same row
vlookup takes advantage of vertically
aligned tables to quickly find data
associated with the value the user
enters
now
let's look at the syntax to write a
vlookup function so vlookup takes four
parameters or arguments you can see it
here there are
four arguments in the velcro function
so the first argument is called the
lookup value
the lookup value represents
the value that you are searching for
next is the table array the table array
represents two or more columns of
information the third argument is called
the column index number
now this represents the column number in
the table from which the value must be
returned the first column is 1 the
second column is 2 and so on and then
we have the fourth parameter which is
called the range lookup now this
parameter is optional now range lookup
is used to find an exact match
so if you want to find an exact match
you need to enter false or 0
meanwhile if you want an approximate
match you need to enter true or one if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now let me give you a brief overview on
what's going to be in our demo
so for our demonstration
we'll use a sales data set you can see
the data set on the left
using this data set we'll understand how
vlookup performs an exact and
approximate match we'll see how vlookup
is case insensitive
then we'll perform a wildcard character
search
we'll understand how to handle errors
when a match is not found
and finally
you will look at two way lookups
now here is a small example of how
vlookup works
so we want to find the units sold by
morgan using the data set on the left
so here you can see i have the data set
it has
some rows and columns so these are the
columns which are order date
region there's a representative column
item units this unit cost and total
and from this table i want to find the
units that were sold by morgan if you
look at the table at the bottom you can
see the representative name morgan
and morgan has sold 30 units
now i want to find this value using the
vlookup function
so here on the right you can see i have
my lookup value which is morgan and this
is my vlookup formula
and using this formula i am getting the
result as 30. now let's go to our excel
workbook and perform all the demos one
by one so this is my excel workbook that
we are going to use for our demo
and here is the data set we'll be using
now this is the same data set that you
saw a while ago
so this data set has seven columns you
have the order date the region
representative's name item there's units
unit cost and total which is basically
the total or the amount of sales that
was generated
now we are going to use a chunk of this
data set
and perform our vlookup analysis
so let's see our first example and the
problem we have at hand
let me go to the exact match tab
all right
so here
i'm going to use this chunk of data
which is actually taken from the
original data set so we have taken the
first
11 rows from the data set you can see
from row 2
till row 12
is going to be our data set that we'll
use
so we have a question here
we want to find the items sold by
thomson
so here
thomson is my lookup value which means
looking at thomson i want to find the
item that is sold
so if you consider our table here you
can see we have the representative's
name thomson
right here
and
from the table you can see thomson sold
pencil
and i want to get this value which is
pencil using my vlookup function
so let's go ahead and write our vlookup
function
i'll consider this as my lookup value
and here under item i'm going to write
my vlookup formula
to write the vlookup formula i'll write
first equal to
and
i'll write vlookup now if i hit tab it
will auto complete
all right now let's
give the parameters so first is going to
be the lookup value which is nothing but
thomson so i'll just select this cell
which is j17
comma
now it's asking to give the table array
so the table array is the table from
which you want to retrieve a value one
thing to keep in mind is that the value
you are looking for should be the first
column of a table
and
you can select the table array till the
end of the data set or till the column
which has the value you want to find
so here i'll select my table array
starting from the representatives column
till
the end of the item column
which is going to be my table array
then i'll select the column index number
so the column index number is based on
the table array you have selected in
this case my column index number is
going to be 2 because we have selected
just two columns and the value which i
am going to find is in the second column
so i will give 2
comma
now the range lookup i am going to give
is false because i want to find an exact
match so either you can hit tab
or you can write 0 which means false
if i close the bracket and hit enter
it will return me the item that thompson
had sold which is pencil you can verify
from the table that thompson had sold
pencil
all right
now let's try to change the table array
and see what result are we getting so
this time i'll slightly change the table
array so again we are trying to find the
item that thompson had sold
so i'll write my formula equal to
vlookup i'll hit tab to autocomplete
i'll give my lookup value as thomson
comma
this time i'm choosing my table array
starting from the representatives column
till
the end of the data set which is
till p12
again my column index number is going to
be 2 because
if you consider this table array the
item column is the second column in the
selected table array so i am going to
write it as 2
comma
the range lookup i want to give as false
because i want to find the exact match
if i close this and hit enter you can
see it has returned me the same result
that we saw earlier
now suppose
let's say this time i want to start my
table array from the region column which
is this column
so i want to select my table array
starting from the region column now this
is going to show me an error because
your table array should always start
from the lookup value column so if you
consider thomson as the lookup value
my table array should always start from
the representatives column so let's just
try this example
so i'll write vlookup
my lookup value i'm going to give it as
thomson comma
the table array as i mentioned earlier
i'm going to choose from the region
column
and let's say i'll select till the item
column give another comma and this time
my column index number is going to be 3
because
since
the table array has three columns and my
item column is the last column so i'm
going to give my column index number is
3
comma i want to get the exact match so
i'll give 0 if i close the bracket and
hit enter you can see it has given me
an error
ok
now let me just show you another method
to use vlookup in excel
so here on the top you can see there's a
formulas tab
and under formulas tab under function
library you see
we have an option to select lookup and
reference if i click on this and if i
scroll down below you can see there's an
option
called vlookup
let's choose this
all right now here
you can give
your lookup value your table array
column index number and the range lookup
under this function arguments dialog box
so here i want to select my lookup value
as
thomson my table array is going to be
from the representatives column till
let's say the end of the data set
the column index number is going to be 2
i'll write 2
and range lookup
i'll write as false because i want the
exact match
if i hit ok you can see
it has given us the exact same result so
this is one of the other ways to use
vlookup in excel now
let's move to the next sheet which is
regarding approximate match
okay so sometimes you might have cases
where you don't have the lookup value
present in the table in those cases you
can tell vlookup to return an
approximate match
now one thing to keep in mind is that
your lookup value column should always
be sorted in ascending order while
trying to get an approximate match so
here we are going to use this table
and
my lookup value column which is going to
be the representatives column is already
sorted in ascending order
and let's see the question we have here
so i want to find the item sold and the
unit cost for mat
so my lookup value is going to be mat
now if you see this table
i don't have the representative's name
matt anywhere in the table now using an
approximate match i want to find the
item and the unit cost so let's do it
so here under item i'll write my vlookup
formula
so i'll type vlookup i'll hit tab to
complete it
and this time my lookup value is going
to be matte so i'll select this cell
comma
my table array i'll select
from the representatives column till
the end of
item column because i want to find the
item value format
i'll give a comma
my column index number
as per the table array is going to be 2.
comma
my range lookup this time i'm going to
give is true or 1
so i'll write 1
close the bracket
hit enter
all right it has written me binder was
the item sold by matt
now let's try to figure out why vlookup
returned binder as the item
now let's say you were asked to insert
the name matt to the representative
column in alphabetical order so where
would you place it
ideally you should place between qivel
and morgan
since this column is already sorted mat
should appear before morgan and after
kibel so in an approximate match vlookup
will consider the previous highest value
in this case the previous highest value
before matte is kibel
and hence
vlookup returned the corresponding item
purchased by kival which is binder now
similarly
if you wanted to find the unit cost for
mat
again
vlookup will return
the unit cost of kibel which is 125.
let's just try it out so i'll write
vlookup
my lookup value is mat comma
my table array for this time is going to
be from representatives column
till the unit cost column i'll consider
i'll give a comma
now the column index number as per the
table array is going to be four i'll
give another comma and this time
i'll double click true because i want an
approximate match where close the
bracket hit enter you can see it has
returned me 125 which is actually
kevel's unit cost okay
we have another question
and this time i want to find the units
sold by rob
now rob is going to be
my
lookup value
if you see the representatives column we
don't have rob
now let's see what vlookup is going to
return as the item for rob so i'll write
vlookup i'll give my lookup value as rob
comma my table array
is going to start from the
representatives column
i'll select till here i'll give a comma
my column index number is 2.
give another comma
i'll double click on true
so close the bracket hit enter you can
see vlookup has written me pen now let's
understand why vlookup returned pen for
rob
now if you are asked to insert the
representative's name rob
into this column so ideally rob would
appear somewhere between morgan and
sorvino because
since this is
sorted in ascending order rob is
actually greater than morgan and is less
than sorvino
so as you know
vlookup in an approximate match returns
the previous highest value which is
morgan here and the corresponding item
for morgan is pen and hence vlookup
returned pen for rob all right
now moving to the next sheet
which is another property of vlookup
which tells vlookup always looks to the
right this means that your lookup value
must always be on the left
and the value you are going to find out
should always be to the right of the
table now consider this scenario where
your lookup value is on the left in this
case
it is the representative's value and i
have taken sorvino for an example
and we want to find the order date for
sorvino
now if you consider this table your
lookup value which is so we know is
actually this column the representatives
column and we are going to find out the
order date
so your representative's name is on the
right of the table
and the value we are going to find out
is on the left of the table
now as per the property vlookup only
looks to the right
so if i use the vlookup function for
this example here
i'll write vlookup
i'll give my lookup value as
sorbino
comma
my table array i'll consider from the
order date because i want the order date
till
the representatives column
i'll give a comma and this time
my column index number is actually the
first column if i consider my table
array as the first three columns
selected
and my range lookup is going to be false
if i close the bracket hit enter it
returns me an error the reason is
vlookup always looks to the right and
this time the value we were trying to
find out was to the left of the table
now
if you consider
the opposite case suppose you have the
order date and you want to find the
representative's name you can do that
easily because your lookup value which
is the order date is on the left and
your representatives column is on the
right so let's just try this
i'll write vlookup my lookup value is
going to be sorvino's order date so i'll
select it from the table
i'll give a comma
my table array will start from the g
column
let's say i'll select the entire table
comma
and my column index number will be 3 if
you consider these
as my table array
comma my range lookup is 0. if i close
this hit enter you can see we have got
so we know corresponding to the order
date
all right now let's move to the next tab
now this tab says
vlookup returns only the first match so
we have a question at hand the question
is
find the units sold by
jardine
if you see this table
we have the representative's name jardin
twice you see here
and if you look down we have jardin here
as well
but the items sold by jardin at the
first instance is pencil
and at the second instance it's desk
now as per the property vlookup always
returns the first match now ideally when
we write the vlookup function and look
for the units sold by jardine
you will see
vlookup will return
36 instead of 3.
let's just try it out
i'll write the vlookup function
my lookup value is jardine
comma my table array
i'll select from the representatives
column till the end of
units column
i'll give a comma my column index number
based on the
table array is three i'll give another
comma now i want the exact match so i'll
select zero
close the bracket and hit enter
as you can see it returns me the first
match of jardine which is 36 so vlookup
did not consider the second
match
similarly
if you consider this table
we have jones repeated thrice so you
have zones here
we have zones
here for the second time and also we
have zones for the third time
and let's say
you want to find the unit cost for jones
so if i write the vlookup function
i'll consider my
lookup value as jones comma
my table array
i'll select from the representatives
column till the end of unit cost column
i'll give a comma
based on the table array my unit cost
column is at the fourth index so i'll
write four
comma the range lookup is zero
if i click on this
and hit enter you can see it here
vlookup has returned the first instance
of jones and it did not consider the
second and the third instance so our
unit cost
for jones is 1.99
because vlookup only returns the first
match
okay moving ahead to the next
example we have here is vlookup is case
insensitive
if you consider this table
i've added another
row in green
so if you see here i have a
representative name called gill which is
in proper case or
popularly known as sentence case
here
i have added
gil's name in
capital letters are all in upper case
so i want to find the total revenue
generated by gil the total revenue is
basically the total column
let's do it i'll write vlookup
my lookup value is gil which is actually
in upper case
i'll consider my table array from the
representatives column till the end of
total column or the sales column
based on this selection my column index
number is 5
comma the range lookup is false so i'll
just double click on false
close the bracket hit enter
you can see it here
our vlookup function has returned the
total as
539.73 which is actually
the value for this row so clearly
vlookup did not consider gil
which was present at the bottom of the
table in uppercase
so this shows that vlookup is clearly
case insensitive
all right
now moving to the next example
the vlookup function supports wildcards
which makes it possible to perform a
partial match on a lookup value
for instance you can use vlookup to
retrieve values from a table after
typing only part of a lookup value to
use wildcards with vlookup you must
specify the exact match by giving false
or 0 for the last argument that is range
lookup now we have a question here
i want to know how much sales did the
representative whose name starts with k
i make
now here sales represents the
total column actually
so i want to find out the person whose
name starts with ki
so if you consider the representative
column i have one representative whose
name starts with ki that is kival
so
using ki as my lookup value i want to
find the total so let me show you
how to use wildcard characters and find
the value using vlookup
so write my function vlookup
okay now in lookup value i'll give ki
after that
i'm going to write ampersand
followed by
double inverted commas
then i am going to write a star
and close the inverted comma
this means
the value starts with k i
am percent actually represents
concatenation
and star represents anything followed by
ki
so this is going to be my lookup value
in total
i'll give a comma
next
i'll select my table array starting from
the representatives column till the end
of total column because i want to find
the sales
i'll give another comma
my column index number based on the
table array we have selected is 5
comma
the range lookup is 0 because i want to
find an exact match
close the bracket hit enter you can see
it here
vlookup has returned me
999.5 which is actually kiwell's total
now there's another way to do it instead
of
selecting the cell in which we have the
lookup value i can directly
write it in the vlookup function
so i'll write the vlookup function
something like this
so my lookup value
i'll pass
ki within double inverted commas because
ki is a character value
so within double inverted commas i'm
writing ki
followed by amber scent which is for
concatenation
followed by
a star
within double inverted commas so this is
going to be my lookup values
this in total means anything that
appears after ki will be considered as
the lookup value
again the table array i'll select as
these rows and columns
comma my column index number would be 5
comma the range lookup is 0. if i close
the bracket hit enter you see we have
the same value so this is another method
or another way of using
vlookups
okay
now moving ahead let's explore another
feature of vlookup so if the vlookup
function cannot find a match it returns
a hash and a error now if you want you
can use the if any function to replace
the hash any error with a friendly
message so suppose
you want to find the region in which an
order was placed on 10th of may 2018.
now if the order date is not found i
want to return a message that is invalid
date
so
if you look at the order date
column we don't have any value for 10th
of may 2015. you can see these values we
don't have any value corresponding to
this date
so
if my vlookup function cannot find this
lookup value i'll return invalid date
so let me show you
how to write this
i'll type my vlookup function
i'll give my order date as 10th of may
2015
as my lookup value
and then
i'll consider my table array starting
from the order date column till the end
of
region column
i'll give another comma my column index
number would be 2 this time based on the
table array we have selected comma
i want an exact match
so i'll give 0 close the bracket and hit
enter
there you go it has written me an error
now i want to convert this error to a
friendly message saying invalid date so
let me show you how to do it i'll do it
here so to return a valid message
i'll use the if any function
and within ifinay function i'll give my
vlookup function
so let me type if na
i'll hit tab
now for the value parameter i'll use my
vlookup function so my lookup value is
going to be
the order date comma
my table array i'll select from the
order date column till the end of region
column
comma
my column index number is going to be 2
comma
my range lookup is 0
i'll close the bracket give another
comma
now if this expression results in an
error i want to display a message that
is invalid date
so i'll put invalid date within double
quotes
since it is
a text message
i close the bracket
hit enter
you can see
the result which is invalid date
now moving on to the final section of
the demo
we have two way lookup
now in the vlookup function
the column index parameter is normally
hard coded as a static number however
you can also create a dynamic column
index by using the match function to
locate the right column
and this technique allows you to create
a dynamic two-way lookup matching on
both rows and columns
now let me first show you how a
match function works so suppose i want
to find
the index where unit cost column is
present
so here i'll use the match function
i'll give my lookup value as the unit
cost column name
comma
suppose
i'll choose my lookup array starting
from representatives column till
the unit cost column comma i'll give my
match type as 0 for exact match
if i close the bracket hit enter it
returns me 4 because
my array was selected from the
representatives column till the unit
cost column and in this array
unit cost is at the fourth index
all right now using this idea let's
solve the following problem
i want to find
the cost of each item sold by morgan
so let's
write our vlookup formula
write vlookup
my lookup value is
j5 which has the
representative's name as morgan comma
my table array
i'll select from
c2
till
f12
i'll give a comma and this time
i know that my column index number is at
4
but i'll be using the match function to
find the same
so i'll write match
my lookup value is
unit cost comma
my lookup array
is from
c1 till
f1
comma my match type is zero
i close this bracket
give another comma
and i'll give my range lookup as zero
close the bracket hit enter you can see
for morgan the unit cost is 19.99 you
can verify from the table for morgan the
unit cost is 19.99
all right
now
we have another question here
i want to find
how much sales did andrews make in the
central region so here
i have
two lookup values one is central one is
andrews now looking at these two values
i want to find the total
to solve such problems let me first
create
another table
i'll place the table somewhere here
okay so let me just paste the table here
all right now i'll create another column
where i'll merge
the values of region and representatives
so here
let me create another column okay i'll
just name this column as
region
rep
all right
now this column
i'll use the concatenation operator
so i'll select
east
use ampersand and then select jones i'll
hit enter
now the same thing i'll just duplicate
it
for the other rows as well so i have my
new column created now using this table
i can easily solve the problem
now to find the total
i'll write my vlookup formula
so my lookup value
will be a combination of
j11
ampersand
k11
comma
while table array will start from the
region rep which has the values of
region and rep combined
till
the last column
and from this table array my column
index number is 5
and my range lookup is 0 but close the
bracket hit enter you can see
for central region
which is this one
and for andrew's representative the
total is 149.25
all right now we are done with our demo
let's have a quick glance at what all we
did in this demo
okay so first of all we saw our data set
which was a sales data set that we used
then we started with our first example
to see how vlookup performs an exact
match
we also saw how using the formulas tab
and lookup and reference you can
write vlookup in
another way so you can use the function
arguments to give your vlookup
parameters next we saw how vlookup
performs an approximate match so we had
mat and raw which were not present in
the representatives column
after that
we saw an important property of vlookup
that is vlookup only looks to the right
followed by
vlookup only returns the first match
following which we saw
that vlookup is case insensitive so here
we had added a new row where gil was
present in uppercase but still vlookup
found the total revenue for gil which
was in sentence case or proper case next
we saw how we can use wildcard
characters to
use vlookups
and here we saw how to use
an if any function
along with vlookup
and finally we saw how to use two
vlookups choose from over 300 in-demand
skills and get access to 1000 plus hours
of video content for free visit scaleup
by simplylearn click on the link in the
description to know more now we are on
the sheet of microsoft excel and here
you can see some data on my sheet
that is employee name employee id and
salary
so here we are going to perform more
horizontal lookup but before that let me
show you that this particular drop down
menu so this particular drop down menu
has all the names of the employees in
this particular table and we have
created this using data validation in
excel
if you want to create the drop-down
menus just like these then feel free to
check out our data validation in excel
tutorial link to which is in the
description box below now let's try to
implement hlookup in excel so here we
have employee name but we want to find
out the employee id so for that let's
create the hlookup now for that equals
to hlookup
now the first one is the lookup value so
this one
is
the cell which is the employee name now
after that the table array we have to
select all the table arrays here
now
the row index number so the employee id
is in row index number two according to
the table so for that provide two and
close the bracket and before closing
brackets you might want to give the
exact match so for exact match select
false
and close the bracket press enter and
there you go
and if you select
jack then you'll find the employee id of
check and if you select jury you'll find
the employee id of cherry reflecting
here
now similarly let's find out the salary
of all the employees using hlookup
so equals hlookup
and lookup value that happens to be the
name of the employee
now the table array
and next we have
row index number that is salary happens
to be the third row in the table so
three
and
exact match
close the bracket and enter so now if
you change the values in this particular
drop-down menu you will find the
employee id and their particular salary
so jack happens to be carrying the
employee id as one zero zero one and his
salary is ten thousand
so similarly let's try to find out
peter's employee id and salary
so there you go one zero zero five and
fifty thousand salary so that's how you
use hlookup in excel here you can see
the first chart so this particular data
is converted into a table format to
avoid confusion while you're fixing the
data so here you can see the name of the
employee employee id department salary
and date of joining and here you can see
the salary column and the bonus
percentage of each and every employee
based on their salaries
now coming to the new data table and
here on the table 2 which is an updated
table here you can find we are going to
find out the department of the employee
and the current department of employee
and the bonus percentage based on his or
her salary so why are we finding current
department again
so here you can see that we have an
intern emily who was joined in the year
2020 but recently she got promoted as a
developer so her department has been
changed from department intern to
department developer in 2021 so that's
what we're gonna find out here in the
current department using x lookup
now let's start to implement x lookup so
for that
equals to x lookup
and for lookup you can see if you need
to find out the lookup value lookup
array written array and all the other
two are
not important right now but you can use
them to get some exact matches in the
future we'll also use that in the future
for now let's try to use the first three
parameters that is lookup value lookup
array and written array so the lookup
value is the name of the employee mary
and lookup array is right here which is
this one
now we're going to select the lookup
array
then comma and
we're going to look up the department so
this is the department
lookup array
and that's all we need
close the bracket and press enter
okay i think we missed out the lookup
value
so the employee or the lookup value
which we required was missed so i've
added here so that is the lookup value
the first one which is mary and there
you go
press enter and you have the department
here now let's add it to all the rows
and here you have all the rows and all
the data related to all the employees
now we will find out the current
department as you can see here you have
emily as intern which is the older data
but what if you needed the latest data
that is the developer in the year 2021
right for that you might want to to work
the x lookup formula a little bit so
let's try that x lookup
lookup value which is the same
and comma
now where you have to look for the
array that is lookup array this one
and the return array which happens to be
this one
and next
you can find the exact match for this
one so that's all right exact match and
here comes the important part where you
have to search last to first by default
x lookup searches for first to last that
is like this in the starting place to
the last place so that's the reason why
we had emily as intern so now if we give
last to first then it retrieves the
latest theta where emily will be shown
as developer now select that
and now you can close the brackets and
press enter so let's add that to all the
rows there you go now you can see emily
clark peter and james all they have got
their updated job profiles as you can
see in the original data emily is a
developer now so is clark who was
originally a tester and he got promoted
to development team in 2021 similarly
peter became a senior finance executive
in 2021 and james the manager of sales
now let's try to find out the bonus for
all these employees based on their
salary so this one is quite simple
so x lookup
now the lookup value is their existing
salary
comma
and the bonus part so the lookup array
is the salary range
then here is another important point
so here you might want to find the exact
match but finding an exact match will
not help you here you might want to
declare another type of value where you
can get exact match or next smaller item
so you'll understand it why i'm
selecting that
so now let's close the bracket and enter
so
so now we have the bonus values now
let's add the bonus value to all the
factors all the rows i mean so you can
see we have different variety of
salaries that is 38 000
2239 etc but here in the ranges we have
provided 10 20 30 40 and 50. so what if
the value is between 30 and 20 that's
when you want the
less number right that's when you want
the number which is equivalent to 30 or
less than 30 which happens to be 15
percent so that's how it has worked here
that is 0.15 bonus to the actual salary
now we are on our excel sheet here you
can see the employee names and employee
ids of different employees from
different zones let us imagine that the
blue one is from east green one is from
west and the black one is from or the
purple one is from
south and the orange one is from north
so
this data is a little small but what if
we had a data with hundreds or thousands
of rows including all the employee names
employee ids or another relevant data
type like sales of an employee and his
employee id and he was supposed to
combine all the data from all the four
different zones into one single sheet it
would consume a lot of time right so
recently
microsoft has released some latest
updates based on arrays and datas so one
of those is vstack function in excel so
how to use it
since it is a latest function i
recommend you to go to the file menu and
in the file menu you can navigate to
account and in the account you can see
the option of update options
then you can select update now and your
microsoft office will be updated to the
latest version and you will get access
to the latest functions in excel and all
the other office related things like
problem presentation etc
now we are going to implement the vstack
function in excel it is completely
simple all you need to do is equals to
stack
and then select the data
remember to select the data from column
a
and cell to or the row two we are not
selecting the employee and employee id
we are just selecting the data now
separate them by comma then again this
one here this set and again this one
and again lastly this particular last
set
now close the bracket and press enter
and there you go you have all the
employee names and their respective
employee ids all together in one data
set
so this is how you use we stack function
in excel and there are also a few more
new updates from microsoft excel
so what is excel power query
power query is an advanced feature of
microsoft excel that allows you to
prepare your data for analysis
you can perform numerous text
computations and numerical analysis to
make your data more powerful and
informative excel power query is a data
preparation and transformation engine
it allows you to carry out the extract
transform and load operations on the
data sets from multiple sources now
let's look at the challenges solved by
power query
earlier in excel there was difficulty in
data connections
now using power query you can connect to
a broad range of data sources such as
relational databases web files text csv
json files and even fetch data in the
cloud
volume variety and velocity are the
characteristics that define big data it
was a major problem to handle such data
now power query enables you to transform
your data to an appropriate size it also
allows you to work on any shape of data
from any source
earlier updating your data and
refreshing it in real time was an issue
using power query a repeatable process
query is adopted to update the data in
real time and in the future
in excel
it was not so easy to reshape transform
and manipulate data but using power
query provides a highly interactive
experience and sophisticated tools to
prepare your data now
from excel 2016 onwards power query on
windows has been fully integrated into
excel but in excel 2010 and 2013 for
windows power query is a free add-in
you can go ahead and download the link
once installed the power query tab will
be visible in the excel ribbon now
coming to the
features of power query so excel power
query allows you to clean transform
manipulate and process your data for
analysis it helps you to automate
repetitive tasks that you want to do it
over and over again you can search for
data sources and make connections as and
when you want power query helps you to
prepare and shape the data in the right
format for performing analysis
and finally
once your data is ready you can share
your findings or use your query to
create interactive reports and
dashboards
now let's have a glance at the demo that
we are going to work on in this video
so we look at how to load data from
different sources
you will understand how to extract
tables from web files so we'll extract
tables present on wikipedia pages then
you learn how to sort and filter data
up next you will see how to group your
data how to split a column into multiple
columns
and then pivot and unpivot your table
then you're going to work on
date columns and make some
transformations
understand how to append tables and
merge tables vertically and horizontally
now let's open ms excel and start with
importing a simple text file
so you can see here i have my excel file
opened
and in the middle you can see i have my
employee txt file
now this is a comma separated file
meaning that the values are separated by
commas as you can see it here
the columns have been separated by
commas and all the values have a comma
between them
now
this
text file has information about
the name age company and the city to
which the employee belongs to
let's see how easily you can import this
emp text file into ms excel
here
i am using
excel 365 or office 365 where power
query on windows has been fully
integrated into this version of excel
so what i'll do is first
let's go to the data tab
and
you have this section called get and
transform data so i'll click on get data
under get data i'll go to from file
and select
from text slash csv
once i click on it it will ask me to
give the location where the file is
there
so my file is on desktop i'll click on
power query files and here you can see i
have my employee txt file
you can see the type here it says text
document click on emp
and hit import
now this will take some time to import
the file onto excel
it's establishing a connection you can
see
there you go
so here you can see the filename emp.txt
you can see the file origin
as i said the delimiter is comma and we
have the data type detection
and here you can see
we have a text file so excel power query
feature has automatically detected the
column names so we have name
age company and city as our columns and
these are the values
now let's hit
load so this will load all the rows and
the columns onto excel
there you go it was really quick
excel has automatically loaded our text
file
now you can see here we have another tab
called queries and connections so we
have made
one query and have loaded
the employee data
it gives a preview also you can see it
here
and if needed later you can go to edit
and change some values that we'll see
later
now you can use this data to create
simple visualizations
so let me show you how to do it
so let's first select the data and
we'll go to the insert tab
under insert tab i'll click on
recommended charts
let's say
i want to know how many employees belong
to a particular city
so i'll click on the second chart which
says the count of name by city
and i'll click on ok
here you can see
we have a nice clustered bar chart
and you can see
in bangalore there were five employees
in hyderabad we had two and in nasik we
had one
you can see the count here this is a
pivot table
if we go back to our actual data here
you can see
in bangalore we had vidya
sonam avinash
varun and himani
and there were
two more people from hyderabad and one
from nasik
so you can use
the excel power query feature to import
data onto excel and
make some visualizations
now
if you want to fetch some data that is
present on the web or on the internet
excel power query features and
functionalities can help you import
those data as well
we will now see how to import data
specifically a table that is present on
the web
here
i'll be using a wikipedia article on the
list of european cup and ufo champions
league finals let me show you the page
first
so this is my wikipedia page on the list
of european cup and ufo champions league
finals
if i scroll down you can see all the
details here
and i would like to import
this table
which has the list of
all the finals so we have columns like
season
winners score line runner sub venue and
attendance
let's import this table on to excel
so i'll copy this url first
now let me open a new sheet i'll go to
sheet1
and then on the data tab
under the get data section
i'll go to from other sources and here i
have
from web which allows me to import data
from the web either you can follow this
path or
if you see here there's an option to get
data from the web if i click on this
it is asking me to enter the url so i'll
paste the url of the wikipedia page here
and let's click on ok
now it's navigating and
okay
you can see
power query feature in excel has given
us a list of tables which you can see
here
we have something called as document
there's a key table and here you can see
there's one table which was extracted
from the wikipedia page
and the table which i am interested in
is this table which has the list of
european cup
finals
you can see it here
excel power query feature has
automatically detected
these rows and it has given a
list of columns as well you can see
these are the columns
i will explore the transform data tab
present in the
power query
now if i click on transform data it will
take me to the power query editor
let me just
click on refresh
now this is the most important section
using the power query editor you can
clean your data filter your data
manipulate your data
and make it ready for analysis
now let's explore a few tabs available
here so we have a home tab that has
a query section
you can see you can reduce rows manage
columns sort the data transform the data
combine different
tables now there's another tab called
transform which allows you to select
your data type transpose your rows and
columns
pivot and unpivot your columns
and here you can see
you can find out some summary statistics
and you can manage your date values as
well
now if you want to add some new columns
to your data you can do that as well and
you also have a view tab
now here
if you see the first two rows
the values are the same you can see
season season these are all repeated
which we actually don't need
and these are pretty similar to our
column names
similarly if i scroll down
you see there are some rows
which have null values
so actually these
rows do not add up any value or do not
add any value to our data so we'll clean
this data first
so let's see how to do it
now if you want to remove certain rows
in the table
what you can do is
go to the home tab
and under reduce rows click on remove
rows
and then choose
remove top rows
if i select remove top rows it will ask
me how many rows do you want to remove
from the top
you can see it here
i'll give i want to remove the top two
rows
now let's click on ok
you will see
that
the excel power query editor has removed
the first two rows
and on the right you can see the steps
that were applied
you can see it here
previously we had these two
rows which were redundant
and once we applied the step
it has removed the first two rows
similarly
let's go down and remove the last
one two three four five
so we are going to remove the last
seven rows from the table
so again
i'll go to reduce rows and click on
remove rows now this time i'll select
remove bottom rows
and here i'll choose
i want to delete seven rows from the
table
from the bottom
i click on ok
if you see
the last seven rows have been
deleted now let me show you the last row
which is this one
so the last season of
ufo champions league was held in 2020
which is this year
and bayern munich won the champions
league against a french team that was
paris saint-germain by a score of 1-0
now if you see the last value that is
the attendance
you can see the value is 0 which means
there were no spectators in the stadium
it was because of the covet conditions
now let's do some more manipulation to
our data
suppose this time i want to add a new
column let's say a stadium name by
extracting values from the venue column
so let me just show you the venue column
so this is our venue column
so the first value
is the stadium name
then we have the city in which the
stadium is there and finally we have the
country name
so i want to extract only the stadium
name so you can see we have some
stadiums like santiago bernabeu
there's wembley san siro
and other stadiums so i want to extract
only the stadium names
so let's see how to do that
i'll click on the venue column and go to
add column tab under add column here you
can see we have
extract
now if i click on this drop down there
is an option to select
text before delimiter
so if i choose text before delimiter
here
i'll give my delimiter as
comma
so everything before the first comma
will be considered as the stadium name
now let me click on ok
now here you can see under applied steps
it says inserted
text before delimiter if i scroll to the
right you can see the last column
has a stadium names
let me double click on this and change
this to
stadium name column
and hit enter
even this step is applied
here you can see renamed columns
similarly
let's explore a few more features
now i want to add a new column called
stadium city
so
if you consider this venue column
whatever is there between the two commas
is the stadium city
so for example santiago barnabao is in
madrid similarly
wembley stadium is in london
san 0 is in milan
so these
middle values i want to extract into a
new column called as
stadium city
so let's see how to do it
so i'll click on the venue column
and go to extract
and again
i'll select
the extract tab
and here now i'll choose
text between delimiters
and my first delimiter i'll give is
a comma
and a space you can see here
all the values
have a comma and a space
and my end delimiter will be another
comma
then i'll click on ok
this will add a new column
to the extreme right of the table you
can see here we have text between
delimiters
and it has extracted the stadium city
let me go ahead and
rename this
column as stadium
city
and hit enter
you can see the applied step here
now
i want to split the score column into
two columns so here we have the score
column
and
the left value presents the number of
goals that were scored by the winning
team
and the right value presents the number
of
goals that were scored by the losing
team
so here i'll split the column into two
columns as winner score and loser score
so what i'll do is
select this column and go to the home
tab
under the home tab we have
split column
i'll select split column
and then choose
byte delimiter
so automatically
excel power query detects that this dash
is my delimiter
and i'll split at each occurrence of the
delimiter
let's click on ok
now you can see
the score column has been split into 2
it has renamed the column as score dot 1
and score dot 2.
what i'll do is i'll go ahead and
we'll rename this column as winner score
and this will
rename it to
loser score
i'll hit enter and i have renamed it
successfully
next
let's change the winners team and the
runner sub team values to uppercase
so suppose
i want to change all the values or the
club names of the winners team to
uppercase so what i can do is
i'll select this column and go to the
transform tab
under transform tab i have this option
called
format
so here
i'll click on format and then
you can see
i can change the case to lowercase
uppercase capitalize each word
so here i want to make all the winner
teams as uppercase i'll select uppercase
there you go
we have successfully converted all the
winner team names to uppercase
similarly let's do it for the runner sub
team as well
so here i have my runnersup team
i'll go to the transform tab
click on format
and select uppercase
now we saw
how to do some simple
manipulation of our data so we created a
few columns split a few columns
now to save all this i have to go to the
home tab and then click on close and
load
this will take some time and load our
data onto this excel sheet
you can see here it's loading the data
this will take a bit of time
there you go
excel power query feature has
successfully
performed some manipulations on our data
some calculations on our data and then
it has
saved the final version
and loaded it onto excel now using this
clean data we can do some analysis
let's say i want to find the seasons in
which the winners team scored more than
three goals so we have a problem
statement at hand where we want to find
the seasons in which
the winner team had more than three
goals scored
so what you can do is
select any
cell in this data and go to the insert
tab
and click on
pivot table
here i'll click on existing worksheet
and then
i'll give my location
i'll place my
pivot table somewhere here and click on
ok
all right
now
since i want to know the seasons i'll
drag season on to row and i'll also drag
the winner's team
column onto rows
then i'll choose my winner score
under values
here you can see we have the pivot table
ready
now we need to filter this table to see
all the winning teams that scored more
than three goals so what i'll do is
i'll select this winner score column and
place it under
filters and here you can see i have my
filter
let me click on this drop down
and i'll select multiple items
from this multiple items i'll choose
4 5 and 7 because these values are
greater than 3
and click on ok
here you can see i have filtered my
pivot table and
to the left you can see the season
and the winner team
that had scored more than 3 goals in the
finals
alright
similarly
you can perform some more analysis
suppose
i want to know how many times real
madrid won the championship
so let's see i'll click on one cell in
the data set
go to the insert tab and click on pivot
table
i'll choose existing worksheet and give
my location here
let's say i want to place my port table
here
click on ok
alright so the question we have is how
many times have real madrid won the
championship
so i'll choose
the winner's team column and place it
under
rows
and
let's say
we'll select the winner score as well
and let's convert this winner score from
sum
to let's say count and click on ok
and
since i want to check only for
real madrid
so what i'll do is i'll go to
the insert tab
and i'll insert a slicer
here i'll choose
winner teams as my slicer and click on
ok
and out of this
i want to choose only
real madrid so i'll select real madrid
you can see it here
real madrid have won the championship 13
times
okay
let's say you want to compress your data
and remove unnecessary columns without
losing any information
you can do that using a feature in the
power query editor called unpivot
to perform this task we'll use a census
data of india from wikipedia so let me
first show you the wikipedia page
so this is my wikipedia article which
says list of states in india by past
population
and if i scroll down
you can see it here there's a table
which says by past population from 1947
to 2011.
so there are a few columns like rank
this state or union territory and we
have population starting from 1951
till 2011 which was our last census
here you can see if i scroll further
there are
nearly 29 states and we have
seven union territories so we will
extract this table and load into excel
first
okay so let me click on a new sheet and
we'll follow the same drill i'll go to
my data tab
and click on get data
under get data i'll go to from other
sources and click on from web
here it will ask me to provide the url
link of the wikipedia page so i'll paste
the url here
and click on ok
now once i have done that
it will load a few tables
onto excel you can see there are a few
tables here i'll click on the first one
so we have our table here
now let's do some transformation to this
data
this opens in the power query editor
okay i'll click on refresh first
this will take some time to refresh the
entire data okay we are done now if you
see this data
clearly
the first
row in this table is not necessary at
all because these are our column names
so we also have our column headers
already present
so let's go ahead and delete the first
row so we'll go to the home tab under
remove rows i'll click on remove top
rows
now i'll give my
number of rows as one so we want to
remove the first row only i'll click on
ok
you can see the first row has been
deleted
if i scroll further
i actually don't need the last row as
well which is the total
so what we can do is we can also remove
the last row from the bottom so i'll
select one
click on ok
you can see the step has been applied
and
you don't see the last row that was the
total row anymore
so the task that i want to do here is
i want to compress
all these columns which are basically
the population columns
so i'll
select my
state or union territory column
and
go to the transform tab and here i have
the option to unpivot columns so i'll
click on this drop down and select
unpivot
other columns
you can see here the step has been
applied and
all the population column from 1951 till
2011 have been unpivoted
if you want you can go ahead and
rename these columns let's see i'll
write it as population column
and
let's say this is
i'll rename it to total population value
all right
now we are done with our
preparation of data let's go to the home
tab and click on close and load
now this will take some time to load the
data onto excel
all right so we have
our census data here so first you can
see
rank one is uttar pradesh and we have
the population starting from 1951 till
2011
then we have for maharashtra
if i scroll down you can see the other
states we have tamil nadu rajasthan this
karnataka if i scroll further
we have odisha there's telangana kerala
now if you see here
the population values from 1951 till
2011 for the telangana state are all n a
which means there was no data available
now this is because telangana was only
formed in 2014 so there was no census
for this state
let's continue with our demo and let's
explore a few more
features and functionalities of our
query editor
now the next table we are going to use
is an adventure works customer table
now this data set is provided by
microsoft for practitioners who want to
learn power bi excel or similar
technologies and want to do some
manipulation some calculation some data
analysis stuff so let me go to a new
sheet and let's import
the adventure works customer data set
it's a csv file onto excel first
so i'll go to my data tab
and click on get data from here i'll go
to
from file and choose
from text slash csv
you can see it here in my power query
files folder i have my
adventure works customer table
i'll select this and click on import
this will take some time to load the
data set
you can see the preview of the data set
here so we have
columns like the customer key we have
the prefix of the customer name the
first name the last name of the customer
date of birth
marital status
if i go to the right we have annual
income total children education level
occupation and homeowner column as well
so let's click on transform data
here we'll learn a few more
features of power query
okay we have our data on our power query
editor
so first what i'll show you is
let's change the prefix column the first
name column and the last name column to
proper case
so you can see it here the prefix first
name and last name columns are all
in upper case
now if you want to change the values to
proper case
just
hit control and select the three columns
and go to the transform tab
under transform tab you have
format
so click on format here you can see we
have lowercase uppercase now proper
cases to capitalize each word so i'll
click on capitalize each word
you can see it here now
we have converted the prefix first name
and last name column
into prop case
the next step i'm going to show you is
let's merge all the three columns the
prefix column the first name column and
the last name column into one full name
column
so
what i'll do is i'll select the three
columns
and then let's go to add column
and under add column we have this option
called
merge columns
let's hit merge columns
okay
now it's asking you to give the
separator i'll select my separator as a
space
and click on ok
ok so before click on ok i want to
change my
new column name from merged to let's say
full name
and now let's click on ok
you can see here it says inserted merged
column and if i go to my
right you can see it here we have a full
name column
now if you want
to shift the location of the full name
column you can do that as well
just
hold this and
keep on dragging to the left
this will move the entire
table to the right and you can place it
wherever you want so i want to place it
let's say here
okay
now actually i don't want all these
columns so let's delete it
so click on this
and
i'll right click
and click on remove
you can see we have removed the prefix
column similarly let's remove the
other two columns you can either right
click and do or go to the home tab
and then select remove columns
all right
now
let's say we want to add a domain name
column from aws customers by extracting
the characters between at the rate and
dot com
so actually i am talking about the email
address
from this email address we want to
create a new column called as domain
name for that we'll extract characters
that are present between at the rate and
dot com
so let's see how to do it
i'll select the email address column
and then i'll go to add column
under add column i'll click on extract
and this time we want to extract
between two delimiters and so i'll
select
text between delimiters and i'll give my
starting delimiter as
add the rate
and
my end delimiter would be dot com
now let's click on ok
so this will
insert a new column to the extreme right
you can see we have our domain name
let's go ahead and
change the column name to domain name
and hit enter
all right
you can see the step has been applied
now we are done with
our preparation of customers table let's
just go to the home tab and click on
close and load
so all the transformation that we did in
the power query editor
will reflect here so you can see we have
our full name column
and if you see
we have our domain name as well
now using the power query editor you can
perform some
statistical analysis
now let's explore those statistical
features
for this we'll be using another data set
called adventure box product data set
again this data set is also provided by
microsoft
so let's go to the new sheet and here
i'll go to the data tab
click on get data
under from files i click on text slash
csv
here you can see we have
adventure works products i click on
import
let's click on transform data
so we have our data
loaded onto the power query editor
the data is mostly clean so let's not
alter this data let's straight away go
ahead and explore some of the
statistical features that we have here
now let's say
if you want to find the total number of
product names in the product table
we have this product name column and say
if you want to find the total number of
product names in the table
how to do it
so what you can do is click on this
product name column
then go to the transform tab
now in the transform tab you have an
option called statistics
click on this drop down and select count
values now this will open another window
that will return the total number of
products in the table you can see the
value here it says 293
now to move back to the query editor we
have to cancel this step here so let's
just click cancel or close
we are back again
all right
now let's say you want to calculate the
average product price from the product
table
so if i move to the right
you have a column called product price
so let's see
what is the average product price from
the product table so i'll select this
product price column
go to the transform tab
under statistics
i'll select average
so this will give me the average product
price which is
714.4373
you can consider any unit you want let's
say this is in dollars
now then we have to cancel this step to
move back
okay
now if you want to find the maximum
minimum product price you can do that as
well
so
let me select my column product price
and go to the transform tab
under the transform tab
we click on this statistic drop down
and let's say i'll select minimum so
this will give me the minimum product
price which is 2.29
similarly
if you want to find the maximum product
price so select this product price
column go to the transform tab
and then choose maximum
so this is the maximum product price in
the product table we have
let's cancel this step
okay
now you can also round the product cost
and product price column to two decimal
places
so if i show you both the columns you
have your product cost
and you have the product price column
you can see the floating values of the
decimal points are not constant it's
varying
so let's limit it to two decimal places
what you can do is select both the
columns and then go to the transform tab
in the transform tab you have here
rounding
i'll click on this drop down and select
round
now here i'll give my
decimal places as 2.
if i click on ok
you can see here
both the columns the product cost and
the product price column have been
rounded up to two decimal places
i can scroll down you can see
all the values have been rounded up to
two decimal places
all right
now
let's say you want to
add a column called discount price
column
by multiplying 0.9 to the product price
column
and let's say you also want to round
that new column to two decimal places so
how to do it
so we want to give a discount of
10 percent so i'll select this product
price column
go to add column
and then i'll choose custom column
here we'll write a formula
so i'll give my new column name as
discount price
and
my formula would be
i'll select product price
i'll click on insert
and then i'll multiply this product
price by
0.9
so this will give me my 10 discount
on the product price and click on ok you
see here we have a new column added
which is discount price
so
if the product price is
34.99 if you give a 10 discount
it's 31.491
all right
now the next question was to change the
around the decimal places to two
so i'll go to the transform tab under
rounding and click on round
let's see i'll give 2 and click on ok
so even this has rounded the discount
price column to 2 decimal places
now we are done with our mathematical
operation on this product data set
so we saw how to find
some average count how to round up
values how to add a new custom column
so let's go ahead and
close it
and load it onto excel
you see here we have our
new product table
added here and
the last column if you see it's the
discount column that we added
okay now it's time for us to explore
another feature
so we'll use a table called adventure
works calendar table which has basically
a date column
and let's see
how using power query you can prepare
that data as well and make some
manipulation some calculations
so let me go ahead and import adventure
works calendars table again this data
set is provided by microsoft
so i'll
go to my new sheet
and i'll go to the data tab
click on get data and from here i'll
click on from text slash csv
and you can see i have my calendar table
here i click on import
now this will open in the query editor
you see here this data set has only one
column which is a date column
so let's click on
transform data
okay
now if you see here
the first row is actually the
column name
so
let's
do the transformation here let's push
this as the column name so i'll go to
the home tab
and on the home tab you have this option
called use first row as headers i'll
select this
you see here we have the column name as
date
now
before making any
operation let's see
if all the fields are available
you see here if i click on
the date drop down
year month quarter weekday day
everything has been
shaded out and i can't access this the
reason is
the date settings are not correct
so we change the regional settings let
me show you how to do it
so we'll go to file
and i'll select
options and settings and go to query
options
under query options
we have something called as regional
settings
here
under regional settings we'll select
english united states instead of english
india
so i'll just scroll down
and
here we have english united states
and i click on ok
now once this is done i'll go to my data
type and i'll select
date as my data type
i'll choose replace current
okay
now you can see
my date column has been formatted
if i go to
the date tab you can see i have access
to all this
now let's do some
operations on this date column
let's say you want to
find the earliest and the latest date
from aw calendars table or the adventure
box calendar table
so what you can do is select this column
go to
date drop down under transform and here
we have the option of earliest and
latest so if i click on earliest
this will show you the last date which
was 1st of january 2015.
let me close this
similarly you can see the most recent
date
i'll go to the date
drop down and click on latest
and you have
30
june 2017 as the latest date
close this
now let's add a new column
say the name start of the week and
others
so i'll select my date column
go to
add column
here under add column i have
my option to
select the day name the week name and
others so i'll click on this date drop
down
and under day
let's say i want to choose
name of d
this returns the d name
similarly
let's say
i want to find out
the start of the week
you can see we have the
start of the week column or start of
week column
now one thing to notice here is
in this power query editor the week
starts on a sunday
now suppose you want to start your week
on a monday you can do some
transformations on this formula tab
so here in the formula bar you can add
a 1 here to make sure your week starts
on a monday so if i hit enter you will
see all these
values will change you can see it's 28 4
and 11 this will become 29 5 and 12.
let's hit enter
you can see it here
your start of the week is on a monday
now there's another method to make sure
your week starts on a monday let's
cancel this step
okay i have to insert it once again so
i'll go to date
and here i'll choose
start of week
now the week starts on a sunday
so
one more method is to
add day dot
monday you can see automatically
power query is giving me a suggestion so
i'll hit tab to finish it and i'll hit
enter
now you can see the values have changed
and our week starts on a monday
now let's see
we want to add a few more columns like
start of month name of month start of
year
and the year value so you can just click
on the date column or select the date
column
go to the transform tab
okay not the transform tab let's go to
the add column tab
and here let's say i'll choose year
so we have all the year values and
similarly
let's say i want to know the
start of the year
now you can do
a few more transformations let's say i
want to know the month
now here it gives us one which means
january that's february march and so on
and so forth
let's say
we'll do one more
i'll click on this
go to my
date
drop down and here i'll choose let's say
i want to know
the day of year
all right now we are done with all our
transformation and preparing your data
on our date field so let me just go to
the home tab i'll click on close and
load
now this will load the
data set on to excel you can see it here
we have the data ready now you can use
this data to make some
analysis
draw a pivot table draw a pivot chart
and do a whole lot of things now while
working on a project it is possible that
not all your data will be in a single
file it could be stored in multiple
files so it's important to combine and
bring all your data together
now we will see how to join your data
vertically
i have my data present in a csv folder
so let me show you the folder first
so this is my csv folder let me open it
and
i have some files these are named as
project 1 2 3 4 and 5.
let me open just one of the project
files
it has a very small quantity of data
you can see it has a month column and an
amount column let me close this
and
let me show it to you again let's open
project 4.
all the files have the same number of
columns you can see this also has a
month column
and an amount column
now we'll combine all this data together
and load it into excel let's see how to
do it
so i'll open a new sheet
and i'll go to my data tab and click on
get data
then i'll go to from file and this time
i'll choose
from
folder now this will ask me to give the
folder location of the path location
where my csv files are
so i'll choose
browse
and here you can see i have my csv file
i'll just double click on it
and click on open
now it has selected my
file path
or the folder path
then i'll click on ok
you can see these are the files you have
project1.xls
project2.xls and so on
i'll
click on this combine drop down and i'll
hit combine and transform
now this will give you the preview of
one of the data files
you will see it now
you can see it here it says sheet1
okay
now it's processing all the
data files present in that csv folder
and this will be uploaded onto our power
query editor
now you can see here on the power query
editor
all my
data files have been
combined vertically
here you can see
the month column
on the extreme right it's the amount
column
and to the extreme left we have the
source name or the
source file where the data came from so
first is project one
then we have project two
if i scroll down we have project three
files project four and similarly we have
project five
now this is one way in which you can
merge your
tables vertically
so we are done with it let's just go to
the home tab and click on close and load
all the transformations that were
applied you can see it here we have our
final table
and we have successfully
combined
five excel files
again
you can also join your data horizontally
this would be like an sql join where the
data is present in multiple files or
sheets
based on a common key column you can
join the tables
so you can perform a left join a right
join and inner join based on the problem
that you are trying to solve
so let's merge two tables based on a
column
i'll show the data set first it's an
excel file which has three worksheets
so here is my excel file which we'll be
using to
merge our data horizontally you can see
there are three worksheets
the first one is year 11 which has data
regarding the student name
the gender of the student and the course
the student had opted for
similarly we have another for 2012 or
year 12 we have the student name
gender as well as the course
and finally we have a courses
table or a courses sheet
which has all the details regarding the
course
so we have the course name the teacher
who teaches or teacher who taught that
course we have the lesson type the
number of credits and the assignment
type
now we'll use this
data sets
to load it on to excel using power query
so i am on my excel sheet let's just
open a new sheet i'll go to the data tab
and here i'll click on get data and this
time i'll choose
from excel workbook
and i'll select my file which is
students and courses i click on import
so we will just see how to import two
tables and join them horizontally
so let me first select
the courses sheet
and i'll click on transform data
now this has
loaded the courses table onto power
query editor
the table looks fine we have the course
column teacher everything is fine now
let's load
one more table and then we'll merge it
so here under the home tab you have
a section called new source
i'll click on file
i'll again select my students and
courses and click on import
and this time let's choose
another table let's say year 11 which
has the column name as student gender
and course
i click on ok
it has successfully loaded this table
onto power query editor
now if you say this
the first row is actually our
column names so i'll go to the home tab
and select
use first row as headers
so this will push the first row
to the column names you can see we have
done it successfully we have my student
name
the gender column and the course column
now let's merge it so
if you see here in the home tab we have
a section called merge queries
let's click on this drop down
and select merge queries
here
i have my table which is year 11
and let's
choose one more table that is
courses
now the kind of join
i'll choose as left outer join which
means it will take all the
rows from the first table and matching
records from the second table
here i need to select the common key
column so if you see both the tables we
have the course column as the common key
column so i'll select
this and now you can see there's a tick
mark which means it has selected the
rows and the column successfully you can
see it says the selection matches 175
175 rows from the first table
and let's click on ok
let's just expand this
and click on ok
if i scroll to the right you can see i
have successfully merged
both the tables
now if you want
you can remove unnecessary
rows or columns suppose if you see i
have the course column
from the year 11 table and here also i
have
the course column
now this is
redundant let's just remove one of the
columns i'll just select this column
i'll go to
remove columns and i'll select remove
columns
okay
the rest looks fine we have successfully
merged both the tables by using a left
outer join
let's just click close and load
now this will take some time to load our
data onto excel you can see it here
we have successfully loaded it on to
excel
now we are done with our demo part
now let's just see
what all we have done in our demo so
i'll
go to my first sheet
here you can see
we had
imported a simple
text file first and then we plotted a
graph which is a pivot chart
then you saw
how to upload
a file from the web so here we imported
a
ufo champions league table which was
present on wikipedia
and then we plotted some
graphs and charts you can see we made
some
analysis using pivot tables
and then we imported another web file
which was based on a population data and
we use the unpivot option or the unpivot
feature in the power query to
reduce the number of columns
then we made some calculations to our
customer table which was from adventure
works
then we used another table
called the products table here we saw
some statistical calculations and we
added a column called discount price
where we used conditional operations
and then
you saw how we manipulated
a date column
and then we saw how to append and merge
multiple tables
try to convert some pdf data into excel
now you can see the pdf document which i
am looking to convert from pdf to excel
so this particular pdf document has a
table
so this is the statewide gst collections
that happened during march of 2020. now
we need to convert this tabular data
from pdf format to excel format
now we are on the microsoft excel
now to initiate the process we might
want to choose a blank workbook for this
so now we are at the blank workbook and
the complete sheet is empty
now let's go into the data option in the
toolbar
and in the data option of the toolbar
we have
the ribbon of get and transform data in
this ribbon you can see get data option
select that and you can see various
options here from file from database
from azure from other sources etc
now we need the first option that is
from file and in that we have a drop
down and in that drop down you might
want to select the pdf if you have a
json file you can also choose from a
json and if you have the data from xml
you can choose that and even you can
extract the data from text or csv as
well
now we need the pdf option so select the
pdf
now navigate where your file is existing
so my file is on the desktop and now let
me select the pdf document
select import
now excel will automatically analyze the
tabular data in the pdf format and give
you the results
now according to excel there are
multiple tabular formats
table 1 table 2 so basically this table
is one in the same so all the 29 states
are fixed in
one table itself but since the pdf is
divided in sheets this particular
document is considering the first table
as a separate table and the table which
is present in the third page as a
separate table
so we have table 1 table 2 and there are
few more tables which excel is assuming
that it might be table
but it's not and another table which is
page number 002 it has a table and
another one is right here now there is
an option of selecting all the tables
all together at once or you can select
only one table which you want to select
so if you select multiple items excel
will automatically give you an option of
choosing your tables
you can just tick and select the tables
you want
or
you can directly select the table you
want on your excel sheet
so right now let's try to select
multiple tables
so i'll be selecting one two four and
five and this particular one is not a
table so i'm eliminating that
now you might want to choose the load
option
so excel is now loading the data
now all the data has been successfully
loaded
now
yeah it is giving us a notification that
all the data has been successfully
loaded and now just right click on it
and here choose the option load 2
and here
select table option and if you want the
data to be
you know loaded to a new worksheet you
can choose that and select ok
now you can see all the data is being
successfully loaded in the form of
tabular format in the new excel sheet
similarly let's try to load another page
in the table format
new worksheet
select okay
and the third sheet
now get ready to impress your boss by
converting all the pdf data into excel
sheet just in a matter of few seconds
with few steps
and there you go all the four tables
have been loaded successfully in the
form of excel in just a few steps
now this is how you convert pdf to excel
now for this particular tutorial we will
be using the student data set
now let's get back to the practical mode
and start our microsoft excel
now we are in the microsoft excel and as
you can see on my sheet okay let me
expand this
so as you can see on my screen we have
the data set belonging to students so we
have 10 students and every one of them
has name role number class blood group
and marks etc and at the end we have the
person page and as you can see we have
the percentage in terms of float values
and we have a lot of decimal values like
8 and above so what if you wanted to
just have one or two digits after
the actual percentage like 80.6 or 80.66
right it would be a little bit more or
good to read right so that's what a
roundoff actually means so now let's
work on having rounded off values for
the percentage now let's create a new
column
let's name it as a
round
off
percentage
so to actually perform the round off uh
formula we do have a predefined method
for that
for that you just have to type in
equals to
round
and there you go we have round up and
around down so both of them perform the
same operation let's select a round up
and
this is the m column and the row number
is siri
so we'll have to press m sorry and the
number of values after the decimal point
for now let's select
one
and there you go press enter and the
value should be rounded off now 80.66 is
being rounded off to 80.7
now when you drag the cell
to the all the rows then you can see all
the values will be rounded off
here you can see
75.16 has been rounded off to
75.2 and 82.33 has been rounded off to
82.4 so we end up with having rounded
off values
so for example uh let us imagine that
you wanted to create one single cell for
all the employees in your company which
stores the
first name second name or last name
including the email ids at one place
right if you want to do so like let us
let us let me show you how it looks like
so let me copy this here
then that's the first name
now it's your second name
along with the email id
now let us imagine that you wanted to
store all the employees in the same way
right so you can do this by using
combine operation in excel now all it
takes is just a simple formula that is
equals to and the first cell address
that is a2
and
you can use an ampersand sign
now you can use the next cell reference
set as b2
and then
colon and the last cell address that is
a2
now press enter
so when you press enter or tab you will
get this particular answer but this data
is completely uh in a state where you
can't understand it right the first name
last name and the email id has got
combined all together
so you want to use some spaces right so
all you need to do is just make a little
modification to this particular existing
data so you can press another ampersand
and include spaces
and then you can separate the email id
and the name with some colon
so now we have separated the first two
cells that is the first name of the last
name with the space using the ampersands
and then again we have used an ampersand
to include the colon and see that we
have also included a space between the
colon marks that it gets separated
cleanly
and now let's try to press tab and see
the result
so there you go the first name and the
second name is separated by space and
the email id and the complete name is
separated by a colon now you can use
this to all the cells
and there you go
all the first name last name and the
email ids have been printed here so
that's how you use the combine operation
in excel
now we have started our microsoft excel
and here we have our empty worksheet so
dated if function is majorly used to
find the differences between two
individual dates so it is also called as
dated if by a few people and a few
people also reference it to date diff
that is date difference so anything is
good now to find the difference between
any two dates let's select a few dates
so the first date would be
let us imagine that you're an employee
and you wanted to find out how many
years that you've been working with an
organization
so for that you might want to need today
and the date where you join the company
right so it might be native joining
and today
so what's the difference
right so let us imagine that you joined
the organization somewhere around 2010
zero one
zero
five
two thousand
ten
and
today so for today can you can give any
particular date
let us imagine that
today is first of january 2021 or
2022 now we have our both the dates that
is the joining date and
the current date which can be the
current date so
the day can be anything so you might be
watching this on a different date as
well so the date of that day for today
would be a little different so we'll
imagine the today's state as an
imaginary read now we might want to find
the difference that is in terms of ears
so you wanted to find the difference in
terms of ears so here you can find the
difference in terms of years days and
months as well so currently let's try to
find out the difference in terms of
years so for years you might want to
specify the third parameter in the
dative function as y if you wanted
months you have to give
the m as the third parameter and if you
wanted to find the days you might want
to give d as the third parameter
uh so we have discussed the third
parameter so what are the first two
parameters right so the first two
parameters are the first date and the
last date so the first date in this
situation is your date of joining and
the last date or the final date
which you want here as your today so
let's find the difference so for that
equals 2
so it can be dated if or date diff
sedate f and
the first date which is the a2 and comma
the last state that is b2
and
your parameter third parameter in terms
of years that is why close the bracket
and press enter so there you go you have
your date here so it's been like 11
years that you're working with your
organization so that's how you find out
the differences so we have 11 years
because
we did not finish the
12th year completely so if we had given
the month as
maybe 6
where we have finished our total years
then
it will automatically change to
12 years
so that's how you work with dated f
function in excel
so you can see on my screen we are on
the excel spreadsheet
and on my spreadsheet you can see
dates in column a and a different
formats in column c d e and f
respectively now by default the data
type or the data present in the a column
will be considered as general and there
are a few situations where even if you
try to format the date in your format
like you know the customized format you
may not be able to do it because it's
still under the general data type so for
that for being on the safer side what we
will do is select the data and navigate
to the data toolbar and in that you have
the text to columns option press that
and remember to have the delimited icon
you know you might be having the
dash as your icon or slash as your icon
for the delimited thing and select that
and next next and here you can see right
it's in general mode so you can press on
date and dmi will be a date format that
is date month and year now click on
finish so it's been formatted now
now let's copy the same data and paste
it in all the four formats so that we'll
see the different formats that we can
change to or customize to
right
so there you go let's expand the columns
a little bit
now we have day
month and year
so now you might want to change a couple
of things right for example you wanted
to change okay let's see the menu so the
way is to select the cells and right
click and select the format cells option
and in here you can see the date
function and in here you can see
different types of modifications that
you can do to your data right
so
[Music]
you might want to also change your dates
based on the location so right now we
are in india and imagine if you wanted
to you know change something based on us
or if you have if you are having your
client in us and he wants the dates and
us format you can also change that so
here you can see english united states
and press on that press ok and you can
see it's been changed to us format where
you have years in the first place
months in the second place and dates in
the last place right
and now let us imagine that your client
does not want the dates all he needs is
just months right you can also do that
get back to the format sales option go
to custom and here instead of uh you
know a month date and year you all you
can do is just write down
month and year and select okay so you'll
have only month and year not the dates
now your client is being a little more
you know he wants a little more detail
and he wants you to add a lot of
granularity to your data which includes
day
time etc everything right so you can
also do that so the same way go to
format sales custom and here
i think it's in date itself
so
let's navigate a little
yeah here so you have the day date
month and year press okay so there you
go right so that's how you can do it
and now let's try a little bit more
if you have a few more options pending
so go to format cells
and
custom
and you also have
timings
so here you have date month year and the
timings press ok and they have all the
timings as well so since these dates are
you know i created them just a few
moments ago to keep it simple so i did
not have to add the
diamonds here so if you are keen about
adding the timings you can also do that
for example if you wanted to add the
timings of the employees logged in and
logged out you can also do that using
the same format
what is a pivot table
a pivot table is a tool that summarizes
and reorganizes selected columns and
rows of data in a spreadsheet to obtain
a desired report
it does not actually change the
spreadsheet data it simply pivots or
turns the data to view it in different
perspectives pivot tables are specially
useful with large amounts of data that
would be time consuming to calculate
manually
now
let's understand the different
components of a pivot table
so there are four main components first
we have rows when a field is chosen for
the row area it populates as the first
column in the pivot table
similar to the columns all row labels
are unique values and duplicates are
removed
columns
is the second component
when a field is chosen for the column
area only the unique values of the field
are listed across the top
then we have values each value is kept
in a pivot table cell and displays the
summarized information the most common
values are sum average minimum and
maximum
finally we have filters filters apply a
calculation or restriction to the entire
table
so let's jump over to microsoft excel
and let me show you the data set that we
will use in this demo
so with india being ready for its 16
census in 2021
that is next year it is a good time for
us to analyze india's last census data
from 2011 and see where different states
and cities across india stood in terms
of population literacy and other
socio-economic factors we will analyze
this data by creating different pivot
tables in excel and explore some of its
features so let's begin
first i'll show you one of the features
that excel offers us so suppose i click
on any cell and hit control plus q
you can see our entire table is selected
and at the right bottom there's an
option of quick analysis
now you can see by default excel has
prompted certain
features such as formatting we have
charts totals and there's one more
called tables
now excel by default has created some
pivot tables for us now the first one
you say is sum of district code by state
names
next we have sum of sex ratio by state
name
then we have some of child sex ratio
some of male graduates and some of
female graduates by state name and there
are others before creating our pivot
table so let's have a final look at our
data set
so first column you see is the city
column so there are different cities
from different parts of india
then we have the state code we have the
state name
district code we have the total
population followed by male and female
population
next you can see we have the total
literates from each city
then we have the male and female
literates
next we have the sex ratio
then we have the child sex ratio
next we have total number of graduates
and finally you can see we have male and
female graduates so using this table
we'll create several
pivot tables
now first of all let's create a pivot
table to find the total population for
each state and sort it in descending
order so you can see here
we have the problem statement
so our first pivot table will have the
total population for each of the states
in descending order
so to create a pivot table you can click
any cell
in your data
go to the insert tab
and here
left you can see we have the option to
create a pivot table so let me select
pivot table
now
my range is already selected the entire
table
and here i'll choose existing worksheet
because i want to place my pivot table
in the same worksheet
and i'll give my location i'll point to
cell q5
now let me click ok
you can see the pivot table fields
appears here on the right
now since we want to find the total
population for each state
so what i'll do is
i'll drag my state name onto rows
so here in our pivot table you can see
we have the different
state names listed
now
we want
the total population for each of these
states
so
in the field list i'll search for total
population which is this one and drag it
under values
you can see
we have our sum of total population for
each of these states
by default
excel will sum any numeric column you
can always change it to average minimum
maximum anything you want now we want to
sort this column in descending order so
i right click
go to sort option and choose z to a
that is largest to
smallest you can see here
in 2011 maharashtra had the highest
number of population
or the total population in maharashtra
was the highest then it was uttar
pradesh we had andhra pradesh
and if i come down we have nagaland and
andaman and nicobar islands towards
the end
so this is a simple pivot table that we
created
now the next problem we have is we want
to find the total sum of literates in
each city belonging to a certain state
so let's see how to do it
i'll click on any cell go to insert
and here i can click on pivot table
my range is selected
i'll choose existing worksheet and give
my location
which is q5
i click on ok
now here
we want to find the total sum of
literates so what i'll do is
first let me drag total literate's
column
to values
you have the total sum of literates from
all the states
next i want to see the sum of total
literates based on states and cities so
let me first drag state name onto rows
and then
we'll drag city
onto rows
you can see here we have our pivot table
ready
to the left of the pivot table you can
see we have the state names and
the cities
per state
and on the right you can see the total
number of literates from each city if i
scroll down we have assam then you can
see we have bihar
and if i keep scrolling we have all the
states haryana himachal pradesh there's
jammu and kashmir which has now become a
union territory
we have jharkhand karnataka and other
states as well moving on
okay so the next thing we want to see is
what is the average sex ratio and the
child sex ratio for each state
with that we also want to find the
states that had the highest and lowest
sex ratio in
so let's create a pivot table for this
i'll click on any cell go to insert
choose pivot table
click on existing worksheet
i'll select cell q5
and click on ok
now since we want
the average sex ratio and the child sex
ratio so first i'll drag those columns
either you can manually scroll and
drag it or here you have the option to
search for it so if i look for child
you can see we have
the same
column listed i can just drag it from
there let me delete this
and i also want the sex ratio
so i'll place it on top of child sex
ratio
next
we want to see it based on
different states so what i'll do is
i'll take
state name and put it under rows
so here you can see we have our pivot
table ready
on the left you can see we have the
different state names listed and on the
right we have the values
now we want to find the average now by
default
excel will sum the numeric columns you
can see it tells you sum of sex ratio
and child 6 ratio
so what you can do
you can click on this drop down and go
to value field settings
and here summarize
values by you can choose average
you can see the custom name it says
average of 6 ratio
click on ok
our entire column is now
giving us the average sex ratio
similarly for this column let me convert
it into
average i'll again click on the drop
down
go to value field settings click on
average
and click ok
and you can see here we have the average
of child sex ratio
for each of the states now the next
question says
which states had the highest and lowest
sex ratio so we'll consider this column
so we'll sort it in any order you want
you can do it either ascending or
descending let me short it in descending
order
you can see we have our column sorted
now
so in 2011
kerala had the highest sex ratio
and if i scroll down to the bottom you
can see himachal pradesh had the lowest
which is around 818
up next let's explore one more feature
of pivot table so suppose you want to
see the top or bottom few rows
of a pivot table
you can do that as well
so here we have a question at hand
we want to find the top three cities
with the highest number of female
graduates
so let's see from the entire pivot table
how we can filter the top three cities
so i'll go to insert
click on the pivot table option
go to existing worksheet
click on q5
and hit ok
now since we want to find the top three
cities i'll drag
city column onto rows and then
we want the female graduates so in the
search bar i'll look for female
and i'll choose this column that is
female graduates and drag it
here on to values so i have
the sum of female graduates for each of
the cities
now since we want to find the
highest number of female graduates in
the top three cities so let me first
sort this column
i'll sort it in descending order
now we have it sorted now from this you
can say that delhi greater mumbai and
bangalore
are the top three cities
but it's displaying all the cities for
us
so let's filter
only the top three so what you can do is
right click
and go to filter
under filter you have the option of top
10 i'll select this
here i only want the top three
so either you can
go down like this or you can directly
type three
your column is already selected let me
just click on ok
there you go
we have the required pivot table ready
and it only displays us the top three
cities with the highest number of female
graduates
now the next thing we want to see is how
to use a slicer in a pivot table
so we have a question here
what's the total population for all the
cities in rajasthan and karnataka
so let's create a pivot table for this
and see how you can use a slicer to
filter the
table click on existing
i'll click on a location this time q6
click ok
now since i want the total population so
i'll drag total population on to values
and then i'll select
the city
onto rose and then the state name also
i'll place it on top of city
so you have
in the pivot table all the states and
their cities
and on the right you can see the total
population for each of these cities
but our question is we want to find only
for rajasthan and karnataka
now for that what you can do is
go to insert
and create a slicer either you can
create from this option or you can go to
pivot table analyze option and here you
have the option to create or insert a
slicer i'll click on this
and since we want to slice the table
based on
state that is rajasthan and karnataka
i'll choose state name
as my slicer field
you can see this is my slicer here
now
you only want
the data for rajasthan and karnataka so
i'll search for
these two
so here we have karnataka so let me
select karnataka first
and i also want for rajasthan
so let me select rajasthan also
you can see in our pivot table we only
have
data for rajasthan and karnataka
so this pivot table
shows you different cities from
karnataka and the total sum of
population from each of the cities and
similarly we also have for
rajasthan
moving ahead
now we will see another very interesting
feature of pivot that is how you can
create percentage contribution of a
table
for example we have a question here
what's the percentage contribution of
male and female literates from each
state
now we want to see in terms of
percentage and not as sum or average
let's do that
i'll create my pivot table
click on existing
and i'll select an empty cell
okay
now here since we want to find the
percentage contribution of male and
female literates
so first i'll drag
male literates onto values
followed by
female literates onto values by default
it has summed up the mail literals and
female literature value
and also
i want to drag
state column
to rows
so here you can see the sum of male
literates and female literates per state
i want to convert this as
percentage contribution so
what we can do is
i'll select any cell
and
i'll right click
and i'll go to show value as
and here i have the option to select
percentage of grand total so i'll select
this
you can see we have the percentage
contribution of male literates to the
total
now if i sort this you will get to know
which state
contributed or has the highest
percentage contribution
so we have maharashtra for male
literates
then we had uttar pradesh in 2011.
if i come down
we had meghalaya nagaland and andaman
and nicobar islands
as those states which had little or
minimal contribution to male literates
similarly let's do it for female
literates
i'll go to so value as and select
percentage of grand total
so you can see here also maharashtra
uttar pradesh then gujarat and all had
the
highest percentage contribution to
female literature
so this is another
good feature
to convert your data and satan in terms
of percentage
now moving ahead
let's say we want to find the bottom
three cities from each state that had
the lowest female graduates
we can do that as well i'll go to insert
click on pivot
go to existing worksheet select an empty
worksheet and click on ok
now since i want to see based on
states as well as cities so let me drag
the state name first onto rows
and let's drag the city column on to
rows
next
we want female graduates so let me look
for female graduates in the field list
i'll drag it on to values
now we have the list of
states and the respective cities
and to the right of the pivot table you
can see the sum of female graduates from
each city
now
first i'll sort this column
i'll right click go to sort
and click on
shortest to largest
now we have sorted our female graduates
from shortest or smallest to largest
now since i want to find the bottom
three cities from each state
i'll come to the cell
right click
go to filter
and select top 10
now i'll
replace to opt-in with bottom
and i want the bottom three
cities from each state
i have my
column selected that is sum of female
graduates
if i click on ok
you can see here
some of the states don't have three
cities so you can see andaman and
nicobar islands has only one city that
is sport player
while the remaining you can find
the bottom three cities with the lowest
number of female graduates so andhra
pradesh had these three in assam we had
nagao then there was debrucker and
silcha
similarly if we come down in haryana we
have palval cathal and zind
if i come further here you can see for
karnataka this gangavati this rani benur
and the scholar similarly you can see
for kerala as well
now moving ahead
now in the next example i'll tell you
how you can create a calculated field or
a calculated column in excel with the
help of a pivot table
so in a pivot table you can create or
use custom formulas to create calculated
fields or items
calculated fields are formulas that can
refer to other fields in the pivot table
calculated fields appear with other
value fields in the pivot table like
other value fields a calculated field's
name may proceed with some of followed
by the field name
so here
we have a sales table that has columns
like the items which has different
fruits and vegetables
and those have been categorized as
fruits and vegetables we have the price
per kg and this is in terms of rupees
and we have the quantity that was sold
now let's see if you want to find the
sales for each item in the table you can
create a calculated field
so your sales column is going to be
the product of price per kg
and quantity so let me show you how you
can do that with the help of a pivot
table
i'll create a pivot table first
click on an empty cell
hit ok
now
if you see on the top
under pivot table analyze
and under calculations we have the
option fields items and sets
if i click on this drop down
i get the option
to create a calculated field or insert a
calculated field i click on this
i'll give my field name as sales
and i'll select my formula
i'll first click on
price per kg and hit insert field
i'll give a space hit shift 8 to give
the product symbol
and then i'll double click on quantity
now this is my formula for sales that is
price per kg multiplied by quantity
i click on add
and i click on ok
if you see here
there's a calculated field that is
present in the pivot table fields which
is sales but it did not add it to our
original table our original table is the
same but here we have added
a calculated field which is present only
in the pivot table list now we can use
this it has already taken it under
values
now let's say i want to find the sum of
sales for
each item
under each category
you can see it here we have our category
fruit and we have our category vegetable
and under that we have different
items like apple apricot banana
similarly in vegetables we have broccoli
this carrots corn eggplant and others
so this is how you can create
a calculated field in a pivot table
now this one more good feature that
excel offers us in pivot table is to
create a pivot chart
so you can use your pivot table and
create different charts
so i will show you how to do that
if i go to insert
here i have the option of recommended
charts
click on this
excel
gives me some default charts which you
can use
let's say i'll select this
let me drag it
a bit to the right
here you can see i'll close this pivot
field list
this is a nice
bar chart that excel has created this is
called a pivot chart now here you can
see the category fruits and vegetables
and the different fruits and vegetables
or the items
in the y-axis you can see the total
sales
if you see
from the graph
guava made the highest amount of sales
now if i sort this
let's sort this first
you can see it here fruit guava made the
highest amount of sales now since i
sorted and changed my pivot table
the pivot chart also automatically gets
updated
similarly there are other charts also
that you can create let's go to the
insert tab
and
let's click on recommended charts again
let's look for a pie chart so this is a
pie chart that you can create let me
click on ok so here is our pie chart and
each pie represents
a certain item
and the pie that has the highest area
represents
it had the highest amount of sales in
this case you can see
it is guava and similarly we have other
items as well this is fruit banana
that's corn
and we have spinach and others
let's explore a few other charts so
first i'll click on my pivot table go to
insert
and under recommended charts let's now
select a
line chart
if i hit ok
move it to the right so this is a line
chart you can see it starts
from guava
which had the highest amount of sales
then it
drops
and in the x-axis you can see the
different items similarly when it starts
with the vegetables
broccoli made the highest amount of
sales with
2800 rupees
and our lowest was
eggplant at 900 rupees
for fruits papaya sold the least at 700
rupees
let's take another chart i'll go to
insert
under recommended charts let's see
this time we'll see a bar chart now this
is a
horizontal bar chart and not a vertical
one we just saw a vertical
column chart like this
this is an horizontal bar chart now you
can always increase and decrease the
size of these charts
let's
explore a large chart let's take
the area chart for now
so this is an area chart again it looks
similar to the
line chart it starts with guava which
had the highest amount of sales
similarly
papaya under fruits had the lowest
amount of seals under vegetables it was
broccoli and finally eggplant made the
lowest amount of sales under vegetable
now let's go to our first sheet and
summarize what we have done in this demo
for people tables in excel so we had our
data
this is
2011 census data from india we had the
different cities the state names
and we had the total population total
literates female literates male
literates we had the sex ratio total
graduates and other information
so we began by understanding
how to create a simple pivot table where
we calculated the total population for
each state and sorted it in descending
order we found that maharashtra uttar
pradesh
had the total population in 2011.
then
we saw
another pre-vote table where we
calculated the total sum of literates in
each city belonging to a certain state
so you can see we had the
different state names and
the cities under each state
then
we saw another feature where you could
calculate the average of a certain
numerical column so here we calculated
the average sex ratio and the child sex
ratio for each state and found out which
one had the highest and lowest sex ratio
after that we saw
how you could find or filter tables
we saw how to find the top three cities
with the highest number of female
graduates we found out that delhi
greater mumbai and bangalore were the
top cities with highest number of female
graduates
next
we saw how to use slicer in a pivot
table so we sliced our table based on
rajasthan karnataka state and saw the
total population for all the cities in
rajasthan and karnataka
in the next sheet
we
explored another feature that was to
find the percentage contribution of male
and female literature from each state
then
here we saw how to find out
the bottom three cities for each state
having lowest female graduates
one thing marked that some of the states
did not have three cities for example
andaman had only one city that was poor
player but the others we found out the
bottom
three cities
that had the lowest female graduates
finally we looked at how to create a
calculated field in a pivot table
so we saw
how to create a
calculated field called sales
and then we explored how to create
different charts and graphs so this was
an area chart that we saw
is a column chart we also saw or looked
at
a bar chart that was a horizontal bar
chart
similarly we saw how to create a pie
chart as well
now here we have four different sheets
of the sales so the first sheet is the
west zone next is south zone east zone
and central zone so all this data
belongs to one single sheet that is
super store data set so i have
categorized or i have taken a part of
the data which belongs to central region
south region west region and east region
now we are going to use all these four
sheets and create one single sheet which
is the pivot table of all the four
sheets
now without further ado let's start the
process now for that we might want to
use the shortcut key that is alt d
now press p
now this starts the pivot chart wizard
now here we have to choose the option
multiple consolidation ranges
then click on next
and here you can see the pivot table is
clicked by default
now we'll go to next
now here click i will create page fields
or the pivot chart wizard will
automatically create if you want that to
create for you
now click on next
now here let's select the range
now i'll be selecting the range
update
now next we'll select east
followed by that we have south
and finally we have best
now we will name these according to the
regions
so the first one will be west
next one will be south
next one will be east
and the last one will be central
click on next and here select new
worksheet and finish
and there you go you have the pivot
table here now you might want to change
the summation value
so click anywhere on the pivot table and
change it from count
to
sum
so that you have the summation of the
total number of sales subcategory sales
and grand total of sales etc
now
here you can see all option now let's
select central and you'll get the
details of the central region
the grand total and the sales happening
quantity of sales etc now here you can
see the furniture office supplies
technology and the grand total all in
one single sheet now let's get back to
the original sheet
so as you can see this is the original
sheet and in the original sheet you can
see various more categories
which is
the
which is the shipment mode customer
customer segment country city state
and you also have
product name subcategory etc so if you
had added all these into this sheet you
can also create a separate option of
adding my new details to your pivot
table
so that is how the pivot table is
created using multiple sheets
so slices in excel are software filters
used along with excel tables or excel
pivot tables over a large amount of data
not just filtering out data but slices
also help you with an easy understanding
of the information being extracted and
displayed on the screen
now microsoft excel slices are
compatible with windows and macintosh
operating systems now let us understand
how to implement slicers in excel so for
that we might want to get back to the
practical mode that is starting our
microsoft excel
now we are on our excel sheet and as you
can see on my screen there is some data
available on the excel spreadsheet and
this table is not just any table
this table from microsoft excel is been
converted into an actual table as you
know by default excel considers all the
data which has been inserted into the
spreadsheet as a database and to
implement the slices in excel we might
want to create or
convert the format of database into a
normal table for that you can select all
your data and just press ctrl t
and that will allow you an option called
convert the data into table
now since this table is already
converted as a table we can directly
start implementing or inserting slices
into the spreadsheet
now for that
select all your data
then go into the insert option
and in the insert ribbon you can see the
filters group and in the filters group
select the option called slicer now you
will be provided with multiple options
since we have the columns employee id
employee name zone designation
department salary employees date of
birth and employee state of joining so
we can choose any of the options
available according to our columns and
create the slices
now let me select the first one that is
zone next designation
department and let's also select
employee name
now press ok and there you go we have
our slice list
now let us try to rearrange these slices
all you can do is just select and drag
them up
and done
now let us imagine that we want to see
or take a look at the employees who are
working in the east zone then we have
all the information displayed on the
screen who are working in the east zone
they are jack tony banner fred etc and
their department designation etc etc all
on one single screen so this really
helps you while you're presenting your
data in a presentation
now for a change let's try to select the
department
now if your client wants to select the
data
from only analytics department then you
might want to select on the analytics
key on the department slicer and there
you go you have an employee called look
hops who works in the east zone and his
department is analytics and his
designation is contract based and the
salary he is getting is 65
000.
now similarly
uh you can see that we have only
selected analytics and
your client also wants data from id
support now you can see that analytics
is gone
but what if you want both analytics and
id support then you have an option
called select multiple
then you can select analytics and it is
supported if you want hr you can also do
that and in the zone if you want
west along with east then you can do the
same east and west and you have all the
employee details
and in the designation let's try to
select
senior trainee okay select multiple
senior trainee and manager so that's how
you do it
so that's how it's done and that's how
you implement slicers in excel to
simplify the filtering options using
slicers during a presentation
and with that we have come to an end of
this tutorial on slicers in excel
so what is sumifs in excel
now you might want to calculate uh the
total sum of sales right so let us
assume that this is your entire store's
sales data and you wanted to calculate
the entire sum of sales so there is a
sum function in excel where you just
have to you know select all the cells
and apply some function onto it and
you'll get the sum of all the sales
right so with something like this you'll
select all the cells and then you'll
apply a sums function and you'll get the
sum here and average everything right so
this is fine but what if you just wanted
to find the sales that are happening in
only western region as you can see our
column f is based on region so we have
four regions south west east and central
so your manager asks you to find the
sales happening in suppose say a west
region so how do you calculate it would
you manually go into each cell and check
if it's western calculate that will be
time consuming right so what if you had
a method which could do it for you just
in a matter of few steps or few clicks
right so that's exactly sumifs so it
will basically add a condition
calculate the sum of sales where the
region is equals to west simple to like
or similar to sql query right so that is
exactly what we're going to do in excel
today that is using summits now let me
add here sales of
west region
now in the next cell let's add a sumifs
function remember there are multiple sum
functions in excel so when you type in
s-u-n you can see so many options based
on sum right you just have some followed
by that you have some if
it is just some if not some f's today we
are concentrating on some f's so
not just somewhere we'll go to some f's
so we'll be having an option of placing
multiple if conditions there so let's
also try that more on that later now
let's press tab to select our sumifs
function
now okay we forgot another important
step so before we apply sumifs we need
to convert our table into
a table format yes it looks stable but
right now it's not in tabular format it
is in the format of database we know
that microsoft excel considers its data
as a database by default so to convert
the database into table just click
anywhere on the data and press ctrl t so
that you'll have a new dialog box and it
will ask if your table has headers just
make sure that you have ticked in it our
table does have headers so select ok
now our database has been converted into
a perfect table and it's ready for
applying summers function so now you can
see our database has been successfully
converted into a table now let's begin
with our summits now again remember we
are using some f's here not sum f or sum
so select sum ifs and press tab
and we have our sums function now the
first step which column are we looking
at what are we finding out right which
is the sum range what sum do you want
for now we need
some of sales so select the sales column
and we have a simple key function here
let's hold ctrl again press shift and
hold shift together so we're holding
ctrl and shift key together and now we
are pressing lower arrow key once yes
the entire sales column has been
selected comma
now where do you want to look so we want
to look i mean which part of the table
you want to fetch right so this is the
region part we want to fetch right now
so again hold ctrl and shift together
lower arrow key the entire column is
selected
now the next last part so we want to
look into the both of the columns that
is sales column and region column now
which type of data you want so for now
we want to western type of data that is
the sales data which is happening only
in west right so we'll select this cell
with
the data as west or you can also
manually enter it for now let's select
the data so i'm selecting the cell f7
which has uh data as west
right now let's close the parenthesis
and press enter so there you go you have
the sales happening in the western
region and you can also try to format it
in the form of currency so let's use
dollars
since it is based on american states so
let's use dollars so there you go now we
are having the sales data of west now
let's try to copy the same to all the
four cells and uh for now here let's
type in east
and this can be
south
right and this can be your central
there you go
right
now you can also copy the same formula
and make minor edits to it so here
instead of f8 you can select uh east
so where is east here
and press enter so you have the sales
related to east now let's try to edit
f9 with
south
select south region enter so you have
south sales and what remaining is
central so let's edit central as well
and press enter so there you go right
now you have all the separate sales data
from west east south and central
now again
uh you might want a bit more granularity
in data right or in your reports right
like you wanted to find the sales data
happening in west and you wanted to find
out the category based on only
furnitures so your manager will ask you
okay a fantastic job so now just give me
another minute detail on the data i want
to calculate the sales happening on west
based on category furniture
right so he wants furniture or he wants
to office supplies only right you can
also do that it's not an issue at all
now let's try to copy this cell and
paste it here and sales invest let's add
another input here on furniture
right now you wanted to calculate the
sales happening in west region only on
furniture so you can also do that now
we can use the same formula as well just
copy paste the formula here right and
you can add a few things here when you
try to add a comma
it will automatically generate the next
criteria so it is expecting that you are
looking for adding another criteria
right now which column you want you want
category so let's select category you
want to select all the cells same trick
ctrl shift lower key
and again press comma
and you wanted to select only uh
furniture so select on furniture cell
then now press enter so there you go we
successfully have the sales data from
west region based on category only
furniture so that's how you do sumps in
excel you can also add a few more
details to it like in furniture you can
also look only for tables so here you
can see in west region we have furniture
sales data and we have sales data of
west region based on furniture which
includes only tables you can also do
that using summers function in the same
way all you have to do is select the sub
category column and select the cell
which has the data as tables so this is
how you use summits in excel
how to create dropdown list in excel now
for that we might want to switch to the
practical mode
now we are on our excel spreadsheet and
here you can see i'm trying to create an
calendar for the employees in the
company where you might have to you know
write down the
day and month and year or week of your
birth date or maybe your joining date or
maybe also your last working day right
this might be useful for all the
employees to you know
avoid them from writing it down manually
so how do i create it so it takes a few
simple steps all it takes is some data
validation methods and also there is an
exclusive video specifically made on
data validation in excel link to which
is in the description box below or you
can search it on our official youtube
channel
now you can see that uh the word
calendar is on the first cell that is a1
but we have four cells below it that is
a3 b3 c3 and d3 so you might want to add
this to all the cells right like maybe
in the middle so for that you can do the
option of margin center also there is a
tutorial on version center about all the
options available in this particular
thing so you can go through that also
and yeah we have done the first step now
all we need is day month year and week
so in a calendar or in a month you'll
have days from 28 29 30 or 31 days right
so let's create a list or the drop down
menu for that so that whenever you click
it right so whenever you click on that
particular cell you will have the list
of
all the days available right so
let's get started with that
let's create a new sheet
so why are we creating a new sheet you
won't want that all the numbers in your
calendar sheet right over here right so
for that so we are creating a new sheet
and all the data will be available here
so here let's write down the days
first and here
the second number
also you can use the option of flash
fill so that you can you know
reduce the effort here so you can see
the flash full option over here all you
need to do is select the cells and drag
them down
until you get your required dates right
so let's keep it to
31 days like when you have the days
so these will be your days and
here
now the next option was month right yeah
month and year
now using the same flash fill option you
will
you know add the months into your sheet
so this will be
sunday
so excel has this smart flash full
option where you can just drag the data
and everything will be filled according
to your requirements so sunday to
saturday
now the next one right that is your
month
so same as the before process will
create
january
and you can use the flash fill option
and all the way up to december now the
last one was the
year so
1990
and
1991
so you can select the cells and flash
fill
up to
2022 maybe
yeah 2022 should be good enough
now this is the flashflow option you
have here and also we have an exclusive
tutorial on flashville all together you
can go through it for a detailed
explanation as well
now coming back to the original sheet
so this is where you create your
drop down list right so select the cell
where you want to add the drop down list
navigate to data and then here is your
data validation menu
so we have a variety of data validation
options over here there is an exclusive
tutorial on that you can go through it
for now we will look into the list
option only
because we want to create a drop down
list right so here it will ask for
source
click on the source here the source bar
right
now navigate to sheet number two where
we have the days options
select the range
so this will be your range
and select ok
also you can add some message here right
what you can do is
in case if there is an error or
something
right you don't want that to be
happening so all you need to do is
write down select from drop down
select from drop down only
so this could be a message select from
drop down only the title is
select options or just options
in case if there is an error you can
write down your title as invalid data
and you can write down the messages
please select
drop down only
so
in case of someone tries to write as 32
or 33 to check the integrity of your
data validation then they will encounter
an error and an error message and then
they must be understanding
what exactly they try to do and if it's
correct or wrong right so this is to
make sure that whatever the data you
enter is correct and valid
so okay and here you can see select from
the drop-down list only options with
option list has title and let's try to
enter 32 right and when you press enter
you will see
an error
so the error messages invalid data
please try to select from drop down only
so you can go for a retry and select the
drop down
right so let's eliminate them and
now select something from the drop down
so let's take it as
maybe 10
right so this is how you clear the day
one now let's try to do with the month
same data validation option
settings will be list
and source will be
this one
i think i made a mistake here so let's
cancel this and go back to sheet2 and
rename this as our week
yeah now coming back to the month again
it will be a list
and the source will be in sheet 2
navigate to the sheet 2 and select your
range and the input message the same
options
select from drop down only
error alert title will be invalid data
this one will be
please select
from
drop down
okay and that's done
now let's continue with here as well
let's quickly do the same
it will be a list
source will be
in sheet 2.
this is your list press ok
and lastly the week
same
process
it will be a list
source will be in your sheet too
the input message
options
title invalid data
drop down
only
right so your drop down list is ready
now so the mult will be anything so
currently we have me and er can be
anything anywhere so let's take it as
1997
and we can be
you know the adjacent week and so what
was 10th of may
let's check our calendars
it was a saturday
so it was a saturday and that's how you
create a drop down list in excel and if
you want you can also add borders to
your calendar
right
so that's how it's done
so on my screen you can see an example
excel budget template theme
so on my screen you can see a column
where you have the debit amount
so in the i column we have all the
amount what we are spending for a month
and on the right column will be the
balance amount or the running balance of
that for example you can see that there
is a row number five where the debit
amount is eight thousand for a change
levis and it is done through upi payment
now if i change this value of 8000 to
4000 something
then you can see that these running
balance will automatically change you
can see that currently the running
balance is 73 000 and if i change this
value from 8000 to 4000 then all the
running balances will change
let's do that so for that let's press
enter
there you go you can see that the number
has been changed successfully and all
the values from the running balance are
also changed until the last day which is
the march 30th
now how is this working and not just
that you can see that we have also
included what is the total debit amount
in january and what is the running
balance that is the total available
balance
after one lakh has been debited into the
account in the month of february as
february income
now the current available balance is
one lakh thirteen thousand two hundred
and the total expense in february is one
lakh four thousand five hundred right
how am i doing all this looks so much
interesting right now let's do this
practically so for that i have already
created a new sheet and i have included
all the data
that we have used previously
the income of that particular month and
all the expenses of that particular
month
now without further ado let's begin to
implement the excel budget template now
our first step happens to be converting
all the data into a natural table so you
know that in excel all the data values
are stored in the form of a database by
default so it happens to be our duty to
convert the database tag table into the
pure table type table so for that select
all your data and press ctrl t and there
you go you have an option to convert
this data into a table
and remember to check this particular
checkbox
and tell your excel that your table has
headers
so we do have headers here so now press
ok
and your table will be converted into a
natural table now let's type in the
formulas
so now let's select the cell j2
and type in the formula
so what are we doing here is we are
trying to
add the sum of j2 plus h3
so which is this particular cell
and
removing i3 that is this particular
debit amount so this formula is used for
checking the running balance
let's press enter and there you go
so it means that you received
one lakh rupees in the month of january
and out of that one lakh you spend
fifteen thousand rupees for something
maybe your educational or something and
then the remaining running balance out
of one lakh rupees is eighty five
thousand rupees now let's copy the same
formula to all these cells
and there you go
now the running balance has been
calculated for all the cells here
now remember the monthly income
available balance and debit for january
and final balance now let's try to
calculate that for all the three months
so here we have three months that is
january february and march
now let's do a simple calculation to
find out the available balance of that
one and the total debit made by that
person in that particular month
the formula is really simple all you
have to do is use a sum function and
calculate the sum of all these values
and done right
there you go so the total expense of the
month january is 93 800 rupees
now let's calculate the total debit of
february month same formula that is
calculating the sum of
all the expenses made in the month of
february
day
now let's also calculate the sum of all
the expenses in the month of march
done
so we have the final values of all the
total expenses made in those particular
months
now
let's calculate the final balance
now i think i forgot one important thing
so before we calculate the final balance
we need to find out the available
balance
that is the available balance after
one lakh rupees is created into our
account and along with the savings that
you have from your previous month right
so that we have a simple formula
now which all we are doing is just
adding the
uh income
cell with the balance cell that's all
there you go
now after crediting one lakh rupees and
adding up the
balance of that particular month that is
we have 13200 remaining from the month
of january and the month of february we
have income of one lakh so the total
amount is eleven thousand three hundred
and
no no it is one lakh thirteen thousand
two hundred yeah
now we have the final balance that is
the difference between the available
balance and
the debit made in that particular month
so in the month of february we had a
total balance of one lakh thirteen
thousand two hundred and the total debit
of one lakh four thousand five hundred
so the final remaining values as eight
thousand seven hundred
similarly the same formula has been
applied for the month of march and the
final balance we have is thirty seven
thousand three
so that's how you implement budget
template in excel all simple formulas
and you have all the numbers at your
fingertips
so first let's understand what exactly
is mis report in excel
so mis stands for management information
system mis reports provide data on
different categories for accurate
decision making
so mis in excel is a procedure to create
interactive report using microsoft excel
so mis reports help management to access
the performance of organization and
allow faster decision making so if you
know to create the mis reports using
various business intelligence tools such
as excel then you might find a very good
job opportunity in a well established
company now let us try to learn how to
create mis report using excel in a
practical mode so let's get back to the
microsoft excel if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
so here you can see that i've got some
sales data of various car manufacturing
companies and i've also got some slices
so using these slices i can get the
real-time information from the dashboard
so i'll select an ear from the first
slicer and i'll go into the second
slicer and i'll select a company
now i'll select bmw and suv type so we
have the data of all the suv types
cars manufactured by bmw car
manufacturing company in the year 2018.
now let's start and create something
similar to this one
so how did i create this mis report
let's go through this in a step-by-step
way
so on my screen you can see that we have
created a completely new excel workbook
and we have some sample data with 5 rows
and 20 columns
so this particular data is based on the
manufacturer year and the car
manufacturing company and the type of
the car manufactured and number of cars
manufactured in that particular year and
also the price of that particular car
now to create mis reports we need to
play around favorite tables so we also
have tutorials on pivot tables and you
can go through that in our simply learn
youtube channel and also we will try to
link those in the description box below
now let's select the entire data
and go into the insert ribbon
and there you can see the first option
that is pivot table
so after selecting the pivot table
option it will show this particular
dialog box where it will ask you for the
range of cells you need to select and
the next one is to create the pivot
table in this same sheet or a new sheet
so we'll take a new sheet here
now select ok and there you have the
pivot table here so first you have an
empty pivot table and on the right side
you can see we have pivot table fields
now you can either drag these options
into the rows and columns or you can
also click it so now let's drag and drop
these
first we will select here
and card
followed by that we will take type
quantity and price to columns
so there you go we have our pivot table
now
let's select all the data in the pivot
table
and again let's get back to the insert
option
and here you can see an option called
pivot chart select that and you will
have various pivot chart options here
now you can select any one which you can
prefer or which you like or whichever
you think can represent your data in a
best way possible so now let's go with
column chart first
let's select okay and we have our column
chart over here
now this happens to be our first chart
now let's create a few more charts
so to create few more charts we will go
back to the same original data
select again insert and pivot table
now again a new worksheet
so here we have another empty pivot
table in the similar way let's drag the
same
data into rows and columns
there you go and again we will select
all the data and create a pivot chart
go to insert option
pivot chat and now let's try to select
pie chart
select ok
and we have our pie chart over here
now let's try to create one more
same procedure select table select pivot
table then create new worksheet for the
new pivot table
and now drag and drop the data
now let's go to insert again
let's select all the data
go to insert option and pivot chart
now let's try to select the bar chart
select ok and there we have our bar
chart
now
remember the first chart we created that
is in sheet 2 this one so we will try to
move all the charts to this particular
table or this particular worksheet
so let's get back to the sheet number
three right click and you can see an
option called pivot chart analyze so
from here you can move the chart select
the option of moving the chart and don't
select the first one select the object
in option and select the sheet number to
which you want to move this chart for
now we want to move this chart to sheet
number two select that press ok
now we have the chart move to the sheet
number two
and in the same way let's go to the
sheet number four
and let's move this particular chart to
sheet number two
there you go the chart got moved to
sheet number two
now
you can insert the slices
so we have selected the third sheet or
third chart and inside the pivot chart
analyze option we have an option of
inserting the slicer
now
we will insert the slices for year
car
and
type
now select ok and you will have all the
three slices onto your sheet now let's
rearrange them
so i'm just organizing them in a
neat way
there you go
and you can also customize your designs
for all the charts
so that they look a little more better
now
if you see
if i make some changes only one chart
will be interacting for this
right so if i select ferrari and year
2020 and
option as sports you can see only one
chart is interacting to these particular
slices why because all these slices are
connected to just one chart here so you
need to make sure that all the slices
are connected to all the three charts
what we created so let's erase all the
filters and select one slicer at a time
right click and you will see an option
of report connections
select that and you see that the
connections are only connected to the
pivot table 3. so select the remaining
pivot tables as well select ok and in
the same way select the second slicer
select the report connection option
connect pivot table 1 and 2 and select
ok
and in the same way the third one
so now all the slices are connected to
all the pivot charts
now if you make some changes here they
will respond automatically in the same
way
now let's select the fourth company the
year 2019 and hatchback option and you
have all the cars which were made in the
year 2019 from ford company in the
segment of hatchback
so this was the sample dataset that we
worked on now you can also work on some
complex datasets such as this superstore
dataset
now one thing you need to make sure that
when you're working with excel mis they
need to make sure that all the macros
are disabled on your dataset and you
convert the entire data into the regular
table format of excel right now excel is
considering this particular data as a
database so for that you need to select
all the data press ctrl t and then
convert the entire data in the form of
tabular data and also don't forget to
click this icon which reads my table has
headers so the first row is the headers
now let's select ok and your entire data
will be converted into tabular form
now let's reset this to the normal
type which has the clear color not all
the fancy colors now the entire data is
converted from the dbms to the tabular
form and now he can start implementing
the mis reports in pivot tables so
that's how you work on mis report in
excel with that we have come to an end
of this tutorial on mis report in excel
so what is excel macro you do certain
daily tasks and daily reports or monthly
reports that you generate and you use
data from your excel and you scrub data
and
you basically have the same things
performed or done on the excel sheets
every time and every day or monthly or
bi-weekly or any number of times that
you open your excel
you
remove certain columns you add certain
things and you
change certain values and
these are the things that you do
an n number of times on an excel
and this can all be done
by simple automated
wave which is macros so what it
does is it is a set of tasks that you
can execute as many number of times as
you want
when you create a macro basically what
it does is it will record all your mouse
clicks and keystrokes
basically if for example you have your
monthly accounts report that is there
and it comes every day and you have to
put it and
extract certain data and remove certain
columns
that you do every time that you open
that sheet for instance you remove that
column i
which has the obsolete values offer of
your accounts or the sheets
that you have and you remove that column
and you edit some names you add such
things every time that you open that
report and then you format it in a
proper way and send it to your
management so this can all be done
in a simple
running script called macros so what you
do is you record those
mouse clicks and keystrokes and record a
macro for it save it and next time
tomorrow when you come you just run that
macros
and this will do everything for you and
you do not have to do that same tedious
task every day so this is basically
a set of codes or a task that you can
execute and automate and which can be
done a number of times
so
it makes your life easy
now
so next thing is how you actually
activate the macros in your excel
it's a simple uh tab that you need to
add
in the ribbon section which i'll be
showing you across
and this will enable the macros on your
excel so you go to files
go to options
and then you need to customize a ribbon
click customize ribbon
and then there is a developer tab which
you see here it should be activated so
you just need to select that
click on the
tick mark and just click ok so this will
add a developer tab here and
this will enable the macro so now you
you have your data and you can run
macros or record a macro and run it over
on your excel
there is also an option to do it a
different way right click on any of the
tabs on the ribbon
customize ribbon and you can
add or remove
your macros from here
so this is two ways that you need to
that you can activate uh your macros so
how you record a macro is the next thing
so here i have a work orders sheet that
i receive every day or one of you will
receive every day and how you record a
macro you have certain set of tasks that
you do
and
you know this report has so many things
that are obsolete which you do not need
which has to be put across to your
management or your
for your use so how you record or
start a macro you go to the developer
tab and start recording a macro as soon
as you click on this record macro button
it will start
recording your key strokes on the mouse
mouse clicks
and you can save that and run it as a
script in the next sheet that you do so
this is the sheet that i have
and
we'll try to run a macros on this and
see what it does
so here i have and
this actually works this way
i need to go to the developer tab and
start recording a macro
so when i click record macro it
starts uh recording my mouse clicks and
keystrokes so in this sheet i have to
you know remove some columns and
the columns that are obsolete and the
data that looks
weird here should be removed and all
what i need is the work order number the
district and the tactician name and the
kind of service that we provide and
the requested workday
the cost
and the payment so this is what i want
and i do it every day when i receive the
sheet and i have to
make these changes and
send it across to the accounts team
so what i do is i simply
automate this by running a macro
so
i go to
let's see how it records the macro
i click record macro i save it as work
order
accounts
and i'll add a little description like
work order
for
account
first
click okay
and
see what i do is basically i
add the
borders first
so that the data looks proper
and then i do not want this column i
delete it i do not want the number of
technicians that are there
i do not want all these and i also want
the labor hours the account and what
kind of payment this is very crucial for
the fmst i do not want any of these
obsolete data
so i just delete this
okay
and then
i just want to have some cosmetic
changes done so
i make sure this
doesn't have any border
and
that's it this is the task that i
perform
every day i still don't need this
and i go to the developer tab and click
stop recording so now i have the macro
save and when i have it i have
you know automated these all these steps
in one simple click
and how i execute it in another sheet so
i will show it across to you
the next thing so here i have the next
report that has to be
changed or formatted and send it across
so i simply go the next morning and go
to the developer tab
and
go to the macro and i have this macro
save which we ran the just now and i
simple with a single click i will be
able to do these daily tasks
and execute in a flash so i just click
run and it does the rest for me i have
my report ready and is in a proper
format that is required and it can be
sent across so here as we see it is done
in a single click by running
a simple macro continuing our
work on macro we can simply do this by a
single click of a button by adding a
button so
what you have to do is go to the
developer tab and in the control section
you will see the insert option
when you click on the insert drop down
you will see a form controls and you can
say select a button
and here i select a button
and the mouse changes to across
and you can add
your macro and assign it
so as we have saved it work order
accounts as a macro
and when i just
assign that macro to this button
i can edit the text by
making this
work order
account just to make it simple
okay
and
now if you see if i just click this
button it will run the macro
and format our sheet
so this is how we run the macros in a
single click of a button by adding the
button
there is another alternative way to go
to the macros in instead of the
developer tab and you go to the view
button
and then go to macros at the end
you can view macros you can record and
you can edit your macro so when i click
view macros it will show you what are
the macros that i have and that i can
run
and you can simply run it
alternatively
and you can record a macro as well
instead of from the developer tab if you
just click on record macro it will do
the same functions that we do
from the developer tab
the next thing is to edit the macro how
do you edit your macro you have
to use a simple application in excel
which is the vba visual basic
application to edit your macro you go to
the developer tab
and then click on visual basic this
literally opens another window
like this and you will see the module
that you have been working on
and you can edit the
macro here so as we see
if you go back to the excel
we see that
our sheet we have been working on
the sheet and it has the column still k
and the actual sheet is this so if i go
to the visual basic editor
and
i'll make sure they know i remove the
columns that are existing from the
column m
and i just delete that
and i click
run
i go back to my sheet
and you see
these changes are not there
okay
this is your old
macro and this is our new macro
as we see this sheet has the rush column
which is the priority
of my orders
so these are the things that we can edit
with the vba
so here we are what is vba visual basic
application it is basically a visual
basic application language that is used
for macros in excel
so what it basically does visual basic
for application is a programming
language of excel that helps you
automate task by writing macros we have
seen how we use macros how it simplifies
our tedious daily tasks
by running a simple macro
now to help us
you know
write these macros and help us get the
best use of our
abilities to
ease our work and automate our task we
use vba
so
why vba there are many advantages of
using vba and why we prefer vba in
macros for excel
so
basically it is a very simple language
it saves time in
performing tedious tasks you have number
of tasks that you do every day as we
have seen in the previous
section
how we uh you can simplify your daily
task by just running a simple macro and
this vba helps us in performing those
steps
in a very simple manner
another thing is it supports
english like statements there are
multiple statements that you can use and
which are very basic english language
statements
and this can help us or it is very easy
to program or
code or edit these commands you can
select a range you can it is like
if an else statement and things like
that we will look into those in details
in the next sections
now one more thing is it improves the
functionality of excel by allowing you
to make excel behave the way you want
there are multiple functions that you
perform in excel like selecting a number
of rows or columns or selecting a set of
cells
in particular you do it on a daily basis
so these things can easily be performed
and easily be edited and executed by
using vba
we will look into those in detail now
what is the vba editor interface this is
particularly
an interface which you will have uh look
in detail
where where you can edit your commands
or your code for your excel
now how this is achieved we will see it
here
now these are the this is basically the
vba editor interface where you can see
the uh
this is the toolbar section where it
shows all the options where in undo or
save or file they will see those details
in the next section this is basically
the toolbar section of the vba editor
interface the next thing is the menu bar
menu bar as we all know it is simply it
shows you the menu wherein you have all
the options like file edit view insert
insert is the one very important uh menu
bar option
and when you can insert different
modules and buttons and all we'll look
into those in details run is one more
important thing all these things fall
under menu bar
the next thing is the vba code window
maybe a code window as it says is the
code window where your actual code
resides
wherein you can go into it and edit the
code or write the codes and select the
different range of functions that you
can perform and this is basically the
bdb vba code window
where you
edit your or write your codes the next
thing is the project explorer project
explorer is simply like a windows
explorer but this is in particular is
specific to your
vba
wherein it shows the different options
that are there the
excel sheets or the worksheets that
you're working on or the modules that
you have saved and so on basically it is
an explorer for your vba like a windows
explorer which is for the file explorer
the next thing is the properties window
properties windows shows you the
properties of the worksheet that you're
working on for instance here we are
working on the sheet 2
and it shows the properties what are the
kind of uh
worksheet that we have the page breaks
the right to left whether it is enabled
or not the name of the sheet and so on
whether it's visible and things like
that
the next thing is the immediate window
and the
watch window
now what is the immediate window
immediate window is basically a tool or
a window wherein you can run and execute
simple
lines of codes individual excel code
that you can run it will allow you to
test individual lines
which is very useful and handy when
you're writing and debugging codes
the output if the lines that you execute
can be seen here in the immediate window
whereas watch window watch window is
similar to it but it displays the value
of the watch expression in its current
current state
so this can be extremely useful again
while we are debugging the vba code
adding a watch is a great utility and we
will see uh the use the
advantages of having a watch window in
your
vba interface
so these are the things that we'll learn
and look into it in detail in the coming
section now we continue our topic for
visual basic per application
for macros and
i'm going to show you how to
you know run some codes and run some
macros and codes and
perform some simple to complex tasks
using the vba for macros so
there are two ways to open the visual
basic application
and the first thing is you can run alt
f11 click on the sheet and then just
press and it will open the
um visual basic for application
window or alternatively you can just go
and click on the visual basic and it
will open the
sheet for you i mean the code window for
you and as we have discussed before
these are the windows that we see this
is the code window and this is the
project explorer
and
this is the immediate window
i will you can run some
testing codes immediately it will show
you the output so here we see the
project explorer window where we see the
modules and all
for our visual basic for applications
so as we see the code is empty here
we'll try to record a macro and see
how the code develops okay so i just go
here and click record macro
and i save it as
a format
and
columns
okay
this quickbook and i just saved it click
ok
and it has started recording so now what
i'll do is as
make it simple and i just delete some
columns here
okay
i do not need this
i delete this either wait i want this i
want the amount of payment
parts cost labor hours i do not want
this
number of technicians forget it
okay
and i go for the left and see what all
do i need i need i don't need this
i delete all these and
i just expand this so that it's clearly
visible
and then i want to change the format i
mean the hot
so
i select this
[Music]
and i change it to time stream
okay
go back to my
developer tab click stop recording it is
saved
okay
now i go back to my
code
and see
the
macro here
so we see the macro here and we can see
in detail what it looks like so
we see the code what it's doing and what
the macro
run has generated the code with so we
see we have basically the name of the
macro is format columns
and what it is doing we're just
selecting the columns and
deleting some we are checking the range
on some columns ee select that is the e
column that we have selected
and then again so on
and
the next thing is the font selection
that is mentioned
we are changing it to times new roman
size is 11 so
it is basically a basic vba code so it
starts with the sub and it should end
with end sub so this is the code or a
format of the vba code that it looks
like and we'll try to do some basic
functions with the
vba and discuss this in further details
so for ease of explanation i have picked
up a blank
spreadsheet and
i'll try to explain some basic uh
functions and
the commands and the codes that we use
to
accomplish the
task that we with vba
so as we see this is a blank sheet and i
have selected a new module for it
so here i start the code and as it says
it starts with sub and
i am specifying the
module name as
number so i'll just try to make it quite
simple and
you know so we as soon as we enter the
sub it sends with the end sub and so
this is the
start of the code and this is the end of
the code and whatever is there should be
here and this is the name of the
code of the macro now uh i'll explain it
further about the dim statement why is
it used and what does it use for
so dim is basically a keyword which is
the
short form of dimension and it is used
to declare variables in the
vba so here i am trying to specify a
variable called x and how i'm going to
do it i
will
have it as a number or an integer or
anything so here in this example i'll
put it as an integer or a number okay
and as i put as it populates the prompt
so i select integer
and for example i select the number to
be
500
okay
and here i'm trying to assign a
variable integer
a cell a value of
500 with a
keyword
so
where exactly i want to put this you
will see it when you execute the code
okay
range
i am selecting
it should be under course where i'm
going to put the value of x as and i
close the bracket and
what should be the value
we will
value should be x
so now as i click
run sub or you can do it with the
by running the alt
f5 key and it will run the
code so you see here in the excel sheet
it executes the value of the cell b5 to
be 500 so this is one simple function
that you can do
with the uh dimension keyboard or dim
keyword
and you can assign the value as integers
now proceed we proceed further with
certain more examples some more examples
and how we assign the string value as a
as a text or
[Music]
something else okay
now i'm going to show you what dim can
be executed used as to set variables
team can be used as a
double
when double is basically a longer form
of single variable it usually takes more
space but uses uh needs more larger
numbers okay and then you can set
double and i just don't specify it and
we can use date
it basically stores the date values okay
and then again string so what string
does if you use string it stores the
text it can contain numbers it will have
some text as calculations or anything
can be performed so these are the basic
thing that i will cover
and
you can also use different
values for it so i will discuss this in
the next example
okay
so in the next example i'll try to set
or
use a string value for it and
i put it as a string
sub string
value
this is my name
so as soon as i hit enter it ends with
the answer prompt and now i can give my
code
so
i put it as dim book as
string
okay
now
i'm trying to use
to name a country or put a value of a
country to one of the
cells so
let's see
how it goes and
i select country
and in country i select
mark
[Music]
okay
now what is the value or the cell that
basically takes the or we will put the
name of the country at so i have to
specify a range and as soon as i hit
it goes and i have to specify the
the cell
here so here i put it as g
and
four
okay
so i close it
and i put a value to it what value i am
going to assign it is a country
okay
now
i'll try to run this code very simply
and see
g4
the name
populates as a country here so
this is a dim keyword you being used as
a string in our vda code
so
we can also use uh
vba to you know pop up a message or an
alert or a kind of a button or a message
pop-up pops up when you execute this
code so this basically can be uh
executed using uh
the
code here which i'm going to put
and we use the
okay let's give it a value
i'm going to name it as double value and
again the name keyword i'm going to use
the
keyword as double okay y double is used
is basically uh it gives a longer it can
be used for a longer form of single
variable takes it usually takes more
space and larger numbers and we'll try
to assign it okay now i'm going to pop
up a message in this which says value of
a is so and so so i'm going to give
value of a as
2 5 0
okay
and how it pops up a message okay
so there is a message box
which you know can be used and it will
give you a value i mean it will prompt
you to enter the value what kind of
button you want and
you you can enter the text and you can
enter so here i'm going to
write a code which
you know which gives a pop-up message a
message box saying that the value of a
is so and so
the value of a
i'm going to put it in percent
code
so it actually takes the value of a
okay
now that's it
and let's try to run this and you will
see a message by popping message box
popping up
okay so the value of
the message box
pops up saying the value of a is 250
so
in the next example i am going to
write a code wherein you know you can
give a value or a string you can assign
it to a selected cell and this basically
used when you
have some
you know when you have a
task of you know giving a value to a
particular cell or you have to assign a
text
or say something about a report okay so
this let's see how it goes and we use
the
i will say
it as
fun with some procedures
this is the name and
again name
so here i am going to i am going to give
a user input and it will be as a
string
okay you can give anywhere i mean any
string or any statement what my user
input will be i will define it here
because
[Music]
this
is the
report
for
eeg
let's make it simple
okay
and where i'm going to put it is
in the active cell or the cell
that i
have it
select okay what will be the value
the value will be the user input
i have defined user input as this is a
report for vba so this cell turns into
you this is a report for vba
i run this
and you see this
so in some cases you need to run this
and
you know it makes life quite simple when
you use vba for this as we have seen
before we have used message box now i'm
going to use the same message box
to
display my name or you can use it to
display your name so let's see how it
goes
i'm going to name it as
name
okay and it's very simple you have to
define a message box
which displays your name
and i'm going to put it under course
that my name is
and we'll try to
run it
see here
so it pops up a message saying that my
name isn't fun so
this is a message box that you can
display and i can do anything with this
this is a pbasics
[Music]
okay i run it again and it pops this
message so these are the things that you
can use to customize or you know when
you open an excel sheet or try to run a
workshop or a report and it pops up a
message customary welcome messages that
you can customize or
you know define a
report or kind of
data in it and this can be used using
run using the message box
and now i have another good example
wherein you know you can write a code to
tell excel what is the value of
a cell or what is the number that is
there in the cell so
here it is
i put this up
okay
number
and
it will again
populate a message box
which
will set it to
the
the entered
[Music]
value
is
and it should tell me
which or i specify
which cell it is that we are going to
find the value of
okay
so i give a range
of
i have to give it in codes
i'm going to
go to complete it
and it should tell me the
value of the number that is present in
the cell
a1
okay
it ends let's try to run it
run it and it will give me the value so
this is how we can use excel to
determine or show or populate a message
box which will give us the value of the
number that is there in the cell so here
i can change it to
a
4
as well
and try to run it
and it will give me the number so
this is simple way of you know
populating a message box which will tell
us the
value of it
let me show you one more simple example
where in a message box pops up on a
welcome message that can be
set when you open the
excel or worksheet so
so let's
[Music]
name it as auto
open
and then
again message box i want it to populate
and
what does it say
i put it in quotes welcome
to
our
worksheet
of workshop
it's very simple you just run it and
see
it pops up a message saying welcome to a
workshop so these are the
one more this is one more way where you
can you know run the code or to simple
welcome message on
excel
next i'm going to show you a code
wherein you can give a value or assign a
value to a particular cell by simple
curve
so
we name it as add value
now i specify the range i mean where
i am going to specify a cell
where
the value will be given to the
cell
now i'm going to
give it as v5
okay to put it as codes
close the parenthesis
what is the value that i'm going to give
value equals
2 5 0
okay so now with this code i mean i'm
going to assign a value of 250 to the
cell b5 let's see
run it see
again i do it to p10
okay
so this is how you can assign a value to
a particular cell
now i can run the same thing and give a
range of cells i mean
let me make it very simple here
i give it as
b1
through
b
5
as four five zero so
let's see what it does
see here i'm going i'm specifying the
range to be b1 through b5 so it is doing
it for the whole range
okay and
then i can give a another set of range
here
like
let me specify it
range to be
[Music]
c
one
i have to give it a course
it will give me an error
c1 colon
c4
and i separate it with a comma and i can
specify another range so the next one
will be d1
to
d4
and then i close the codes
close the parenthesis
however the value that i give is
let's say
2 3 0
and i try to run it
so it gives the value
of c1 through c4 and d1 through d4 as
230 as we specified in the
code
so this is one of one more example where
you can assign values to
the uh
so range of cells or cells and with the
vba
one more thing i can
you know assign a value to a particular
cell by specifying these cells it's a
very simple just specify the cells like
six
comma
seven
okay
and
i close the parenthesis
i assign a value to it
value equals
10.
let's see
see
here it assigns the value to that
particular cell that we have specified
row 6
and column step
okay
so this is one more example where you
can assign values to particular cells
okay in the next example uh there will
be a scenario where you need to select a
range of cells in your sheet so this can
also be done this task can also be
performed using vba
so
i will show you how
this is our
let's say select a
range
okay and
and i am going to set a dim
variable as
example okay let's say it has example
and
what i'm doing is i'm specific range
because i need to select a range of
cells
okay
now i'm going to set the variable as
set example where i am going to define
the range of the cells that should be
selected
so let's say a
one
two
three
five
okay this will be the
selection
and what i'm going to
set the value okay i am going to set the
value
example
i'm going to give it a value of
256. so
let's see how it pans out
okay so here i'm selecting a set of
cells a range of cells and i'm going to
assign a value
with this function
so this makes it quite simple and this
will be used in a regular daily task
wherein you know there is there will be
a scenario where you
have to select a set of cells and give a
give a value to it so you can do it with
a click of a button with the vpn
now i can simply tweak this with
you know by just selecting it so
there is
i'll remove this
and
instead of assigning a value i'll just
put an option to select it
now let's just run it and see what
happens next
okay so this is one way of you know just
selecting it okay and then you see it
becomes easier for you to copy paste and
do some functions so you can select this
and you can assign a value and you can
also
give a set of values to a particular
range or cells with these codes
now what if i want to do a selection of
the same
rows and columns in the next sheet
and i can do this with the
set of another set of commands so i will
show you how
so here let's say you know we said the
same thing
and we specify the worksheets okay
worksheets
i want it in sheet2 okay so i just put
it as g2 and i activate it basically
activating it and now i'm going to
specify the worksheet
to
and what is the range that i'm going to
select the same thing okay
the range will be
a1
to
d5
okay
what i'm going to do i'm going to select
it
okay
and see what happens here
okay okay
so here i am selecting the worksheet too
and i'm activating it and i'm going to
assign range and i'm going to select it
so i can just
copy the same or select the same set of
cells
in the next sheet
okay now when there will be
uh as i said there will be
you know by requirement where you need
to copy some cell contents and paste it
to another location so how you do that
it's uh again a simple
code that you can write
and let's say
let's say it has a
copy and paste i'm just making it simple
by giving something that we can
understand and relate
[Music]
copy
paste
okay
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
select this range
and i'm going to copy it and paste it
somewhere here okay
so let me just remove this and
i'll show you
first we have to specify the range where
you want to copy the cells okay so let's
say it is again a1
it should be in course
[Music]
okay
then
what i'm going to do is
once you select this the selection that
you have
should what should be the function and i
am going to specify the selection
and the function should be
copying it
okay so i just
said that
and where i'm going to paste it so i
have to now specify the range
where i have to
paste this selection
and you can just mention the
column here let's say
g
uh
10
okay
and close it
i'm going to select it
and then where i'm going to paste it i
can do it in this sheet okay
active sheet
and
paste
so
we are selecting a range of cells
selection
and that selection what we are doing is
we will copy it and now we are going to
specify the range where you are going to
select it and then
paste it
quite simple
let's see
okay
see
and
you can just change it so it is visible
okay
so this makes uh quite easy
and you can done it
the next scenario will be like
when you need to
get the count of the number of cells
like you have to have a selection and
you need to count the number of cells so
this can also be done and it's quite
easy
i am going to show it to you
let's say the sub the
account
cells
should always be relatable so that you
know you remember and you understand
what is
the output and why you're using it and
i'm going to set a
variable let's say
i'm going to set an example for this and
what we're going to do is we are going
to specify a range first okay we'll
specify the range of
the cells that we are going to
that we need to count basically so i'm
going to set a variable as a range and
then
what we are going to do is
example
and we specify the range
you can specify the range or your
selection where you count the where you
need the count of the number of cells
so a1
now how you want the output you want it
you want a message box to pop up
so you will set a message box
and
what should it give you will give you
the count of the
variable that is the variable is here is
examples okay so
it will count the number of cells in
this
area
okay uh
let's see it says
okay here i think i'm listed so i just
specify the
number here
and let's see so it gives you the number
of
count in this is 20. okay
now let's see i want to
six
so it gives you the selection so it's
quite simple it will be very useful in
our daily task and then you need to
count the number of cells so this is one
way to get it
well i can further tweak this and to
determine the
or count the number of rows or columns
so it's again very simple
i just need to do some changes here i
have to set the
column count
so if i want to
calculate the number of columns
just
let's see how it should calculate or
give the message
the number of columns here
see
it gives there are five columns okay one
two
one two three four five okay
so it gives us the number of columns
here
if i change it to
it should give me
four
followers
okay similarly you can count the number
of rows here
let's change it to rows
see
it says six rows out there
okay
should give me number
see so this way you can calculate the
number of
count the number of
cells number of columns number of rows
with this
the next thing i'm going to talk about
is the if statement if statement is one
of the
most widely used statement and
whoever is in programming i'm very much
familiar with this function so what it
does is we specify a condition if
condition is met then the out should
output should be such and such we can
specify the condition and it will check
whether that condition is there and if
it is
space i mean if it is
achieved then you will have to specify
the output as well so this can be
achieved with the if statement
okay and it is very easy because it is
it understands the basic uh english
language so it's not very complicated
and i'll show you how
so the syntax can be like this if
suppose you specify a condition
and if that condition is met
then the result you specify the
condition and the result
okay so this is one thing and then you
can specify the
else or else condition
where you know you specify the condition
too
then
the result should be
this
so here you are going to
specify two conditions or multiple
conditions where you specify
this and if it is there then result will
be this if it is this condition and then
the result will be something else
let's take an example wherein you have
to you have some scores or marks
and you have to
select the result you can't do this
manually
entering so just you can write a code
suppose for example
i have it here
okay
and
i specify as
if statement
okay
now i have to specify the
variables now i have two variables i
have a score and i have a
result and the score is an integer the
number and the result is a string pass
or fail so i specify this okay dim
score
i specify it as integer okay
and then
there's another variable that i have to
set
result
as
string
okay
now what the score will be the score i
have to specify the range
score i'm giving it as a range i mean
it's in my
cell a1
okay
i specify the range
what is it it is a value
okay sorry
should be a lot
okay
and then i'm specifying a condition here
if
score
value the variable
is greater than or equal so as i said
it's quite simple and it takes the basic
english
language functions
then
the
result result is another variable that i
have said result what it should be it
should be
in quotes
pass
okay
so
if this condition is met then the result
will be this okay
and now where i want to specify my
result i should give a range for that as
well so i give it in the next column or
any one
this is the basic uh
example
value should be
the result
okay let's see how it drops
see
says pass
change it to 40.
it doesn't give me anything because i
have specified only one condition here
okay
75 let's see how it runs
see
so this way it's very basic condition
that you are specifying you are
specifying two variables the score and
the result
and then you are giving a value for it
and you are specifying the condition if
the score is greater than then the
result should be passed
now in the next uh section uh
we will simply tweak this and use an if
then else statement we'll attach an else
statement with it and see we'll specify
another condition
and see so here again we'll use two
variables that is the score as integer
and the result as a string and let's uh
stick to the same values
and now
i'm going to specify it and if the score
is greater than 60
then
the result
so the result will be pass as it is
before
and then
i'm going to specify another condition
else
the result should be
should be
okay
okay
and now
i have to put it to the end if statement
i have to
specify the answer and the result will
be again in the value i mean the range
will be v1 so let's see if it is more
than 60 then it is passed otherwise it
is fake
okay this pass let's see
okay so we are specifying two variables
again we are giving at a range and we
are specifying one condition if this
condition is met the result is passed
otherwise else it is fail
so another set of example
uh the next statement that we use or we
we're going to discuss is the
loop statement that is the for loop
statement and why we use it there are
there are situations in
uh tasks that you need to execute and
you need to do it several number of
times
these are basically executed
sequentially it means one after another
so the first statement or the function
is executed and the next
is taken up so
and then the next and so on so these
loop statements allow us to execute a
statement or a group of statements
multiple number of times many number of
times and this happens only when the
first task or the first
task is done
and it executes that and it goes to the
next one so here we will discuss a
simple example
of the for loop statement
so let's see how it
works
and i'm going to set up a
loop statement okay again the
i'm going to make it as loop 1.
so here it is i have to specify the
variable that is dim
and i'm going to specify x as an integer
okay i'll try to execute it and then
explain it what happens and how it
executes okay for x equals to one two
okay let's see
and
i'm going to specify the range
range as
so what i'm going to do is basically i'm
going to fill the column a
from 1 to 24 with some value 1 from 1 to
24 with the values of 1
through 24 okay
so i'm setting up a
range
and how it ends is
it gives me a value
now it excuse this and goes to the next
so i'll explain you how so we are
setting up a loop we are setting up an
integer a variable x as integer and we
are setting the value of x to be 1 to 24
so here
for 1 it executes the first thing is it
it takes x as 1
and it fills in
a1
and then
the next value of x will be 2
and it goes to a2 and fills the value as
2. so just let's try to execute this and
you will see
the
row column a filled with 1 through 24
see
it's quite simple it executes one
condition
and then goes to the next and we are
defining it with the number of values
and the variable as x
and the number of values is going to be
24
okay so this is one basic example of a
for loop statement
now let's do some more uh addition to
this
uh
example by you know executing another
set of for loop
and giving the output and we'll code the
output to be the color coded ones in the
column b so how we do it it's a basic
simple example that i'm going to take
and again
what i'm going to do is i will have this
values here and i'm going to color code
the
b column with certain color index for
each number there will be a different
color so let's see
and
what i'm going to do is i'm only going
to change the
b
and what action is going here we put up
a value now we are going to
select it
and with this selection
what i'm going to do is it should select
it
and
it should color the interior with what
is the color index
okay
and the value of
x
and then i'm going to specify the
pattern what uh pattern it will take for
the
box to be color and i'm going to put it
as a solid
it will fill the whole thing with the
solid
and then i just execute it see
it takes this
color b
and it's coded like this
so these are the simple things that you
can set up with the
codes and for loop statements
so there are numerous examples and
exercises that you can perform tasks we
can perform with the vba
and this can be found in detail
next courses advanced courses
so what exactly is a user form so user
form is a graphical user interface that
helps you have an live interaction with
your worksheet which enables you to
enter or eliminate data from your excel
worksheet through the graphical user
interface
now let's get into the practical mode
and start the excel workbook now we have
launched our microsoft excel
so let us create a blank workbook for
now
now we have the blank workbook or
worksheet now before we get started with
the user forms in excel the fundamental
step is to enable the developer menu on
the toolbar here you can find the
developer menu so basically it will not
be enabled as default
to enable that you need to get into file
menu and inside the file menu you can
see the last menu that is the options
menu select that
and you will have a dialog box on your
screen
and inside that you need to go into the
customize ribbon option
and inside the customized ribbon option
you have the main tabs
scroll through the main tabs and here
you can find an option called developer
by default it will not be enabled it
will look something like this but to
enable that you need to select the check
option in this and click on that and
select ok now the developer option will
be enabled on your tool menu
so now you have your developer option on
your toolbar
so to get started with user forms in
excel click on the developer option and
here you can see visual basic
so click on that visual basic and now
you have your new window opened right on
your screen
so this is the visual basics for
applications
so here is where you create your user
forms
now to create a user form just select on
insert menu and you have the option
called user form
now a new user form will be created for
you
and that is user form 1.
so this is the user form which you can
design and enable to interact with your
worksheet and help you insert data or
eliminate data
for now let's try to create a simple
user form for employees
now here you can see the controls option
where you can find the various options
to provide an object into your user form
so it might be a label it might be a
text box it might be a page it might be
a command button it might be a frame or
a toggle switch many more for now let's
make it simple let's create a label
so this is our first label we have just
dragged and dropped it
and let us name it as
okay so let us select it
and rename it as employee id
now let's insert another label
drag and drop
as simple as it looks
select that
and rename it as employee
name
now another one you can also copy that
and paste it
and this should be our
employee phone number
now we have our three labels on the
screen
let's try to insert the text box
now this is our first text box
for employee id
now let's copy and paste it
so another text box for
employee name copy and paste again and
the last text box for
employee phone
now let us try to insert the button
so the first command button let us
rename it as insert
now let us relocate it to a little bit
left now let us try to insert another
button
and
here it
second button would be
refresh sheet
the refresh button will play the role of
clearing the
text boxes in case if there is some data
already entered if you want to clear
that you can just press on refresh and
it will be clear
now we have our user form so let us try
to rename our user form so here you can
see that we have the properties tab and
inside the properties tab you can always
rename it and to rename it let us go
into caption and rename it as employ
data
and that's done
so our basic user form is ready now
let's get back to excel sheet so
remember that we have created three
labels employee id employee name and
employee form we need to create the
exact same columns here so employee
id
let us expand the column a little bit
now
e m p l o y e e
name let us also increase
the width
and finally we have employee phone
there you go
we have our three columns
let us select all the three columns
and
align to
middle can also format your
cells
let us select the green color
and text as white
and let's fold
yeah pretty good
there you go so we have created our
sheet and it's ready now
now
the last part remaining is we need to
code this particular user form
so coding in the sense we have two
buttons over here right so those buttons
should be performing some kind of
operation so for insert button the
operation should be inserting the data
which we have entered into these text
boxes
so to program it just double click on
the insert button
and here
eliminate everything
and
paste this code so basically what we did
is we had this particular code segment
so this is the starting part of the code
segment and this is the ending part of
the code segment
so we are writing our code in between
these two lines
so what did we write here
so end of the row is sheets of sheet
name so this is the sheet name
right here we have our sheet name as
sheet1 so that is the sheet name where
we want to perform the operations and
range from a
to rowscount and xlr row that is we are
counting the number of rows here that
particular statement will count the rows
till the end of the sheet automatically
and after that it will shift to textbox
value that is once the row number is
counted that is from 1 to n it will
start entering data from the first
available row
that is a column
a column then
once the a column is finished it will
enter into b column and subsequently
into c
and once
the text boxes are entered the data that
is let's come back to here so once we
have entered all the text that is the
employee id name and phone after
selecting the insert button
automatically these three text boxes
should go blank again you cannot have
the same data again in your
text box
so that is why we have included text box
value 1 null text box value 2 null text
box value 3 null so that was for command
operation insert now we should program
the command operation for refresh double
click on that
and you have the
code option over here so this particular
code will be automatically loaded from
the click button one now for click
button too you need to add some more
data that is refreshing so whenever you
press the refresh button the text should
go blank so that will use the same code
from the previous click button or the
command button
paste it over here
and this should perform the clearing
operation
and it's done
now close this
so select the employee data user form
and here you can see the run option so
select that run option and the sheet has
the user form here now let us enter the
employee id as one two three four five
and employee name as j-o-h-n
okay caps lock is on
j h and john
employ phone as some
1800
231
and select the insert option and the
data got inserted now let us try to
insert another data one two three four
six
employee name quick
and
employee phone number
one eight double zero three four five
yeah by now you might have guessed i'm a
fan of john rick yes
and yeah there you go we have entered
the second data over here now let me
show you another trick where you can
place all this user form as a macro and
replace this by just one single button
so whenever you press that button this
data form or user form will pop up and
you can directly start entering data
so for that let's get back to the visual
basic
and stop this particular execution and
you got your user form back
now you need to insert a model get into
insert option and select the module or
model yeah it is module not model
so inside this module you need to write
the command for macro
so
here it is
so
what we are basically doing is
a-n-p-l-o-y-e-e
data
dot show
or we can use an underscore and get back
to user form
and
rename this as
date
cool
so what we are doing is entering the
subject as enter employee details this
will be the macro name and when this
macro is called the employee data user
form should be shown and once it is
shown the code should be ended
that is end subject
now we have designed our module
now let's get back to the sheet
and here
go to the developer option go to the
insert menu and select button
and draw the button somewhere
and now you can select the enter
employee details macro and press ok
and now you have a button here
now you can edit this
edit it as
press to enter
enter employee details
and there you go
done so now whenever you press this
particular button the user form will
activate
okay
and you need to play this
okay the error was related to the
employee data sheet name we had to
rename the employee data from user form
to employee data initially it was just
user form we have renamed that to
employee data and now the code is fine
so let's get back to the sheet now if
you press this button
the user form will automatically start
now let us try to enter the data again
one two 3 4 5 7 this time
and
some name
let's enter as
jennifer
and her phone number would be one eight
double zero three four five
zero nine eight some random number and
select insert and the data has been
inserted here
so this is how you work on user forms in
excel
now what is regression so when you talk
about statistical modeling regression
analysis is used to estimate the
relationship
between
two or more variables and basically we
would want to look at
two or more variables
and
basically a relationship of those
variables with the response or the
target right so for example if we look
at our data here we have temperature we
have price of ice cream and then we have
units sold and we can
go ahead and make predictions so for
example when you look at regression here
you see something like this which is
regression statistics
you have anova
you have different plots which we have
here which is x variable
x variable 2 and then you have normal
probability plot now we have already
seen how you can
have your add-in that is data analysis
which helps you in doing different kind
of data analysis here right now how do
we do this so we have our variables here
which is temperature price of ice cream
units sold and when we talk about
regression we need to understand which
one of these are
independent variables which one of these
are dependent variables right so when
you talk about your x
that's your independent variable or we
can say predictor or explanatory
so when you talk about your independent
variables or as we say predictors
or explanatory variables these are the
factors that
might influence the dependent variable
and when you talk about dependent
variable that's your response or target
that's the main factor you are trying to
understand or predict so we can plot a
scatter plot to see relationship between
variables
if they are linearly related are they
positively related negatively related
and so on we can also
get values such as r square which is
coefficient of determination
regression line and then
analyze the relationship between
variables so
here is one of the links of one of my
other videos where we are
learning on machine learning and also on
regression but that's programmatically
and using a processing framework such as
spark
now here let's see how do we do this in
excel so basically we would want to use
our variables which is temperature price
of ice cream units sold
and then get these plots so what we can
do is for example i can get rid of this
and might be i can just say
no borders
and
when it comes to these plots
we can have them generated again that's
not a big deal
using your data analysis
add-in tool
so we have been given variables here now
as i said when we talk about your
regression analysis we need to
understand whether we have one variable
or we have
multiple variables right so you might
have heard of univariate analysis
bivariate analysis and so on well
here we are focusing more on using excel
to do our regression analysis so i'll
not go deeper into regression topics but
certain things
as basics should be known that when we
talk about regression analysis
what does it do it helps you understand
how the dependent variable changes
when one
or more independent variables vary
and
it basically allows us to mathematically
determine which of those variables
really has an impact
so technically when we talk about
regression analysis model that is based
on the sum of squares which is basically
a mathematical way to find the
dispersion of data points so
mainly the goal of the model is to get
the smallest possible sum of squares and
draw a line that comes closest to the
data so that's what we mean by our
regression line or basically looking at
the points
and seeing if the points fall on a
regression line if there are residuals
that is points which do not fall on the
regression line and in terms of
statistics
when we talk about
statistics we differentiate between a
simple and multiple linear regression so
you have something called a simple
linear regression
models
which basically
gives you the relationship between
dependent variable and one independent
variable using a linear function and if
you use two or more variables that is
explanatory variables to predict the
dependent variable we are actually
dealing with multiple linear regression
so if the dependent variable is modeled
as a non-linear function
because the data relationships do not
follow a straight line
we have to use non-linear regression
now what we will do is we'll see how we
can work on this so here we have some
variables and if we look at this
might be based on temperature price of
ice cream
we would want to find out how many units
were sold now what we can do is we can
basically
start looking in by creating a simple
scatter plot which is quite easy in
excel so if you have been given
variables what you can do is you can
click on insert
you can then choose the kind of plots
which you want and here you have
insert scatter plot so we can choose
this and you can choose the first option
so that gives you a blank layout and
what you can do is now you need to
select data so for example let's click
on select data and then you can say add
so what we would want is we can give a
name so we want x values and we want our
y values right so when you talk about y
that's your dependent variable or your
response or target so that is in our
case units sold and x values are 1 set
of features or variables or multiple
variables so here i can click on this
series x values and then i can
select this
now in y values what i can do is i can
select these
and then i can just say okay
so that shows me that it would be giving
me a regression scatter plot
now let's say okay
and we have some points plotted here now
if you would want to see the impact of
one individual variable such as
temperature or price of ice cream you
could as well do that now what you can
also do is you can add more meaning to
this by giving in a title or you can
also go into quick layout and you have
various options here so you see it gives
you what is the access title what is the
series and i would prefer to use here
something like this one so that gives
you your regression line that also gives
you your r square and that gives you
your y and x that is your coefficients
so let's select this one and then we
have some values which we can use to
compare this also shows me the
regression line and you can keep this
for reference if you would want you can
change
the chart title to something else a
scatter plot
of
dependent
uh vs independent
variables and you can give any name
which has more meaning
and
we can get rid of this one so we have
series and we can say what are these
points if you would want to add in
legend if you would want to do that or i
can just get rid of this
and
i will keep these values here which we
will
see when we do a data analysis we can
always
compare these values so here i have
created a simple scatter plot
and then i can look at dependent ways
independent variables
or i could have selected one particular
variable so this is just for reference
now we can add more details we can say
what is my x-axis what is my y-axis
so basically you can here
say for example just say y
and might be here i will say
x and we can rename that later
now
how do we perform data analysis or get
into regression
right now what we would want to do is
we would want to get
or we would want to do the regression
analysis to demonstrate the relationship
between
dependent and independent variables so
normally when you talk about your linear
regression equation you might have known
about it so it is basically why
when you say y
equals
you can say
bx plus a
plus c
and this would be normally the
mathematical equation for a linear
regression when
x
is your independent variable
y
is your dependent variable
your
a is the y-intercept
which is expected
mean value of y
when all x variables are equal to zero
so basically on a regression graph
that's the point where line crosses the
y axis and that's your intercept
when you talk about b that's basically
your slope of regression line which is
the rate of change for y as x changes
and then you also have
your constant right so that's your
sorry that's basically your random error
term right which is basically
the difference
between the actual value of dependent
variable and its predicted value so your
linear equation
always has an error term because in real
life predictors are obviously never
perfectly precise
right now what we can do is we can also
reduce this
equation to
y is b x
plus a
and that's the equation of a line we can
look into this and the linear equation
can be understood mathematically in this
way now how do we do it in excel so what
we can simply do is
[Music]
here let me
yeah
so
we need to get into data and then here
we have our data analysis add-in you can
click on this one and from these
different options you can choose
regression
so that's what we would want to do now
we'll say okay now here you need to give
your input y range so as i said you will
have to select
the dependent and independent variables
right so we would want to do some
regression analysis here and here we
have your x and y
so y being your target
that's basically your units sold so we
can select this along with the labels
when it comes to x either you can select
one variable or multiple variables so i
will select temperature price of ice
cream
and then since we have chosen the
headings we will go for labels
right
now we can always look at the confidence
level we can change that
so you can say whether you want it in a
new worksheet or you can just say output
range and i will probably
just click here and select one of the
cell here
now we can also choose the other options
which we would want to see as a part of
this regression analysis
so basically we have selected input y
range which is your dependent variable
you have selected x range which is your
independent variable and if we are
building a multi regression model then
we
have
chosen temperature and price of ice
cream both
now we can choose the labels which we
have done we can choose your output
range which is basically on this sheet
and then we can select the residuals
so that basically gives you
your residuals now we can also get your
line fit plots which you were seeing
earlier
you can also go for your normal
probability plots
and then basically just say okay
and
let's say okay
and that basically gives you
your regression analysis output
so we
basically have your summary output
we also have anova
we have our serial output that's from
the previous one
and basically we can get rid of this
that's not required
i can get rid of this one
yeah so now we have our regression
statistics we also have
our plots so we can basically look into
these
so we have our normal
let's get rid of these
let's get rid of this let's get rid of
this and then what we can do is
since we had some existing data
it has overwritten so let me get rid of
this and i'll repeat this step again
and
let's say water yeah
so now what we want to do is we want to
do a reaction analysis
so we go get into data we get into data
analysis we choose regression
we have already chosen our y range which
is column c
x range is multiple variables we have
gone for labels
output range which we would want to
select a particular cell
so let me select this
i am going for residuals line fit plots
normal probability plots and say okay
so now
we have our plots
we can just separate them to have a
better understanding
yeah
and that basically shows you the
variables so here it shows me units sold
and then what are the predicted units
sold and here the variable is
temperature here the variable is price
of ice cream right so that's your one
variable and second variable and then
you also have your normal probability
plot
now to interpret this
or to understand what we have here where
we look at your
summary output so it is good to
understand what xl is helping us out
so basically when we do a regression in
excel it is performing all the
calculations automatically the
interpretation is something which we
need to understand so basically we are
looking at multiple r value here
and we can
let's also fine-tune this one
yeah
we have our values here and if you see
we have our r square
now we can then basically look at
our multiple r so what is your multiple
r that's your correlation coefficient
which basically measures the strength of
linear relationship
between two variables so
this can be any value between your when
you talk about your correlation
coefficient
it can be any value between -1 and 1 and
its absolute value indicates the
relationship strength
so
the larger the absolute value the
stronger the relationship so 1 basically
means a strong positive relationship
minus 1 means a strong negative
relationship and 0 means no relationship
at all
now when you are looking at r square
that is the coefficient of determination
which is used as an indicator of the
goodness of the fit
so it basically shows how many points
fall on the regression line so your r
square value is basically calculated
from the total sum of squares
when we say precisely it is the sum of
squared deviations of the original data
from the mean
now
when we talk about
looking at the value of your r square so
it is basically we can be
seeing
that this is
0.45078
that's the value which i am talking
about so it basically means
45 of our values fit the regression
analysis model so in other words
45 percent of dependent variables that
is your y values are explained by the
independent variables that is your x
values
so
normally if you have r squared value
higher then that is considered as a good
fit
and here we have considered multiple
variables now when you talk about your
adjusted r square it is the r square
adjusted
for the number of independent variables
in the model
so
you would want to use this value instead
of r square for
multiple regression analysis
such as in our case
now you also have standard error so
that's basically
goodness of fit measure that basically
shows the precision of your regression
analysis so the smaller the value the
more certain you can be about your
regression equation
so when when we talk about your r square
that represents the percentage of
dependent variables variance that is
explained by the model and standard
error is basically an absolute measure
that shows the average
distance that the data points fall from
the regression line so you will have to
look back into regression
statistics terminologies to basically
understand more of this and if you're
already from data science background
that
then you already know what i'm talking
about we are just seeing how excel
easily helps us in doing these things
now
we can also look at observations here
which is basically the number of
observations in our model which is 7.
now when we talk about regression
analysis and if we look at analysis of
variance that is your anova values here
so we basically see df you have ss
f and significance f
now to understand these
so basically what we are doing is or
what excel is doing is it splits the sum
of squares into individual components
that give information about the levels
of variability within your regression
model so when you talk about your df
that's basically the number of degrees
of freedom associated with the source of
variance you have sum of squares that is
your ss
so smaller the residual ss compared with
the total ss
the better your model fits the data
right now when you talk about ms that's
your mean square you have f is basically
the f statistic
or you can say
f test for the null hypothesis
basically it is used to
test the overall significance of the
model and then you finally have your
significance f
which is the p value of f so
uh when we when we usually talk about
seeing simple linear regression the in
anova part is
not
really used or it's rarely used
right but when we look at the
significance f value
that gives an idea of how reliably
or statistically significant our results
are so if significance f is less than
0.05
that's 5 percent our model is ok if it
is greater than 0.05
we will have to better choose another
independent variables
right now we can also look at the output
of coefficients and that's what we would
want to look at so you basically have
your intercept here so when you talk
about your intercept
temperature price of ice cream so we
know we are looking at our variables and
then we are also looking looking at our
intercept which basically gives you
more details on your coefficients
so the the main important thing when we
talk about regression analysis
is basically your coefficients it
basically enables you to build a linear
regression equation
in the form of y equals bx plus a which
i explained earlier
and then basically we can understand our
regression analysis
output better now when we look at the
residual output which we are seeing here
so that gives you your observations how
many observations we have
it shows what is the predicted units
sold and then it also gives you your
residuals so we can compare the
estimated and actual number of sold
umbrellas based on the observation
so we have
11.209 here and if you compare that's
basically 12
the second one is 15 and here it is 13.5
you have and similarly you can compare
all the values of actual units sold
and what our regression has predicted
so basically what we can do is we can
compare these
and
we will see if there is any difference
or no
right
so
obviously there will be or there would
be some difference because independent
variables are never
perfect predictors of your dependent
variables
and the residuals
basically help us in understanding how
far the actual values are from the
predicted values
so that's what we see here in the
residual section
so for example when we look at this one
which is 11.209
and the actual is 12 we see what is the
residual and how far is the predicted
value from the actual value
so
similarly we can also look at the
percentile values so that gives you your
probability output and this is what we
have in our
graphs so we have basically our
variables
we are looking at our variables and also
the units sold and the relationship
between them we can basically
add in more details to this particular
plot and you also have normal
probability plot which is basically
getting
your values from your probability output
here so this is how you can perform a
simple regression analysis and now what
you can do is you can as i said you can
basically be looking at your scatter
plot you can be looking at your y and x
and your r square values right but
remember what are the variables which
you are selecting
and then you can compare these
with basically the values what you see
here
so remember here i have chosen
my both set of variables
and you can choose
one variable and then basically see what
is its impact on the response or on the
target
so
it's pretty simple here you can
add more details to your scatter plot or
the plots what we have created
or
some people prefer to do it using
formulas
so
basically we have some statistical
functions that can help you do linear
regression analysis such as
you have
linus you have slope you have intercept
you have correlation and so on so
basically
you can use these particular functions
and what you will have to do is
you will have to basically
go in for a function if that's what you
would want to do and then you can search
for functions
and say for example i'll just say lin
nest
and say go and here i have my function
so if i would want to really use this
one i can do that
what i will have to do is then select
the variable so if you just say ok and
that basically says your known y's known
x your constants your stats and
basically you can use the formula also
but we are not covering that here might
be in the later videos we can do that so
just try out and perform some regression
analysis
and try to look at your different
variables and try to interpret that so
that basically gives you
an easier way of performing regression
analysis
using your data analysis add-in in excel
now at times you might be working on a
really important spreadsheet on your
excel or you might have the sales data
of your company or some confidential
data of your organization and you might
have shared the file with your junior or
you might face some pocket issue and you
forgot to save or you missed to save
your data and what to do if you cannot
save your data and how can you recover
it right so this might be a really big
hassle today we are exactly going to
discuss the same and see how to do it in
multiple ways so excel comes up with an
option to automatically save the data
also it will try to warn you that your
data is not being saved would you like
me to save it or not right so we'll do
the first one so here you have the auto
save option you can either say ok to it
or you can ignore it in case if you
ignore it if you choose to ignore it or
if you choose to manually save it and
then if you want to close the file
remember we haven't saved the file if
you wish to close it excel will
automatically come up with a dialog box
asking you want to save your changes to
your data.xlsx
that means it is asking you if i have to
save it or not
let's try to ignore this and
forcefully let's try to close it you can
go to task manager option here we are
trying to simulate the option of pocket
issues
so we are forcefully closing excel
without saving any data
so we have closed it now here you can
see we do not have excel running in the
background now when you directly open or
try to start excel when you get the
power backup again and if you want to
open that same data file it will ask you
the document recovery option it says you
have close the file without saving the
changes and you can choose to you know
come back from the same place where we
left last time okay
now that was the pocket issue and now
let's see uh another way okay let's
imagine that somebody uh eliminated a
few important data files from your
organization's confidential data
employee id employee name etc and again
uh let's simulate the force uh
close of the excel
now we are closing it again without
saving no data has been saved
now it will also ask the same
data it has another version here the
original one
which wasn't saved so here you can
recover the same file again however it
was initially so you can save it and it
will get back to the original place
so this was one way also we have another
few multiple ways just we have to
navigate to file and here you can open
and in the open menu you have a button
called recover unsaved workbooks not
just the current workbook it will also
have all the remaining files
which are related to excel that are not
saved
so here you have a few workbooks which
was not saved this is one option and we
also have another option
we can just navigate to info
and there you have another option called
manage workbook and in the manage
workbook you have another option called
recover unsaved workbooks which will
also redirect you to the same file that
is microsoft office unsaved files and
you'll have all the ncaa workbooks which
are related to excel so this is how you
can recover the unsaved data in excel
using multiple ways first thing excel
will automatically ask you if you have
to save the file or not and in case if
you forget to save it you can
directly recover it by default by excel
it will automatically show that some
folder was not saved on the left side of
your excel spreadsheet by default and in
case if you missed out on that one you
can manually go to file and you can
either choose open option or info option
to recover the unsaved folders from your
default file location from your pc that
is microsoft office unsaved files etc
which will have all the list of all
unsaved workbooks related to excel
let's see what is a project plan project
plan is a basic thing that is needed to
execute a project according to project
management book of knowledge a project
can be defined as an approved
elaborative document that guides the
team during project execution and
project control when we are making a
project plan a project plan must answer
several questions for us these questions
are like what are we expecting our
project to deliver how are we expecting
to get our deliverables within the
desired time who all will be a part of a
project and what tasks they will have in
the project when will the project start
and when it is expected to end that is
the deadlines of the project now let us
learn about project management in excel
microsoft excel is one of the most
common application these days it is used
in both offices and at homes microsoft
excel is an easy project management tool
that allows the team members to easily
see the tasks in a project develop a
plan and track its progress before we
learn more about project management in
excel let's first have a look why do we
use excel microsoft excel is an easy
tool to plan a project so it can be used
by people who are beginners in terms of
project management in excel one can find
several analytical tools like
concatenate len and counter so this
makes data analysis easy and effective
as the entry of data is easy same is
tracking and controlling of project
status then there are several project
management templates in excel that help
us to have an effective distribution of
project data we will be checking several
project management templates towards the
end of this video now let's have a look
at the process of making a gantt chart
in excel before we begin this it's
important we know what is a gantt chart
a gantt chart is like a horizontal bar
chart that is used for project
management with the help of a gantt
chart we can check the status of the
task the date they start the date the
end and the dependencies on each other
gantt chart helps in coordinating and
monitoring different tasks in a project
now let's have a look at the steps that
will help us in making a gantt chart
first step we have is make a project
table we have several rows and columns
like here we have three columns in the
first column we have the tasks in the
second we have a start date and in the
third column we have the duration or
tenure of the task the second step is to
make a bar chart in excel for this we
will select the entire second column
then we will go on the insert tab and
click on the bar graph chart there we
can select stacked bar graph in 2d bar
charts as a result we will have the
entitled bar graph on the screen in the
third step we will add the duration to
the bar graph we will right click on the
chart and in the menu that appears we
will select select data option a window
that appears on the screen in that
window we will select add option as
shown we can also see the start date is
already in the entry section then in the
dialog box that appears type tenure in
the series name and click on the rain
selection icon that's shown in the
figure now select the relevant data from
the tenure column and click on ok now we
can see a bar graph that has two colors
on the screen this bar graph now has the
duration of the tasks the fourth step we
have is adding description to the gantt
chart now we will open the box again and
in that box we will select the edit
option as shown in the figure then we
will select the tasks as we had selected
the duration of the tasks before and
click on ok we can now see the tasks
have appeared towards the left side of
the gantt chart the fifth and the
remarkable step will help us convert
this bar graph into a gantt chart we
will now click on the bars and select
the format data series option from the
menu that appears then in the format
data series dialog box we will select no
fill option we can find the gantt chart
on the screen now in accordance with the
data that we had entered now we can see
the tasks on the left side are in the
reverse order so what we will do next is
we will click on the task panel then go
to the format access dialog box and
select the categories in reverse order
option now we can find the tasks in the
right order one more thing we can notice
is gantt chart is starting with some
other date and not with the dates that
we had entered so for this we will copy
the first date in some other cell then
clicking on the copied cell we will go
to the home menu to select the dialog
box as shown in the figure then in that
drop down menu we will select the number
option we can now find a value displayed
in the copied cell we'll copy that value
click on the dates on the chart and as
the format access dialog box opens we
will place that value in the box that
says minimum shown in the figure as a
result we will have our final gantt
chart on the screen in the last step we
can give several designs to a grant
chart change colors and make it more
presentable for us now when we know the
basic steps of making a gantt chart i
will show that practically to you in
microsoft excel our first step is to
open microsoft excel and in microsoft
excel we will make a project table in
our project table we will have three
columns the first column will be task
the second column will have the start
date the third column will have tenure
or the duration of the task so beginning
with tasks we have task 1 in task 1 we
have 1.1 1.2 1.3 then comes task 2 in
task 2 we have 2.1 2.2 2.3 and 2.4 then
we have task 3 in task 3 we will have
two subsections 3.1 and 3.2 then we will
start with the starting dates in
starting dates we will put 1st january
the task 1 1.1 will be 1st of january
then this will be 4th january let's say
this is 5th january then we will put
this as 11th of january and this will be
again 11th january only this will be
15th january let's put this as 17th
january let this be 19th january task 3
begins on 23rd january
and it the 3.2 section begins at 26th of
january now let's put the tenure or the
duration of the task we will begin with
task 1 it takes 12 days then 1.1 takes 7
days we say this takes 4 days and this
takes 8 days then for task 2 it again
takes 12 days it takes 5 days
five days and let's say this takes six
days and this takes four days then we
come to task three this takes eight days
and let's say this takes six days and
the three point two section takes five
days so this is how our project table is
ready in the second step we will select
the entire second column after we have
selected this column we will go to the
insert tab in the insert tab we'll go to
the bar columns and in this we will
select 2d stacked bar charts now we have
the entitled bar chart in accordance to
our data on the screen then comes the
third step we will add the duration of
the tasks to the bar graph we will click
on the chart and after we click on the
chart we will select
select data option in the select data
source dialog box we find the start date
is already there now we will click on
add and after we click on add in the
series name section we will put tenure
then in the series value we will click
on this icon
and select the entire tenure series and
click on ok so this is the bar graph
that we have now this is now in two
colors the orange color and the blue
color this bar graph now has the
duration of all the tasks in our project
table now in the fourth step now it's
time for us to add description to our
gantt chart instead of this 1 2 3 4 5 we
will put task 1 task 2 and the sub tasks
so what we will do is we will again go
to that box we will left click on the
gantt chart select the select data
option and then we'll go to the start
date here we'll select the edit option
in the edit option we will select all
the tasks and click on ok now we can see
all the tasks are aligned towards the
left of the bar chart as we can see this
is a bar chart or a bar graph and not a
gantt chart the next step we have is
converting this bar graph into a gantt
chart so we will click on the bars and
select the format data series option
from the menu that appears here we have
this format data series option now we
can see the dialog box on the screen
here we'll go into the color section
fill section
and then we will select no fill now we
can see the blue lines have disappeared
so this looks like a gantt chart so now
when we have a gantt chart on the screen
we can notice that the tasks here are in
the reverse order so what we will do is
we will click on these tasks and select
the format access option here we will
select categories in reverse order we
can see our gantt chart is now in order
like we have a task 1 on the top and
task 3 at the bottom the dates are
starting from 11th of december but the
dates we have provided are from 1st of
january now we will copy this cell then
go on the dates box here we'll go to
format access in the format axis we can
see
minimum in this minimum we will paste
this value and press enter as we press
enter we can see our gantt chart
starting from the date that we wanted to
start and that too in the correct order
starting from task 1 to task 3. now as a
result we have our final gantt chart on
the screen in the last step what we can
do is make our gantt chart more
representable we can change the color of
these bars we can give them shapes and
we can do many other things to make it
more presentable we will first select
the bars like what we will do is we will
select task 1 and let's say we give it
the color blue then task 2 we will give
it color green and in task 3 we'll give
it give it the color black so here the
subsections will give different colors
to the subsections as well then we come
to task 2.1 this is how we can change
the color of these cells or
apart from changing colors we can select
a bar graph and do the gradient fill so
this is how we can make a gantt chart
more presentable after changing the
colors or changing the shapes we have
our final gantt chart on the screen
finally let's have a look at some
microsoft excel templates for project
management microsoft excel templates
help in collecting data putting them
into order and check their dependencies
with each other with the help of these
templates we can monitor the status of
the tasks and we can also check the
progress our project has made moving
forward we will check some important
microsoft excel templates the first
template we have is excel project review
template this template helps us have an
overview of the project we can have a
clear understanding of all the tasks
that are planned and that are completed
this helps project managers to measure
the progress of the project and take
further steps accordingly second
template we will check is excel budget
template in this template we can monitor
all the expenditures of our project it
helps us in managing the budget of a
project and also helps in comparing the
budget of our project at different
phases let's have a look at the budget
template in excel once we can download
this template from officetimeline.com
the gantt chart towards the right is in
accordance with the dates towards the
left if we fluctuate the date we can see
the template working the start date for
task 1 could be changed to 10th june if
we change this date to 10 june we can
see the fluctuation in the gantt chart
so this is how we can use this template
directly let's have a look at the third
template now third template we will see
is excel sprint project tracker template
this template is used majorly in agile
projects where the project is made in
several sprints or sessions this
template includes the start date the end
date and the duration of each task we
can also see the percentage completed of
each task let's have a look at this
print project tracker template as well
we can see the gantt chart towards the
right and the data towards the left so
if we change any data we can see the
gantt chart changing for example we can
change the data in sprint to feature 3.
let's change the start date to july 2nd
we can see the gantt chart changing
this is how we can use this template
directly to track our sessions let's
have a look at the fourth excel template
this template is excel project tracker
in this template we have the data of all
the tasks with the status and owners we
can track the percentage of tasks
completed and also compare the plan
duration of the task to the actual
duration of the task after the critical
part tracker let's check the excel
project schedule template this template
helps in effective management of the
project as it helps in monitoring the
time that each task of the project takes
it provides a clear view of all the work
associated with the project let's have a
look at this template in excel once we
can see the gantt chart in accordance to
the data if you change the estimated
hours at two places let's say at the
design review we make it 15 hours
instead of 5 hours and at the create
staffing plan we make it 2 hours instead
of 20 hours we can see the gantt chart
fluctuating this is how we can use this
template to manage the schedule in a
project moving forward the next template
we will see is excel project status
report template this template helps us
having a list of project deliverables
and the risks associated with that
project this template helps the project
managers about different crucial
activities involved in a project after
this we have excel milestone tracker the
milestone tracker helps us in tracking
or monitoring different tasks in a
project project managers use this
template to monitor the project
performance with respect to the
timelines the last template we will see
is excel project planner excel project
planner includes a list of tasks with
the respected owners along with the
start date and the end date of that task
this helps in monitoring each task and
comparing the estimated task date with
the actual ones let's have a look at
this template in excel we can see the
gantt chart with respect to the data
entered let's make changes at several
places in the data we can make this 22
to 24 we will make this 23 go to 2 and
we can make this 5th september go to 15
september and when we make the changes
we can realize the gantt chart is
fluctuating so this is how we can use
this template to plan a project
effectively and efficiently
excel supports a number of shortcut keys
that you can use to speed up your work
and make your work efficient
these shortcuts make working with
spreadsheets a little easier now the
question arises do i need to memorize
the shortcut keys the answer is no
the keyboard shortcuts in excel helps
you perform data analysis better and
faster but it would be an advantage if
you can remember a few of them
now
let's begin by looking at some of the
important workbook related shortcuts
so we will see how to create a new
workbook open an existing workbook and
save a spreadsheet so that you don't
lose any data or calculations that you
have done
towards the end
you will see how you can toggle between
different sheets in a workbook
now to open an excel workbook on windows
you can just search for excel here
you can see
this is the excel app
i'll click on it
and you can see there's the home tab
new tab
from here you can open any existing
workbook as well so let me go to the new
tab
and open a blank workbook
now mark here on the top it says book
one
dash excel
now
if you were to create a new workbook the
shortcut is control plus n
now
mark this
so if i hit control plus n
you can see it has opened a new workbook
called book 2.
i can show you to you here
you can see there are two workbooks book
1 and book 2.
so the shortcut to open a new workbook
is ctrl n
now if you want to open an existing
workbook that is present in your system
the shortcut is ctrl o
so if i hit ctrl o
you can go to browse and check for
your excel file that is present on your
system let me go to the desktop and
search for
excel workbooks
you can see i have two excel files here
let me select the kovid 19 file and
click on open
i'll enable editing
there you go
so we have our existing workbook opened
on excel
now if you want to save a workbook or a
spreadsheet
the shortcut is control plus s
now this is very simple you use it in
other editors as well
now suppose
i duplicate this column
i use ctrl c
go on top
and hit ctrl v
now to save this spreadsheet i'll just
press ctrl s
you can see the workbook is saved
now you can also click on
this one which says save control plus s
so i don't need this column actually so
let me go ahead and delete this column
and now to close the current workbook
the shortcut is control plus w
so if i hit control w
it will ask me do you want to save this
file or not
i'll say don't save and it will close
that current file
next if you want to close excel
the shortcut key is ctrl f4
now if i hit ctrl f4
you can see my book one is closed so i
can go ahead and close the workbook
now let me go ahead and open a workbook
again so i'll search for excel
and click on it
i'll go to a blank workbook
now if you want to move to next sheet
you can use control page down
now in this current workbook we have
only one sheet now let me create
two more sheets and come to sheet1
now if you want to move to the next
sheet the shortcut is ctrl page down
so if i hit control page down you can
see i'm in sheet 2 now
if i again hit control page down
i have come to sheet3
next if you want to move on to the
previous sheet
the shortcut is control page up so let
me hit control page up you can see i am
in sheet2 now
and if i hit control page of once again
i have come to sheet1
now to get a little more clarity on this
let me open a workbook that has multiple
sheets or multiple tables
so i'll hit ctrl o
and i'll look for my sample superstore
data set
click on it
you can see
this data set has three tables the first
one is the orders table
the second one is the returns table
which has the detail about the orders
that were returned
and the next table is of people table
that basically has person and the region
to which the person belong to
so let me come to my audits table
now if i want to move to my returns and
people table
for that i can hit control page down
which is to move to the next sheet
so if i hit control page down see i am
in the returns table now
if i hit control page down once again i
have come to my people table
if you want to move back i'll hit ctrl p
job
you can see i am in my returns table
if i hit control p job once again
i have come back to my orders table
now there are a few other shortcuts that
i want to tell you here so suppose you
want to switch between different tabs
that are present in the ribbon you can
do that as well with the help of
shortcut keys
so in excel this is the ribbon which has
different tabs like the file tab home
tab insert draw page layout
and so on
now currently we are in the home tab
if you want to move to the data tab
the shortcut is alt a so if i hit alt a
you can see we have come to the data tab
now
if you want to go to the view tab
the shortcut is alt w
you can see we have come to the view tab
and if you want to move to the formula
tab the shortcut is alt m so if i hit
alt m
you can see we have come to the formula
tab
now let me open another actual file well
we have listed all the shortcut keys
that we are covering in this video so
let me go ahead and do that
so i will go to file
and under open
i'll click on browse
and
under desktop i look for my excel
shortcut keys file and click on open
so this is the excel sheet we have
created for you for your reference
you can pause the video to note the
shortcut keys we have covered so far
if you want to get access to this excel
sheet please share your email address in
the chat section we'll send it to you
over email
so far we have covered all the workbook
related shortcuts
so these are the shortcuts we have
covered so far that i am highlighting
here
now let's move back to our slides
and see what we have next
so you can see we have our cell
formatting shortcuts up next
now here i will tell you the different
shortcuts that can be applied to a cell
such as editing a cell aligning cell
contents adding a border to a cell
adding an outline to all the selected
cells etc so let's go ahead and do these
operations
so
i'll go to my
book one
and the first shortcut that we'll see is
how to edit a cell
for example
there are certain values
such as 10 20 30
and
if i scroll down
like this
and now if you want to edit the cells
you can just
select that cell here i have selected
a4 cell you can see on the top
and hit f2 to edit the cell
so if i hit f2
you can see i can edit the cell and make
it say 40.
similarly i'll hit
f2 again and make this as 50
and so on
now
you can also edit the formula that is
present in a cell so let me use a
formula say will calculate the sum
and
i choose
a1 to a8 and find the sum
now if i select this and click on f2
i can change the formula as well
let's say average
i'll hit enter you can see it has
calculated the average from a1
to a8
now if you want to copy paste cells the
shortcut is very simple is ctrl c and
ctrl v
now suppose i want to copy
cell
a4 i can just hit ctrl c
and i'll hit ctrl v to paste it
similarly you can also select a range of
cells and hit ctrl c
and ctrl v to paste it
similarly
you can also copy paste
different cells
from other worksheets so i have come to
my sample superstore workbook and let me
select a few cells
and
i can copy it
by hitting ctrl c i'll move back
and i can paste it ctrl v
next if you want to bold and italicize
the font values in a cell you can use
ctrl b and ctrl i respectively
so if i want to bold suppose
the headings
or the column names i can use control b
you can see it's bold
and if i want to italicize certain
values let me select this one i can use
ctrl i to italicize it i'll hit ctrl i
you can see
it's italicized
now you can also underline the cell
contents so let me show you how to do
that for this purpose we use control
plus u
so
let me select this cell
and i'll hit ctrl u you can see
it has added an underline similarly let
me do it for one more cell
i'll hit control plus u you can see it
has put an underline to this cell as
well
now if you want to fill colors to
certain cells
the shortcut you can use is alt plus h
plus h
so let me show you
if i select this cell and hit
alt h
you can see it has
it has prompted me to select a color
i'll select this blue color
and you can see
you have filled a color to this cell
similarly
you can fill color to a range of cells
as well i have selected these cells and
let me hit alt
h
and this time i'll select this green
color
you can see we have filled all the cells
with green color
now
if you want to add a border to a cell
the shortcut is alt plus h plus b
now let me select
this cell 40
and hit alt plus h plus b
so it has prompted me to select the type
of border that you want
now let me select i want a top border
you can see
here
it has put a top border to cell b5
and now let me choose
cell e6
and
again hit alt
h b
and this time
let's say i'll select all borders
you can see the cell
has all borders
across it
now if you were to remove the outline
border the shortcut is control plus
shift plus underscore so if i want to
remove this top border from cell b5
i'll hit control shift underscore
you can see the top border is no more
there
similarly
let's remove all border from cell e6
i'll hit
ctrl shift underscore
you can see the border is gone
now if you want to add outline to
selected cells
the shortcut is control plus shift plus
ampersand
so let me select the cells that i had
colored just now
and if i hit ctrl shift ampersand
you can see it has added a border
to the selected cells i can show it to
you here as well let me select it
and hit
ctrl shift ampersand
you can see it has added a border
to all the selected cells
another thing i want to show you here is
if you want to move to the previous cell
the shortcut is shift tab
so if i select this cell and hit
shift tab it will take me back to the
next cell which is e8 if i hit shift tab
again it takes me to c8 next is b8
then it's a8
now if you want to move to the next cell
the shortcut is
tab so if i hit tab
it will take me to the next cell
now
if you want to select the cells on the
right
the shortcut is ctrl shift right arrow
so initially if i select cell h2
and now i want to select all the cells
on the right i can just hit
ctrl shift right arrow so as you can see
it has selected all the cells on the
right
similarly if you want to select all the
cells on the left
the shortcut is ctrl shift
left arrow
as you can see it has selected all the
cells
now if you want to select the column
from the selected cell to the end of the
table
the shortcut is ctrl shift down arrow
so
i'll hit ctrl shift down arrow you can
see it has selected the entire column
now if you want to select the data above
the selected cell
the shortcut is ctrl shift up arrow so
i'll hit ctrl shift up arrow you can see
it has selected all the cells that are
present on top of it
yeah
let me again take you to the excel sheet
that is all the list of shortcuts
discussed in this video
so i'll go to file
and
i'll open excel shortcut keys
so now we have looked at all the cell
formatting shortcuts
that i'm highlighting
again
if you want to get access to this excel
sheet please drop in your email id we'll
share it over email
next we'll be discussing about some
additional cell formatting shortcuts
so up next we will see some additional
self formatting shortcuts
here we will have a look at how to add a
comment to a cell
so comments are used to give extra
information about a cell value
you can also learn how to find a value
and replace it with another value in the
spreadsheet
then we'll see how to activate a filter
insert the current date current time and
also add a hyperlink to a cell
finally we'll see how to apply a format
to the data in a cell
now let me go to my sample superstore
data set
so this is my sample superstore data set
now if i need to add a comment to a cell
the shortcut key i will use is shift f2
so let me select rosina hoffman and hit
shift f2 you can see
my comment box has appeared
now let me give a comment like
brocina
is
from
l.a or los angeles you can see bristina
hoffman
is from los angeles now if i select this
you can see
our comment
next
if you want to display find and replace
a value from a cell
or a range of cells you can use control
plus h
so
let me
select control plus h
you can see
our find and replace
box has appeared
and here
if i want to change
the name of say suppose
brucina
to something like
angela
i'll first select for
brocina
so here i am
typing what i need to find that is
proceena and i'll replace it with
angela suppose
now i'll hit replace all
you will get a pop-up say all done we
made 48 replacements if i click ok
and select close
you can see
the name brocina was changed to angela
excel is another important feature which
is
to filter your data based on certain
values
now
let me show you how you can apply a
filter
so i'll select this city column
and i'll go to my data tab
and here you can see we have filter i'll
choose this
now we have applied a filter to our
city column
to show you more
you can see here it has all the
city name listed
and if i uncheck this select all
and i'll select certain cities and click
ok
it will filter my data only for those
cities
ctrl z to undo it
and now
if you want to activate a filter
the shortcut key that i'll use is alt
down arrow
so if i hit alt down arrow you can see
my activate filter box has appeared
choose cancel
if i click on a particular cell in this
city column
and hit alt down arrow again you can see
the list of cities
here
now i'll move back to my
book once
and
i'll show you how you can insert the
current date now to insert the current
date in a particular cell
the shortcut i'll use is control plus
semicolon
so now if i hit control plus semicolon
it will give me the current date
you can see this is our current date
that is 9th of june
similarly you can go ahead and get the
current time as well
so the shortcut for that is
ctrl shift colon so if you hit ctrl
shift colon it will give you the current
time as well
also
excel allows you to insert a hyperlink
now in order to insert a hyperlink you
can use control plus k
so if i hit control plus k
you can see the insert hyperlink box has
appeared
now you can give any address here so let
me
go to
google and
say w3schools i'll copy this link
and i'll paste it in the address section
and here on the top where it says text
to display
i'll write
w3 schools
website
now if i hit ok
you can see we have inserted a hyperlink
and if i click on this it will take me
to the w3schools website
so it opens up in my google chrome you
can see this is the w3schools website
similarly let me insert one more link so
i'll go ahead and click ctrl k
and this time let's say i'll
choose
simply learns website
i'll select this website address and
here in the address section i'll paste
the
url
and on top i'll write
simply learn
website
which is my text that it will display i
click on ok
if i
click on this cell
it will take me to my simply learns
website
going back
now i'll tell you how to apply certain
formats so let's see how you can apply a
currency format
so you can see we have some numerical
values here i'll select this values and
if i hit
control shift
dollar
now these numbers have been converted
into
currency
format we have all
in the form of rupees
similarly
if you want to
convert a particular cell value say 0.3
into
percentage you can use
control shift
and percentage symbol so it has
converted into 30
suppose it's
0.6
and on this if i select control shift
percentage
it has converted into 60
another shortcut key that you can use is
alt q
or alt plus q
this will go to the tell me what you
want to do box so if i hit
alt q
you can see
it has taken me to the tell me what you
want to do box if i select a pivot table
it will ask you to give the range
and select where you want to place your
pivot table
and hit cancel
now moving ahead
if you have enjoyed watching this video
so far consider subscribing to our
simply learn youtube channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update
let's see what we have next
so now we look at some of the important
row and column formatting shortcuts
here we will learn how to delete rows
and columns hide and unhide selected
rows and columns as well as group and
ungroup rows and columns
i'll
go to my sample superstore data set
now
if you want to select an entire row
i'll click on a particular cell
and if i want to select
row 7
i'll just hit shift
space
so you can see it has selected my entire
row
similarly
if you want to select an entire column
you can hit control space
so if i hit control space it has
selected my order date column
now to select the entire worksheet
you can use ctrl shift space
so i'll hit ctrl shift space
you can see
it has selected my entire worksheet
now if you want to move to the edge of
the worksheet you can use ctrl right
arrow
so this is the edge of the worksheet
now
if you want to delete a column
you can use alt plus h plus d plus c or
alt h d c
now let's say i want to delete a
specific column
let me choose a column
say the discount column i want to delete
it
so i can use alt htc
so let me press alt h d c
you can see the discount column is gone
i'll use ctrl z to bring it back
now
if you want to delete a row
you can use shift plus space to select
that entire row so let me hit
shift space now i have selected my row
10
and then if i hit ctrl minus it will
delete row 10.
and see
row id 9 is deleted if i
undo it
i have it back
moving ahead now if you want to hide a
selected row the shortcut is ctrl 9
so let's say i have selected
row 11 and i want to hide it i can just
use ctrl 9 to hide it
now you can see we have hidden that
particular row
now if you want to unhide that selected
row
the shortcut is ctrl shift 9 so i'll hit
ctrl shift 9
to unhide it
you see we have that row back
similarly
you can also hide a selected column
now to hide a selected column let's say
i want to hide
first name column so i can use
control 0
so if i hit ctrl 0 you can see we have
hidden the first name column
now to unhide that selected column we
can use control plus shift plus zero
or control shift zero
so if i hit ctrl shift zero
you see the shortcut did not work let me
try it once again ctrl shift zero it's
not working
so for that you need to change the
settings by going to the control panel
so let me
search for my control panel
i'll select it and now
i'll search for
language here
let me
search for language
i'll click on it
i'll go to advanced settings
and then
i'll click on
change language bar hotkeys
and
this here i'll select change key
sequence
and then
under switch keyboard layout
i'll choose
not assigned
and click on ok
i'll apply and click on ok and then i'll
close it
now if i hit ctrl shift 0 it will unhide
my selected column
moving ahead now if you want to group
rows or columns the shortcut key for it
is alt shift right arrow
now suppose i have selected
these two
cells
and i want to group these
cells
so i can hit
alt shift right arrow so you can see the
group box has appeared
and i have selected rows if i click on
ok you can see here we have grouped both
the rows
now
if you want to ungroup the rows
the shortcut for it is alt shift left
arrow so i'll hit alt shift left arrow
and select rows i'll click on ok
to ungroup the rows
now let me take you back to a reference
sheet
so now we have covered all the row and
column formatting shortcuts that you can
see here
now let me move back to our
slides now we are into the final section
of our shortcut keys
here we will cover the shortcut keys you
can use in a pivot table
in microsoft excel a pivot table is a
table of statistics that summarizes your
data for example you have sales data for
different regions and for different
products
using a pivot table you can summarize
the data by region and find the average
sales per region the maximum and minimum
sales per region total sales made for
each region and for each category of
products etc
it allows you to summarize and show only
relevant data in your reports
i'll create a pivot table and show you
different shortcuts to group pivot table
items and group pivot table items
then we'll see how to hide pivot table
item
create a pivot chart on the same sheet
and create a pivot chart on a new sheet
now let me go to excel and create a
pivot table using my coronavirus data
set
so
[Music]
i'll select file
and i'll open a file
i'll choose my covet 19 data set
so you can see
we have our coronavirus data set
it has the date column
the day column
month
year
the total number of cases that have come
up in each country
the total number of debts that were
reported
country territory code
and we have the continent as well
now let me show you how you can create a
pivot table first
so i'll select my table
and under insert
i'll choose
pivot table
i have my
table range selected
then i'll choose existing worksheet to
place my pivot table
i'll select a cell and click on ok
just squeeze this
and
i'll
sort in this column as well
now
i want to drag
my countries and territories onto rows
so you can see we have
all the
countries here
and then
i'll drag
the cases column onto values
and similarly
the deaths column onto values as well
if i close this
and let me squeeze it further
you can see we have our pivot table
ready
it has all the country names
and the total sum of the cases and the
total sum of debts that were reported in
each country
let's use this pivot table and
apply some shortcut keys
now first to group pivot table items
the shortcut key that i can use is
alt shift right arrow
so let's select a few
items from this pivot table i have
selected four
rows
and if i hit
alt shift right arrow
you can see we have created a group it
says group 1 and it has
4 countries and the total cases as well
as the total number of debts
now
if you want to ungroup the pivot table
items you can use alt shift left arrow
so let me use alt shift left arrow
so first i have to select this group and
use alt shift left arrow
you can see we have ungrouped the pivot
table items
now if you want to hide a pivot table
item you can use control minus
so
let's say i want to hide
the values for afghanistan i'll use
control minus to hide it
see afghanistan is no more there in this
pivot table
to unhide let me just use ctrl z it's
back
similarly
if you want to create a pivot chart
based on the pivot table on the same
sheet you can use alt f1
so let me hit alt f1
close this
and let me hit alt f1
there you go
we have our pivot chart
ready on the shame sheet itself
so you can see there's a blue line and
there's orange line as well
the blue line represents the number of
cases and the orange line represents the
sum of depths
this chart depicts that united states
has the highest number of cases as of
now
and then you can see we have
hungary iraq then there's portugal
and other countries as well
let me delete it
also if you want to create a pivot chart
on a new worksheet
the shortcut you can use is f11 so you
just have to hit
f11 so let me hit f11
you can see here
it has created a new pivot chart
on another worksheet
it has a sum of the cases and the sum of
the depths
with that we have covered all the
shortcut keys that can help you speed up
your work in excel
if you think we have missed out on any
shortcut keys then please put it in the
chat section as well as in the comments
section of the video
now let me go back to my slides
now let's have a question and answer
session where i'll address a few
questions so please feel free to put in
your questions in the chat section of
the video
there's one question which i can see
here is
how important is excel for data
analytics
so microsoft excel is one of the top
tools for data analysis it is
recommended for those who don't know
programming
excel supports a wide range of functions
to short and filter your data perform
calculations and apply conditional
formatting as well
you can also create pivot tables and
pivot charts perform what-if analysis
and derive valuable business insights by
visualizing the data using reports and
dashboards
another question i can see in the chat
is
is it necessary to memorize all the
shortcut keys
not at all you need not memorize all the
shortcut keys it is hard to remember all
of them
shortcut keys are only useful for
performing your tasks better and faster
but
it would be an advantage if you memorize
a few of them also if you continuously
use it while working on excel then it
will be easier for you to remember them
let me check a few more questions
the next question i can see here is
can excel be integrated with other
software
of course it can be
excel data can be imported into
microsoft access
microsoft word and powerpoint use
microsoft excel to create tables within
their documents
power bi desktop uses microsoft excel to
analyze data similarly
excel can also be integrated and used
with microsoft sql server python and r
programming
now let me check if there are any more
questions
okay someone has asked
how to secure information in excel
so excel has a cell locking feature that
prevents other users from changing the
information in the cell
additionally the entire worksheet or
workbook can be password protected
if there are certain parts of the
workbook that should not be seen by
unauthorized people you can place a
password on those parts of the workbook
or the entire workbook itself
now i think i have covered most of the
important questions if you have any more
queries put it in the chat section our
team will reply to it
today we are going to talk about uh
microsoft excel interview questions so
here i'll be discussing some important
questions that you will come across
when you face interview for excel and
we will start with the basics the
beginner level
and
most of them will be discussed here will
be the beginner level at the beginning
and then we'll discuss it at the further
left
okay so of the first question that you
might get asked is what is a cell
address in excel
so
a cell address is a combination of
column letter and a row number that
identifies a cell on a worksheet
basically each cell will have an
associated column number
column letter and a row number so you
have to keep in mind it will always be
a column letter and a row number each
excel sheet will have suppose for
instance if you take row 5
rows will be in numbers and the columns
will be in letters column a column b
column c
d and so on
and the numbers will be for the rows so
for instance
if you take this particular uh
cell the cell address is d5
column d and row 5.
so this is the cell address now
let's move on to the next one
now you will be asked what is relative
cell referencing and absolute cell
referencing in
excel
so relative cell referencing is usually
the relative references change when a
formula is copied to another cell
depending on the destinations row and
column
okay
so this is called relative cell
referencing absolute cell referencing
irrespective of the cell you know you
don't have to depend on the value of the
cell destination there is no change when
a formula is copied
so this we i'll explain it in the next
slide
the basic difference is this type of
referencing is there by default in excel
relative cell referencing you just
insert the formula you don't need to put
a dollar sign in the formula whereas
absolute cell referencing if you don't
want to change in the formula when it's
copied across cell then absolute cell
referencing requires you to add a dollar
sign before and after the column
and
row address so
see for instance
this is relative referencing you know if
you see this this particular cell is
having we put the value as a3 into b3 so
what it will do is it will multiply a3
and b3 and it will give the product this
is relative cell reference
whereas absolute cell referencing is
again the same thing but you have to put
a dollar sign
before the column and the row number so
here you are specifying
this as a3 into
b2 okay
a3 into b2 and it will give you this
particular answer irrespective of that
it will give you it will calculate what
is there in this and it will give you
the answer
okay now we need move on to the next
point is basic question when you
scroll across an excel sheet sometimes
you have a header on the first row and
if you scroll down you will not be able
to see the first row so there is a
process uh or the there is a
trick to freeze the paints in the excel
so you just need to
have the rows locked so how do you
freeze paint this is the question so
what you need to do is you need to
select the view tab go to the view tab
and go to freeze panes it's a basic
thing and you will see this if you see
here
select the third row and click freeze
panes so you just select this and click
free page
okay
so you're going here and you're going to
the third row and you are going to view
tab and we are selecting freeze pane so
what happens is first two rows will be
locked
okay
these two rows will be
locked similarly for
if you want to freeze the columns okay
it's the same thing i am going to select
this particular column
and then click on view and then click
freeze pane
so what happens is the first two columns
unlock a and b will be locked and if i
scroll right you will always see the
customer name and category column so
these two we have logged and the next
will be scrolled so this is the
function of freezing pains okay
now coming on to the next one
and you will be asked
and you have an excel sheet or a
spreadsheet
and you want to restrict you want to
protect the data for from anyone or from
someone cop from copying the cell for
your worksheet so how do you do that you
need to select that particular data that
you want to protect
and then click ctrl shift f and then you
will see the
protection tab okay
you just need to go to the protection
tab and select lock
okay and you will be asked to put a
password wherein you will be getting the
review tab where you you need to select
the sheet put a password and just save
it so i will show you across in
one of the examples here so this is
particular uh data that you have and you
need to protect you select it
so here
as i said i selected it and then i just
press ctrl shift f so here you see the
protection click the protection tab and
then click select and then locked
then click ok and then you need to go to
the review tab and then click on the
protect sheet
and you are having the you need to
select this
protect worksheet and contents of locked
cells so you are selecting these and you
are protecting the content and you just
need to
put some password
okay
and then click ok
okay so this is how you protect the data
on a worksheet and you are selecting
this area ctrl shift f
and just put up a password and select
lock sheet so this is how you protect
the sheet from anyone to copy it
now the next question that you might be
asked is what is the difference between
a function and a formula in excel
so
you will be asked this question and you
need to remember this formula is like an
equation which is typed in by the user
you are typing it suppose a
one plus b two you are typing this
formula in one particular cell okay
whereas function functions are
predefined calculations it is like a
formula
which is already there in excel and you
can use it so as it says here it
consumes more time and it has to be
typed in manually you this is as per the
need basis and this is particularly it's
very quick and very efficient you have
inbuilt formulas in excel the sum and
multiplication product and
various other things that you will come
across so this is the basic difference
between a formula and a function in
excel okay
now the next question that you might be
asked is uh or you need to know
basically is
the order of operations used in excel
while evaluating the formulas so what is
the order you need to remember this
acronym pedmas p e d m a s or in other
simple terms you can use this also
please excuse my dear and sally so these
are the acronyms p
e d
m a s now let's see what happens first
and you uh in math when you do some
calculations you have order of
operations okay baud mass is the one of
the order of operations now in excel
similarly in excel when you put up a
formula you excel will calculate it
in a particular order and this is called
the order of operations and the order of
operations is first it will calculate
what is there in the parenthesis it will
perform this function and then it will
see if there are any exponents in it and
if it is there it will do that
calculation the next and after that it
will see if there is any multiplication
or division so p e d and then it will
see
if there is any addition
okay and then the last one will be the
subtraction so excel knows this and you
have to know this so that when you put
up a formula you will know what is going
to happen for us and you will not mess
up with your formula okay this is the
order of operations it is one of the
important questions in the interview for
a beginner excel
level now the next one is uh
how will you write the formula for
following multiply
the value in a cell a1 by 10 and add the
result by 5
and divide it by 2. it is quite simple
okay so i'm just giving it an example in
this slide and you might be asked
something else so you will be given a
task to
calculate or put up a formula for this
so when you are asked multiply the value
in a cell by of a 1 by 10 so this is
particularly thing okay a1 is the
particular cell that is being given and
you are multiplying it okay you put it
in parenthesis
and then
add the result by 5 so it will calculate
the parenthesis first okay and if it
sees if there are any exponents you have
to think in that way if there are any
exponents in it or not and then
first it will see the parenthesis and
then exponent there are no exponents
here and then it will do the
multiplication and then the
addition
and the division okay
so you will get this particular answer
and if you put it simply in this way
your answer is wrong because
it will multiply it into 10 add
5 and divide by 2 so you have to check
which one is right and you have to make
sure that you are putting the right
parenthesis okay
so
this is the formula
okay
the next question is uh
there is a difference what is the
difference between count counter and
count blank these are three particular
important things that you need to these
are similar but they are quite different
when you actually see it okay so first
we will see what is count count is
basically it counts the number of cells
which have numeric values as the name
suggests it is count it will count the
number of cells which has numeric
volumes okay if you see per this uh
column and uh where at a 11 we are
putting it as
count equals to a 10 to a 2 to 8 and so
you're taking this range and you're
finding out what are the number of cells
which have numeric value if you see this
one two
three four
five
so five cells have numeric values it
counts the
cells which has numeric value and the
next thing is the counter
okay what counter does it counts the
number of cells which has any form of
content it can be anything it can be a
number it can be a
alphabet it can be anything it will see
what are the
number of cells which has any form of
content okay for example this is the
same example we here taken here and we
have put the function as counter a two
to eighteen now see one two three four
five six
seven so it sees that there is
no seven cells have some content in it
it is numbers and
letters it can be anything but it has
some content so counter is the function
for this now the next one is count blank
okay as the name suggests it will count
the number of blank cells only
so again the same examples count black
a2 to a10 okay it will see what are the
number of blanks okay if you see this is
blank and this is black so two
cells are black so it will count the
number of blank cells only okay
now the next one is uh what is the
shortcut to add a filter to a table
why do we use filter and it is one of
the basics uh
function in the excel where you need to
do some sorting and it can be done by
using a filter what is the shortcut key
it's very simple control shift and l
this is the key that is used to put up a
filter you just press this
ctrl shift l all together and you will
find the filter and you can sort it now
the next question that you will come
across is how do you create a hyperlink
in excel
so it's quite simple there is a simple
shortcut ctrl
okay you press these two together and
you will get the option you will select
the it will select the cell where you
have to insert the hyperlink hyperlink
basically it redirects to
any other document it can be a web page
it can be a word document it can be
another excel sheet or so on okay
so these are the things
okay
now another important question
that is
how to merge multiple
cells text strings in a cell so how do
we merge the
text strings in multiple cells into one
cell
there is one particular simple function
that you can use which is called called
as concatenate concatenate function is
used to merge text strings present in
multiple cells
okay and it's a very simple thing you
just need to put this equals to
concatenate
and then if you for example this is the
formula concatenate text one text to
text
or this is uh
concatenate a1 comma b1 comma c1 this is
the data in our
three cells excel is fun in a1 b1 and c1
so now if you want to put them all in
one
and you can merge it in one cell using
the concatenate function and it's very
simple concatenate
and parenthesis a1 comma p1 comma c1
okay and you will get it all merge in
one particular cell
okay
so this is how you use the concatenate
function
and you can also use the and operator to
combine cell values it is the same thing
you can use e and operator instead of
commas okay
and i will show it to you in the example
here
okay now we have this i'll just copy
this thing to
[Music]
here
okay
and let's make it simple
and now i want to put this here
equals con
concatenate
and a 1
comma b 1
comma c
i just close it and i put enter so
you see this this all the the different
text is merged in one particular cell
and it will you can perform various
merge functions using the concatenate
function it's a very simple thing and it
is a frequently asked questions in the
interview okay
the next question uh it is very very
important one again
and very basic as well
so how can you split a column into two
or more columns you have some particular
text or a sentence written or data
written in your cell or a column and you
want to put them across in two or more
or many number of columns so how do you
perform this function it's very simple
again you need to select that particular
cell so for instance we have it here is
india is a democratic country india
space is space a space democratic space
country so the it's a different text
here and you want to split this
particular
sentence into different columns okay you
need to select that cell and then go to
the data tab and then choose text to
columns there will be an option and then
you need to select text to columns okay
and you will see this screen okay
and you need to select the choose the
delimiter here and what we are
specifying here is first it is a
delimited and then we are selecting a
delimiter as space because we see that
it is space here which is very common
and we want to split it so you will see
a preview here which shows what your
output will be like india in one column
is
a democratic country so the denominator
is space here
and
t you need to select this and then click
next okay
so you will see the options select the
columns data format and choose the
destination now you see the data view
and you need to select the destination
where you want to put this output as and
you select that and then click finish
and this one what it does it it's it
splits the text into multiple columns
okay so you see this you have selected
this as the output and it starts here
india is a democratic country so
uh you will come across some data which
is you know huge and there are spaces or
obliques or anything that is
differentiated it with and you need to
put them in different rows or different
columns so
this is the
function r that you
need to use to split the text into
different or multiple columns okay
okay the next question can be very
simple one or most widely used in fact
and what is the use of vlookup and how
do we use it
so what is this particular
thing in excel vlookup function is used
for looking up a piece of information in
a table and extracting some
corresponding data or information so you
have some set of values in one
particular column
and
you want to retrieve or extract the data
corresponding to that particular
column or a cell
in the whole sheet okay so the syntax is
something like this it is you need to go
to one particular
cell where you want the output as and
you type the function
we look up and you are selecting the
value of it is the
cell exactly where you want the output
to be and you are selecting the table
here
and the you're specifying the column
index
and range lookup so value this indicates
the value that you have to look for in
the
first column of a table okay
and then the table table basically this
refers to the table from which you have
to retrieve a value we will show this in
the example in the next slide
and the column index column index it
provides the column in the table from
which we are
to retrieve a value okay you will
specify the column index which one you
are looking for
the next thing is range lookup which is
optional true with if you put true it is
approximate match which is default and
false if it is exact match if you're
looking for the
exact match so what is the use of
vlookup and how do we do it okay
so find the product related to a
customer name richard okay you have this
sheet and in this one you want to see
what richard has what okay what is the
product
that he has bought and you can do this
with the
vlookup function okay so you just go
here and you type in the function
vlookup you're naming it as richard
and
first thing is the value it is h4 okay
and then the next thing is the table
okay table is a2 because this is the
table okay and you're looking for
customer name richard
okay and then you're selecting this
the whole column index which is e15 that
mean you're selecting this whole table
till 15 okay e 15 you're selecting this
and then the next thing is optional
which is giving you the
uh
range lookup okay what it does is it's
optional it is you're looking for an
exact value or an approximate by default
it is
approximately so how it performs the
function okay
so it gives you the answer as camera it
goes and look up for
richard in this particular it will give
you the output here and the
a2 is the table that it will look for
the customer name
and it will search for richard
and then it will give you the output as
camera now the next thing will be we
vlookup different from lookup function
how different they are vlookup lets the
user look for a value in the leftmost
column of a table so as we've seen in
the example it
allows you to look for a data in the
leftmost column of the table and returns
the value in a left to right okay it
starts in left to right well lookup
function lets the user look for data in
a row column and returns the value in
the another row or column it will give
you the lookup function in the next
workout okay not very easy to use as
compared to the lookup function okay as
we see uh it's a bit complicated when
you compare it to the
lookup function it's quite simple and
it is used to replace the v lookup
function okay
so this is the
different
lookup and vlookup function
now uh excel is basically used for
reporting mainly used for reporting to
management you have to extract different
kinds of
reports and what are the report formats
that are available in excel this is one
of the uh important questions again
for a beginner level and there are three
formats basically compact form
outline form tabular form okay these are
the three formats
that are available report formats that
are available
in
excel okay
the next question is about a function
which is how does if function work in
excel okay the f function in excel it
actually performs a logical test
and you will give a condition it
performs the test and returns a value if
the test evaluates to true and another
value which you again will specify if
the test result is false okay for
instance
we have here a simple example which is
shown in the slide
and what we are doing here is written
record is valid if age is greater than
20 we have age here specified
and
salary is greater than 40 000 else
return the record is invalid so we are
giving two conditions and it actually
checks and evaluates whether these
conditions are met and it will give you
the output where the record is valid or
invalid based on the two conditions that
are specified okay
and f2 to axis which is this these
column we are specifying it should be
greater than 20 and g2 to g6 which is
the salary column and we are specifying
the condition to be greater than 40 000
so based on this two things it will
check and perform if these conditions
are
met then it will give the desired result
okay so this is the
function that is used
in excel if function okay
the next thing is sum if function
okay again the summary function adds the
cell value specified by a given
condition or a
criteria so you are giving a condition
and you are actually doing another
function which is performing the
addition okay it will add the cell
values based on a condition again it is
shown here the total sum of salary where
salary is greater than 75 000. again for
example the salary column is g2 to g6
and we are doing a sum if function what
the result will be it will
perform the addition
of salaries which are greater than 75
000 so it will see which values are
greater than 75 000 and
then then the output will be it will be
adding these
salaries which are greater than 75
000 okay
now coming to the next
slide we will discuss another important
function counter and we'll find the data
um result based on the data that we have
and the count function so we have a
slide
their data here
and using the curvy data find the number
of days in which the number of deaths in
italy has been greater than 200 okay
it's not
shown here for some reason but i will
show you in the exact sheet okay so this
is the data that we have and we will try
to find the function so we will use the
count if function and counter function
is again simple count if you are
specifying the
column that is the
source that you are looking for that is
g2 the column g
and it is two it starts from two row two
g two till g three five triple seven
which is the end of the column and what
you're looking for is italy you're
specifying it in codes
italy and then the next column that it
will look for is the e column the number
of cases okay here we have the number of
cases e22 again we are specifying the
range and what we're looking for is
number of cases which are more than 20.
so we'll perform this function and we'll
show you the
output okay
i'll show you to you the excel
so here is the sheet and i will uh try
to get the
answer here
and
the
so we are performing count
okay
count f
and you are giving the
brackets parenthesis g2 which is the
countries column okay countries column
here who are specifying the whole range
three
five triple seven
there is basically uh a long a long list
of uh
data and you're specifying the page and
what you're looking for is particularly
uh any country you can pick up like
algeria
okay
algeria
and you specify it in quotes
okay
comma
then what is the next target that you
are looking for is the column e variable
it is mentioning the number of cases
okay so you specify the
column range for the number of cases
which is again e
and then
[Music]
the
three five triple seven i mean it's a
basically a long list of data that
you're looking for and then
you are what is the condition that you
want to know and you will have to
specify it in course and what you're
looking for is number of cases which are
more than
and you hit enter
okay so it give you the output as 143 so
there are 143 days in which the number
of cases were more than 20. so let's uh
refine our search further let's see 30
and it gives 140
so another example that you can take is
let's pick afghanistan
afghanistan and
so there are about 19 days that
you will see the number of cases where
more than 30
and this can be done with the
countif function
so the next question is
about
the pivot table
so what is a pivot table
it's basically is a summary of table of
the data set i mean the data that is
there that can be you know multiple
number of rows and columns which has
different
data that has to be that is there in the
reports and you need to analyze those
trends and you need to create a report
and basically present it to the
management or in a presentation
so pivot table is a summary of table you
know whatever data is there you can put
it in a summarized format they are
useful if you have long rows or columns
that hold values you need to try okay
so you have long list of data and you
need to summarize it and put it in a
presentation or a
you need to track the values so
it's very simple you have to select the
data
and then go to the insert tab and select
pivot table
okay
and then it will show up like this and
you need to
select the table which is a
table or range and then you need to
specify where you want to put up this
private table okay
and it's quite simple and i can show it
to you in one of the examples okay so
what you need to do is you need to
select this and once you generate or
as we have seen in the previous slide
you need to select this and you need to
select the output where you want to put
the
pivot table and then once you do that
you will see something like this and you
need to select these particular fields
and
put it in value so it will for example
you need to select the depth number of
death you can just simply say click this
select this drag and drop it in the
values okay so these are the different
fields that can be put up in the table
okay we can show it to you in the
example here
so this is our data and we need to
show it in a pivot table okay select
this
and then go to the insert tab and click
private table okay
select that
and it will show you the
uh table or the range and now where you
want to put it okay i will put it in the
existing worksheet okay
and i'll just select which color i'll
put it
here for example and it will show you
this and click ok so this is the table
and now you need to select the fields
that you want to show in the table for
example we need to see the continents
the number of cases as per the
continents okay i selected and put it in
the row and we see the immediately we
see it in a table
where you see the number of names of the
continents and now i want to see the
number of cases
and
i simply select it
and put it across the values so this is
quite simple and very informative very
short and crisp
rare form of presenting their data in
a private table okay
so this is how it is being used and it
is being presented
you just need to go to the insert tab
pivot table and it will generate the
table and then you can select the fields
all right
so the next question here is
how do we create a drop down list in
excel
this is particularly useful when you
need to sort
particular data with the drop down list
where a number of
different variables are there and you
need to select one particular
field and sort the data so you can do
this by creating a drop down list using
the data validation
present in the data tab it's quite
simple you select the data and you go to
the data validation tab
in the data and click select data
validation
so once you select that it will ask you
to specify a range so you need to select
what data you need to
sort and put a drop down so you need to
select this and click
data validation and you select the list
option which shows you that there is a
different option okay i'll show it
across in the excel for example what we
have here is some particular data and we
have different
variables we need to sort or put a drop
down list so just go to data as in as
said in the slides and go to data
validation
and click data validation now as you
click it it will ask you to data
validation settings okay and in the drop
down go and select list option
so it will ask you to specify the source
so when you asked to specify the source
just click this particular column
and click ok so here dimensioning the
source is
column b okay b
3 t b 14 okay
click okay and then it will give you the
option so here you can uh you can put
this in anywhere across the excel
and click the option okay
so this is the way to drop down using
the data validation option so in the
next example we will see so how do we
apply advanced filters in excel
we use the advanced filter option
present in the data tab so
this is the scenario wherein you have
multiple set of data
and you need to sort it and it's here
it's actually huge data
and you need to sort a particular column
or a field
with this criteria
and you can select it and specify the
criteria and specify a range what you
want to
select or based on what criteria the
range can be specified
and you can just get it in a single
click
so
this is the option you have to go to
data tab advanced and you have to apply
the advanced filter and then you need to
specify the list range that is the
basically the source and then the
criteria where you specify the criteria
present here i mean you are specifying
in this case we will take an example
where we are trying to
sort the data of the number of cases
based on number of deaths
and in a particular country and we are
specifying the
output we the copy to field easy output
where you will see the output so i'll
show it to you in the excel so here we
have a spreadsheet wherein you will see
all the
uh data kobe data that we have and based
on the countries and the continents and
the number of deaths number of cases and
so on okay and it also has different
fields like the date year and month
so so here i am going to sort the data
which is particularly for europe and
which has deaths of more than 200 in a
day so how do we do it go to data
advanced and
the
you need to select copy to another
location okay and this is the list range
so it's basically given in this
countries okay and the criteria range
you have to specify this so i am going
to select this
as my criteria okay
and then
i have to put the output in one
particular cell so i need to select it
again
let's say here okay
and then i just click okay
see
it's quite simple instead of running
through the whole thing
we can just do it with a simple
function okay so it shows me the deaths
which are more than 200
and
for which particular country and for
which particular
continents all right so this is
basically
made very simple with this option the
next question is
you know you need to highlight some
particular cells using a particular
criteria in this case we are trying to
analyze or highlight those cells where
the total sales is more than five
thousand dollars so what we do is we use
conditional formatting to highlight the
cells based on the criteria
it's a very useful tool in analyzing
data and
visually it helps you know you can have
a look at the
data in
quick flash you will see the data and
it's quite visible using the conditional
formatting so how we do that is i will
show it to you
now
so as said in the slide we have the data
of the sales that is provided to us and
we need to see
who has done more sales which is greater
than the five thousand dollars so just
go to home
and you need to say go to conditional
formatting so for that you need to
highlight or select this go form
conditional formatting highlight
okay and you have different options here
you select creator that
and you specify the value right here my
criteria is five thousand
dollars okay we can select which color
so let's go for green
okay
see this you will immediately see
the
option you don't have to dig or look in
deep into the data and find out which
one is more than 5000 or any particular
value
okay so conditional formatting now
moving on to the next question the index
and match function you must be familiar
with the index and match function and
why it is used basically index
function is a very powerful tool
wherein you know you
for example you have a table of
planets in our solar system and you want
to get the name of the fourth planet
mars so you can do it with a formula
using the index function and at the same
time
you can use the match function okay with
the match function together you can play
wonders with it okay match function is
another function that is designed to
find the position of an item in a range
for example we can use the match
function
to get the position of a word or
look or
in this case we have a name and we can
use the
index and match function to
find the city
how we do that is
shown here
okay it
it looks quite complicated here when you
see the formula but
i can show it to you in the excel and
explain it further okay
so here i have and i want to know
where these people are and where they
belong to
okay
so
let's see how it goes as we have seen it
and
we use the index function okay
index okay
now when i have to specify the
range okay
so the range is a2 and it shows it
selects the
name and i want to select it from a2 to
a7 okay e7 sorry
e
column e
7
okay so as you see it highlights the
whole table
okay now what i'm going to do is i want
to match it okay
match it with a condition i have i am
specifying a condition a 10 why
because i have to specify a name here
and it will show me the
city where he belongs to okay
where it shows is a
2 okay if you see a2 it shows the name
through a7 i have to specify the range
here okay not just one name we are
specifying the
whole range as you see if you put the
values it will show you the selection
okay
it's in and what it should be it should
be the
exact match so
zero denotes the exact match parenthesis
is closed
and i am putting another match condition
okay what is this and this will give me
the output
what output is
okay
b
nine okay this is my
city b9 is the city where i'm trying to
find from okay
and what it should look for is a column
a a one through
e
one okay
it should select these
this particular
row and
what it should be it should be the exact
match again okay
let's see how it goes it will give you
an error because you haven't put the
value here okay so let's see
and
okay
hit enter and you will see
the city where he belongs to okay
now let's see where anna belongs to
enter let's choose dallas okay so this
is the
one other function index and match
function being used and it can be asked
in frequently in the interview questions
okay the next question will be uh how to
find duplicate values in a column
okay there are two ways that you can
actually do this and
one is
basically the very simple one which is
the conditional formatting and the other
one is we have seen this before count if
function okay how we do that you need to
simply select the data
and go to conditional formatting
and select duplicate values
it's quite simple and there is another
way
which give you the color-coded
conditional formatting again there is
another way that is the count if
function how we do that is again
you have to put another column and put
up a
countif criteria content function
wherein you see that you are specifying
the range
and
the
the value which is being twice or enter
duplicate and you have to put up a
condition i will show it to you in the
text
so here we have the data and i need to
find the duplicate values here so i just
select this
and as i said it's quite simple go to
conditional formatting
form and then go to conditional
formatting and select highlight cell
rules and simply go down and select the
duplicate values
okay it will give you what color you
want you can simply select red or
anything as you see the moment you
select you will see the
duplicate values highlighted
okay so i just cancel this and there is
another way then count a function so
i'll put another column
where it says duplicate names and i will
put up a counter function here
okay
so let's see how a counter function
works here to check the or find the
duplicate name
so as i said i will put up a formula a
function here for the count if
and we'll drag it to other cells okay
count it and
since it's an absolute
reference
i have to put up a dollar symbol okay my
reference here it will be h the column
here h
two
okay
and again dollar because i'm using it as
an absolute reference
colon
through
dollar symbol again
nine
okay so it drags still at the hole
it drags till the all the names okay the
h9 all right
and then
what i'll do is i'll put a comma
in
why i want to do is i have to
select
h
h2
okay this is my criteria i mean it is
repeating twice all right
and
i have to
close the parenthesis and if it is more
than one okay
so this is my formula i just put enter
and it should say true so this is the
condition
and it is true okay i simply drag it
the whole thing
and whether events is uh repeated yes
it's true
andrew it's a duplicate entry false
me
is a duplicate entry and it says true
and as you see me and events are
duplicate entries so this is how we use
the count tip function
and the conditional formatting to sort
duplicate entries in the date
now let's move on to the last question
for the beginner's level and since we
have duplicate entry there is also
a problem to remove duplicate entries so
how can you remove duplicate values in a
range of cells okay to simply do that
you can delete the duplicate values in a
column by simply selecting the
highlighted cells and press the delete
button so you go in each column and you
see the duplicate values
select it and delete it okay
and this is one tedious way of doing it
and you can also after deleting the
values you can go to the conditional
formatting choose clear rules to remove
the rules from the sheet
so this is one way okay the next thing
is again a simple button that is there
in the
data tab that is the
is one of the tools present in the data
tab which is simply called as remove
duplicates it's quite simple
and it's there in the data tools let me
show you in the excel
so here we are and
we have this data and we need to check
and remove the duplicate so as i said go
to the
data tab and simply click on remove
duplicates and when you click on it it
will ask you you want to continue or
expand this selection i just say
continue with the current selection and
remove duplicates okay
select all click ok
to duplicate entries that were removed
previously we saw that events in uh
and away there any weather so that has
been removed
okay
so
that's it for the beginner level and
we'll go to the intermediate level in
the next slides choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1 000
plus hours of video content for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
so here we are at the intermediate level
questions and these are like a higher
level or intermediate level
compared to the previous things that we
have discussed with the basic level
questions uh for the excel interview so
let's move on to the next thing
and
so there are there are some scenarios
where you enter the date or
some dates in particular data sheet
and you need to find out
what is the
day of the week okay so you might be
asking your question how do you find out
the day of a week for a particular date
so that is the function we have a
specific function and that is the
weekday function to find out the day of
the week for a particular date
okay so as we know these are the seven
days of the week and
we just put the
function as it says
equals to weekday and we need to enter
the
column or the
area or the cell
address here so weekday is the function
and it will give you the
which which day it is of the week okay
we go as it says one it denotes sunday
okay
and three is again tuesday okay
so this is the function that is used to
find the day of the week
so now we move on to the next one
and there is a there might be a question
what are the wild cards available in
excel so basically excel sports three
types of wild card which are
asterix the star it represents any
number of characters it can be used in
different formulas and all like
multiplication and all so it represents
any number of characters okay the next
one next wildcard is the question mark
it represents one single character okay
you just need to memorize this in the
back of your mind that it represents one
single character okay whereas asterisk
is
it represents any number of characters
and the third one which is rarely used
in excel it is the tilde
it is used to identify a wildcard
character that is
tilde asterix question marks in the text
okay and it is very rarely used so you
need to memorize these three things that
the there are three types of wild cards
we can see the functions of these in the
later sessions okay
the next one is
we have a
question here what is the data
validation illustrate with an example
you might be asked this question and you
have to know what is data validation
what is what is it used for and you
should know how to set up in an example
okay data validation is a feature in
excel that is used to control what a
user can enter into a cell okay so you
have with the data validation you are
not allowing
a data kind of data that should be input
in the
cell okay for example you
have the authority and by setting up the
data validation that you can enter
either a number or a text or a adjust
number
and so on okay using the data validation
and where is it available it is in the
data tab okay select data validation
option present under data tools
okay and you just need to select the
particular
cells where you want to set up the data
validation i'll show it to you in an
example so this is how it looks like you
just need to go to data tools and click
on data validation and it will show you
and you have the options here allow and
if you click on the drop down you will
see different options like i will show
it to you in the example here okay
for this particular thing if i want you
know
this column should have only
names and it should have if you insert a
number you will be thrown with an error
okay you will get an error message
saying that this is not a valid option
okay
so
there are some columns where you have to
put only names or you have to put only
number so you can set this up with the
data validation
technique okay you just allow it or
customize it as per your requirement so
this is how it looks like when you set
up an app so here we have set up a data
validation saying that it should not
allow you to put any text okay so you
will get an error when you put a number
here the value does not match data
validation restrictions defined for this
cell
okay
so here as an example i have some data
where i am putting the names here and
i'll put the salary here i want to make
sure that you know we cannot
enter any
numbers here okay it should be only text
it should have only name so how do i
perform that how do i restrict any user
to that they should not be able to enter
any number and you should only enter the
text okay so there is a function okay
you just need to go to data validation
click data validation
and here in the setting
i'll go to custom there are different
options here you can you can choose
whole numbers decimal list
date time so your these are the options
and i go to custom and i'm giving a
particular formula here okay what is
that it should be only text okay so it's
a simple thing it should be text and i
need to define the range okay so how
i'll define the ring i just select this
okay and
i select the range okay
so i have selected the range here
and if you go to input message
and error alert you can customize it and
here we are taking the default one and
this is the input message if you want to
set or customize something okay so let's
see how it works okay i have said this
and then i try to put a
number here
and it throws me an error the value
entered is not valid because we have set
a restriction a user has restricted
values that can be entered into the cell
so this is how the data validation works
the next thing is
you will be given a situation wherein
you have to
uh you will be given data and you have
to
perform a function like
in this example we are taking a
condition wherein you will have data and
you have to specify the result based on
that data you have to
formulate it okay so given below is a
student table
write a function to add password fail to
the results
column based on the following criteria
you will be given a criteria so this is
the student table you are giving the
student
names marks and attendance and then
based on that
you will have to specify
a next uh
a formula
wherein you will see the result okay
based on the past uh student data you
have to put a pass fail results in the
column based on the following criteria
what is the criteria
and for example here in this example
what they're saying is
you have to
say this the student is passed if his
marks is more than 60 and the attendance
is more than 75 percent okay so how we
perform this function as it says you
have to use the if function and check
with the and condition to fill the
results column okay
so let's see this in the example here
so here is the example and we will
perform the
if function and check with the and
function so how we do that is here okay
so i have to
put the if function here
okay
and check with the and function okay
and i have to specify the conditions i
have to satisfy where it should see the
or check the conditions okay so we are
checking the
conditions here and the marks should be
in row um in the column u
and it starts with u five so let's see
u
five okay it will immediately go to
column u and five row five okay
and then what is the condition we are
satisfying here it should be greater
than
60 okay
and the other condition is
the column v that is the attendance
column okay and what is the condition we
are specifying v
5 should be greater than
75 okay
and we just close this conditions with
the parenthesis and now we have to
specify the result whether it is pass or
fail
pass
comma
in quotes again
wait
okay
so let's see how this works okay
okay see this works okay the marks is 50
and attendance is greater than 80. so he
is
failed because his marks are 50 his
attendance must be more than 75 but yes
he is
he has not scored marks more than 60. so
we drag the same formula to the
whole thing and you will see the result
okay this is quite simple and you will
see this
formula and using the if and
check
and check with and condition okay now
moving on to the next question you might
be asked to
you know this is a simple function
wherein you can you will be asked to
calculate your age in years from the
current date okay so how we do that
there is a particular function and it's
very simple use the year frac or dated
if function to return the number of
whole days between start date and the
end date so you specify a start date
which will be
today's date and the
i mean the birthday and then the end day
will be
today's day for example okay and you
will get to know the h using the year
frac function and dated if function okay
so here is a small example and this is
how we use the
ear frag function okay you specify this
function and then specify the input
that is the today's date and the
date of birth and the
today's date okay and this is one of the
ways to get it and there is also dated
okay this again it is day-to-day
function and you specify the input cells
okay so let me show you an example for
the same
so here we are and
we have today's date that is the fourth
of may
and date of birth for anything it could
be
so i will specify the
ear track function okay
equals
here
rack okay
and then i should as soon as you enter
you specify the start date and the end
date okay
and i will specify the start date as
today's date that picks the column and
then i put the comma
and then the end date should be this
thing okay and just close it and it will
give you the
age
okay so this is the age for example if
you want to find out my age i don't want
to reveal my body but it's okay
okay
let's see if it calculates
i'm 32 years old okay
all right so this is one of the ways and
similarly you can use the dated if
function shown in the example all right
now moving on to the next question
you have a nested if statements this is
very important and you will definitely
be
coming across this question how are
nested if statements used in excel what
are nested if statements the f function
can be nested i mean it can be loop when
we have multiple conditions to meet okay
it can be nested the false value is
replaced by another if function okay
you have specified some condition and
you are
putting up a condition and if that
condition is not there or not met then
if it will be replaced with another
if function so
the syntax will be like this below is an
example
so we
actually we use two if statements in
conjunction okay so here is an example
here we are specifying a condition
wherein you know
uh the result is excellent if it is more
than 80 and if it is less than 60 it is
bad or average so this is very simple
you perform one if condition and if that
is not met
it will go for the next if condition so
we are nesting two if conditions we are
joining two if statements
okay uh i'll show the same example here
in the excel
so here we are we have some data and the
students and their marks okay and we are
specifying a condition wherein
if the
result or marks are more than 80 the
result is excellent and if it is
less than 60 it is bad or average okay
so how we get this is we use two if
conditions if
statements
so
uh as we have seen it
if
if
now the first condition is
uh our source or the
source is b
two okay
so b
two
and what i'm specifying is it should be
greater than
80
all right i just close this
and the result should be
excellent okay
excellent if it is more than 80 and
if this condition is not met it will go
to the
next
if statement okay we are nesting another
if statement what is the condition here
for the next statement it will check b2
is
less than or equal to
60 you can specify any marks all right
so if it is less than 60 it should give
the result as
bad
our average okay
specify anything and you
okay
and just close the double parentheses so
let's see how it works okay see
it works like this
now let's pull up the same
formula the for the other results okay
see
if it is more than 90 it is 90 it is
excellent so it is checking the first
thing if it is greater than 80 it is
excellent okay and now in this case for
mark it is bad why because it will first
see whether it's excellent or not if it
is not excellent then it is check the
other condition if it is less than 16 it
will give you the
bad result all right
and similarly so on for the
other
marks all right
so this is how we use the
nested if statements
you are adding two if statement the
first condition and the second condition
with another if statement okay
okay when it comes to excel it is
basically involves a lot of data and a
lot of data to be analyzed
and we have some powerful tools which
are used in excel to analyze the data
one such
important tool is descriptive statistics
that is used to analyze the data so
we
might come across a question and you
will be given a data or a table and you
need to find the descriptive statistics
of the columns using data analysis tool
okay so you will be given us maybe for
example anything and you will have a lot
of data you have to use the descriptive
statistics option
in
excel for the data analysis okay how you
do that is you have to add a pack okay
you should be knowing that you need to
add a
pack which is called the analysis tool
pack which you go to
file options and then just click on the
add-in and select the analysis tool pack
click
excel add-in and just click go
then it will add the
option
and then when you select the data you
have to go to the click on the data
analysis option which will be
which will show up when you select the
add-in or when you add the
add-in okay then you need to select the
descriptive statistics what we need to
do is we need to analyze this data and
it will show you the
values like mean and the
you can also customize you can you see
you have these data and for you to check
each and every row and find the mean the
smallest the
maximum number
and things like that so this can be
easily done using the descriptive
statistics for the data analysis
uh i'll show the same thing in the excel
how it can be performed
so here we are and i'll show you first
how to
add the
option to it okay go to add-in
select analysis tool pack
as shown in the slide and you need to
click go if you just click okay it will
not add so just click go and then you
need to select analysis tool pack okay
these are the different options uh
for now we are selecting analysis tool
pack and then click ok as soon as you do
that you will see the data analysis this
option gets enabled
when you add that pack so this is the
data that you have you need to find or
analyze using the descriptive statistics
so as you see it
click data analysis and click uh select
descriptive statistics okay and it will
show up the option like this and you
need to select the input range okay for
some reason it's already there and
if you want me to show i will show it to
you across you have to select the whole
data
okay this is my input range and you need
to select this labels in the first row
so that you know it doesn't take the
first row okay i'll show you
okay and now i'm putting the output in
another
worksheet okay you can specify or you
can filter by a new worksheet and these
are the
options that you can select so you can
you are getting a summary statistics
which is the default and you can select
the confidence level that is the mean
value and you can set it up by whatever
value percentage you want and you are
selecting the largest one and the
smallest number so all these data will
get analyzed and it will open up in a
new sheet and just click ok
and you will see this so these are the
if you see this is our data paid organic
social and revenue so this is uh
okay
let's make it more precise
okay
so with a single click
yeah all our data is analyzed okay this
is the mean value and this is the
minimum is zero maximum is so return sir
this is the total and the number of
count is thousand so you don't need to
scroll down and check what is the
largest
amount that is paid so this is the
largest amount for the paid okay and so
on so
the largest revenue generated all these
things are
generated with a descriptive analysis
okay
descriptive statistics with the data
analysis too so the next question is
about a pivot table and this is more
refined or more advanced compared to the
last one that we discussed in the
beginner level so here you are asked to
create a pivot table to find the total
cases in each country belonging to their
respective continents you are giving you
are being asked to
put up a table of pivot table with two
variables basically each country and
their respective continents so again we
have the same data and we need to set up
a pivot table which shows the
continents in the countries with the
respective continents the number of
cases
okay so let's see how we get this in the
example
so here we are we have the same data
it shows the days months here cases
countries
and their
continents okay
continents here and so on okay so i'm
i'll go to the insert tab and select the
pivot table okay again the same thing i
will be asked to enter a input range
okay
so i select this
and since it's huge i'll just
put the number to be seven seven seven
seven
okay let's assume
now this is our input data and uh
where you want the output to be it's
already selected you can put it anywhere
i am putting it here okay just click
okay and it will give you the option to
select the fields now what we want is
number of cases okay which will show you
the value and the
countries
and
territories their respective continents
so
okay so this is how it looks like and we
have to
check
now it is asking us to find the
countries okay so
with their respective continents
you see this you see africa as a
continent and you will see
okay
you will see africa
if you just remove this you will see the
number of con i mean the cases with the
respective continents and if you want to
include these countries territories
where the respective continents you will
see
as if you just expand this you will see
the countries that are having the cases
in the continent africa okay so
country-wise sorted with the continents
okay this is another advanced step to
get the data or show the data in the
pivot table okay another question that
you might be asked is a basic and we
have already seen this in the previous
example that i have shown how do you
provide the dynamic range in data source
of a pivot table you have to select a
particular data source in your input
table
have to show up in the pivot table so
you have to select the input range but
how do you
create or how do you create a provide a
dynamic range in this data source so
just need to create a name table to
provide a dynamic range so
where is the data of your table so as we
have seen in the previous example
you will be able to select the input
range and you just need to put this
value any number
so that you know it will pick up the
dynamic range for your input source for
the table okay so
now we move on to the next one and this
is about about the pivot table again is
it possible to create pivot table using
multiple sources of data yes
yes you can create a pivot table from
multiple worksheets sometimes you will
have different data in different sheet
can you create a pivot table
for
all the worksheet in a single pivot
table yes you can but there is a
condition there should be a common row
in both the table so you cannot have
different types of data there should be
a common row okay so then only it will
act as a primary key for the first table
and the foreign key for the second table
okay
so this is something that you have to
remember
and you need to create a relationship
between the tables and then build the
pivot table so you have to analyze what
kind of data it is it should have a
common row in both the tables on both
the sheets and then you have to
establish a relationship between this
table and then build the table okay
there is a visit for that we'll
see that later now let's move on to the
next question so the next question is
again you know with the pivot table uh
wherein you will be asked to further
refine or
you know refine your search and show it
in the data so here we have with the
kovid data example again you will be
asked to create a pivot table to find
the top three countries from each
continent based on the total cases using
the coveted again we have done this
before we have created a pivot table for
this and we need to further refine it
showing the top three countries with the
number of cases
and i will show that same thing in the
excel and we already have created a
table and we'll refine it further to
show the top three countries which are
having the
highest number of accounts in the
respective context so here we are we
have the table uh already with us and
i just click on the
show field list it will show me the
countries and territories what we are
asked is you know to show the countries
with the top three that is number of
cases
so you just need to go here and you need
to select the value filter there is a
filter which you can select with the
value and how i select top 10 and what i
need is top three it's very simple and
you just need to know these things okay
and based on the number of cases okay
this is our field already then just
click ok and it will show you the top
three countries so it's quite simple and
it is very important to know this uh
field and how you play with the value of
the filters for each particular uh field
in the pivot table so it shows you these
things all right and now you can refine
it further with the continents and all
okay
so different continents and you can see
this so you go there and there is a
value filter you can set up all right
you have set up a value filter okay
okay now there is another one
how do you create a column in a pivot
table okay
like you will be given a situation where
you need to add one more column and show
it in the pivot table with a particular
calculation or with a particular value
and you have you don't have that actual
value in your
data but you have to calculate it and
show it across in the table so there is
another option which is called pivot
table analyze and you need to create a
calculated field from pivot table
analyze option
so when you go to your table and then go
to pivot table analyze you will see the
option to add a calculated field
okay
just go there and click select
calculated field and you need to define
so in this example we are going to
define another
column where we calculate the bonus of
the sales and there is a particular
formula the formula is you put an if and
statement and then you calculate the
formula you specify what is the bonus
and what is the way that you're
calculating the bonus and it will
particularly add it another column
to your table so let's see how we do
that in the
table net so here we are we have this
table and i have inserted a
pivot table and i am putting it in
output here
okay and then you will get the table
okay
now you need to select the
customer name
and the unit sold unit price saves
okay so we will add another column to it
how we do that is this
go to pivot table tools and then you go
to analyze okay
click on field items and set okay we
need to select calculated field here
select that and we are defining a new
field here which is the bonus
bonus and
as i said we will put up a formula for
this and we will define it how
we calculate the bonus okay
with an if and statement which we have
seen before how we put up a
and if and statement okay now i'm going
to say it as
like this sales my sales
should be
i'll specify a condition how they will
calculate the bonus if sales is greater
than 4000
and
the units sold okay i am trying to put
it as the units which also depends on
the units
sold
is greater than
thousand okay for example let's say
thousand a person who is uh
able to
do uh
sales of thousand four thousand and the
unit sold should be more than thousand
then the sales
what is this the bonus will be
sales
into that is the amount of sales he has
done
into five percent okay let's say five
percent bonus
and
sales
is
if it is two percent okay
okay
we are adding this field bonus
click add
okay
so we have added this and we have put up
a calculation for the formula and you
will see this in the so this is simple
way of adding the
column to your existing data and we are
doing the calculations and showing it up
okay so this is one way go to pivot
table analyze and field
items and sets you can select this
option and add it okay you can customize
this as i said with adding different
fields this is pretty handy in analyzing
the data which does not exist in the
table and you add some value to your
pivot table okay
the next question will be about slicer
you must be familiar with what a slicer
is in a pivot table and how do you use
it what are the purpose of using it
and how do you
put up a slider in the paper table so
how does a slicer work basically slicers
are used to further filter data in the
pivot table suppose you already have
some data
and it's for ease that you can do it by
just adding a slicer you can select
particular
data in or a field
and you can see the output for that
particular field that you have chosen
in the
slicer okay so it's very simple go to
the insert tab and select slicer under
filters okay
and then it will be like this okay and
here if for example you see this is our
pivot table we have added two slicers
to filter our table that is month and
countries and territory so this will be
the general pivot table that looks like
and we haven't added another two slices
that is month and country so if you go
for example if you want to see what is
the
number of cases and some of the deaths
for a particular month and for a
particular country you can just do it by
a single click and it will show that
particular data only in the table let's
see
and do this in our excel
okay
so there is a table uh pivot table
already created for this and i want to
add a slicer so how do i go ahead and do
this is i go to the
options and
insert slicer okay at the moment you
click on it you will see what are the
options that you want to add you can
select different fields and
select the slicer for it uh for this
example we are choosing month
okay this is one of our sliders you can
just put it here
adjacent to the
and again
this will be our slider okay
let's add another slicer here
okay
and this will be the countries and
territories okay
click on that and you will see two
simple badges here that you can choose
from so if i want to know in the month
of feb
how many number of cases were there for
particular let's see the moment i choose
the month it will show that particular
number of the corresponding table for
the whole and now i want to further
refine it to a particular country so for
example australia okay so there were
total number of 18 cases and zero deaths
at the same time if i go for algeria it
is like this
so
as you see
it goes like this okay so this is one of
the very important tool that you can use
to show the data in a much simplified
manner and ease
okay so the next question is about the
pivot table again what is the percentage
of contribution of each country in
continents to the total cases again the
same example for our code the coveted
one in this time we want to show the
output as the percentage of contribution
for each country and continents to the
total cases
so we have the same data and we generate
a pivot table and we should show it as
the sum of the cases uh to be percentage
okay and this is how we do it
this is our
data and i'm going to create a pivot
table for this
okay
so it shows the table
and here i have to show
what is the
fields that we need to select okay
first is we're just selecting
the
cases and the countries and territories
okay
so
cases to be the values okay
okay so this is how it looks like
now when i see
let me show you
see it shows the number of cases now if
i just want to refine it further and see
it as number of
percentage percentage as the number of
cases okay so how i do it show field
list
i go here
and i go to
value field settings okay
then
again
number format
show the value as okay
sorry
show the value as you need to select
this thing
percentage of grand total and then just
click ok
and you will see this to be the
percentage so
it shows
the data in the form of percentage
okay this is very simple and you just
need to remember as we have seen before
show fan field and then value field
settings okay this is the thing that you
need to check okay grand percentage
there are other options also
and you can select from whatever you
want in this case we are showing
it to be the percentage okay okay guys
now the next question is about uh in a
very important aspect of presentation
when we come to
favorite charts how do you create a
favorite chart in pivot tables this is
very
basic or very you know
important aspect of pivot tables that
you can represent uh data in a in the
form of a chart and there are different
types of charts which i'll show it to
you in the
[Music]
okay so we have a data here and we want
to show it at in
right now it is in a tablet form
okay we have put up a pivot table for
this and now if the same thing can be
put up in a favorite chart okay so what
you need to do is go to the insert tab
and select the pivot chart it depends on
different versions of excel that you
have different uh forms or different
buttons so i will show it across to you
and this is how it looks like okay it's
very simple it can be a pie chart it can
be a
bar chart it can be
different forms and we can see that in
the example here okay so let's go to the
example and
so we have the uh pivot table generated
here already what you need to do is you
need to select the table
and go to
insert and
see the options there are there is a
column chart there is a line chart there
is pie bar
area scattered and other parts okay
there are different pumps okay so right
now what we do is we will select the
column chart here
okay you need to select the pivot table
and click on the column chart again
there are different forms which
can be seen uh in some time now
so this is the basic form okay
and it will show you the countries i
mean that and it will show it as a form
of a chart okay
again you can change the chart type you
can change it to pi okay
this personally is very good in
presenting or doing presentation
and you can select different forms
different styles okay it'll also show
you the percentage
so this is one form of presenting your
table
into a chart okay again bar type is also
there
so this won't suit here in our example
there are different ones i'm just
showing it to you
as how it looks like
so depending on your uh
i mean the aesthetic you can see and
select what kind of chart is best
suitable
okay
so this is how you put up a pivot chart
in
pivot tables
okay
so this is been last for the
intermediate level and
what are macros in excel create a macro
to automate a task basically
you have some daily tasks that you
perform in excel okay
and
you can do this with quite ease using
the macros okay it basically is a
program that resides within the excel
file and it is used to automate tasks in
excel some daily tasks that you run like
running when you come across in any data
and you have to scrub that data and
you do some daily routines and by
removing some columns or adding some
formulas
and you know
doing some adding some colors and
changing the fonts or be it anything
that you perform and you have to do a
repetitive task so all that can be done
by recording a macro and this is what
macro is used for in excel so
how you capture those steps in excel is
through a macro to record a macro you
can either go to the developer tab in
the excel and click on record macro or
you can use or access it from the view
tab okay so
these are the
ways to access macros okay just go to
the developer tab and click record macro
wherein you know when you click record
macro it will record the steps that
you're performing in each step and it
will capture that and you can save that
it is like a daily routine that you run
and you can do all these multiple steps
maybe n number of steps within a single
click by running that macro later on
okay
so you record a macro and run that okay
you do it through the developer tab
go to developer tab and click record
macro
and it records all the steps that you're
performing okay you need to name it
and you just need to perform the actions
and it will record the macro and you
just save it later on whenever you come
across the same daily task that you run
you can just click it by running that
macro okay
so in a single click it will perform all
the
actions that you have done or steps that
you have performed on that particular
excel sheet or any other excel sheet
okay this is very handy when you have
similar data and you do the similar
tasks each day okay
so this ends the
intermediate level and in the next we
slides we will see the advanced level
so now we discuss the advanced level uh
interview questions for excel
and when it comes to the advanced level
you will come across definitely you will
be asked about
what if analysis how does it work how
does it or how does what-if analysis
work in excel so what if analysis as the
name suggests
you have to have
an analysis done
okay
with the help of different complex
mathematical calculations like formulas
and
using different formulas and
calculations
you can experiment with the data and you
can
analyze if this particular input changes
what will be the scenario
how will your output turn out to be
so as you
can see
it is about different variables to see
how your changes would affect the
outcome of a situation so
this is what what if analysis is and the
same thing can be done with excel and
how it is done is you need to go to the
data tab and click on the what if
analysis under forecast okay so there
are three options in
one is the scenario manager goal seek
and the
data table so these are the three
situations or three tools which are
available in the what if analysis
in the data tab okay so goal seek is
basically for reverse calculations
okay
and you have some
idea you have some set goal in mind
and you have certain variables and
what you need to do and what you
need to achieve
to have certain set goals okay you have
you will set a value for the goal and
with the goal seek option you can get
to know what value you have to achieve
to
come to that
level okay
so
this is what goal seek is
it is one of the simplest sensitivity
analysis tool
and
so for example you know that you know a
single outcome you would like to achieve
like you have a set goal that you have
to achieve this particular grade
okay
and the goal seek feature in excel
allows you to
arrive to that goal by mathematically
adjusting a single variable within that
equation so you set the goal and you
will do the what-if analysis goal seek
option
to
know what you have to do or what you
have to achieve
for the set goal
the next option is the data table and it
is basically used for sensitivity
analysis
okay so
in this
scenario
you
the data tables allow the adjustment of
only one or two variables within a data
set
but each variable can have unlimited
number of possible values okay
so basically they are used for
side-by-side comparisons
in it makes it very easy to read the
scenarios okay one but you need to set
up the
data table correctly okay and
what you do is
you give the input in the table and then
you set up the formula and for instance
you need to calculate the monthly
payments for a loan okay you provide the
principal amount like
whatever amount you're taking two laps
three lakhs and you set the interest
rate in a formula okay
and you set the term
in
and then you need to
provide different uh input options like
what loan amount that you're taking
and
you set the formula and go to data table
and
i mean go to what-if analysis and select
the data bill table stretches across
and then you will see the monthly
payment options or the monthly emi that
you can calculate there are different
things that you can calculate you can
calculate the target or the sales bonus
or things like that okay giving
different scenarios in the
variables okay but you need to set up a
data table it might be a little
challenging but yes it is a very
powerful tool okay
so the next one is the scenario manager
it is a bit more complicated compared to
the other two but then it is uh more
advanced than goal seek as it allows you
the uh to adjust the multiple variables
at the same time okay and
this is very complicated compared to the
other two
and it is even i mean it gives more
better output when it compares to the
other two what-if analysis tools
so here when you go to what-if analysis
and the scenario manager you have to
select the data and provide different
scenarios that is different values for
each scenario and then it will create a
it will analyze calculate and create
different scenarios okay so it becomes
very easy for you to analyze what if you
are changing the value
of your interest amount or the
term of loan or your targets like
monthly targets or an yearly targets and
things like that and you just have to
see what the scenario will be when you
set this particular value
for a
table or for data whatever targets that
you need to set you can use this what-if
analysis in
excel for the different
scenarios and different calculations
okay these are very powerful tools and
you need to know this
now as we move on to the next one you
might be asked what is the difference
between a function and a subroutine in a
vba
okay
even though these two are used quite
frequently
there is a
pretty much different from each other
okay so a function always returns a
value of the
task it is performing okay so when you
are writing a module
you will have a function when you have a
function it will always give you a value
okay for example you are performing an
addition it using the function it will
give you a value for sure whereas
subroutine it does not return a value of
the task it is performing functions are
called by a variable okay
you can
set up a variable and you can call the
function okay whereas subroutines can be
recalled from anywhere in the program in
multiple types okay in many different
ways you can recall a subroutine like we
have seen
we write a subroutine and we put up a
button and we can when you click the
button it will recall the subroutine
functions are called by variable okay
you have to set up a variable and when
you enter it it will come up okay
functions are used directly in
spreadsheets as formulas whereas sub
cannot be used directly in spreadsheets
as formula okay this is very important
difference and the next thing is the
functions can be used to perform
repetitive tasks and return a value
whereas users must insert a value in the
desired cell before getting the result
of the sub so this is particularly
limited okay whereas functions can be
used to perform different repetitive
tasks and return a value user input is
not required whereas
if you see the subroutines user must
insert a value okay
in the desired cell that too in a
particular cell which is defined in the
subroutine to getting the desired result
okay so these are the differences
between functions and subroutines now
the next one is
what is the difference between this
workbook and
active workbook in vba
so when you work on modules and
different excel spreadsheets and
workbooks you will have these different
workbooks open
and
there is a particular difference and you
might be asked what is the difference
between this workbook and active
workbook so as the name suggests this
workbook refers to the name of the
workbook where the code is actually
running from okay you are running a code
vba code and it is the actual
workbook where you are running the
code from and that is this workbook okay
and you have multiple spreadsheets open
and you are working on particular
suppose for example you are working on a
sheet x okay and you active workbook is
the workbook that is currently active
from the different open verbs you have
different
open workbooks but you are working on
one particular
workbook and that is called the active
workbook so this workbook is the
refers to the name of the workbook where
the code is actually written whereas
active workbook is the one that is
currently
open currently active okay so this is
the difference between this workbook and
the active workbook in vba
as shown in the example this is a simple
uh sub that is written a code that can
be written to find out which workbook is
the uh
which workbook is the
this workbook in the vba and the active
workbook as well okay so this is a
simple thing that you can run to
determine okay it shows the active
workbook and the this workbook okay
so as we move on to the next one
so this is the question how will you
pass arguments to a pbf function okay
there are two ways basically arguments
can be passed to a vba function as a
value or as a
reference so
this is uh an example that you can see
it is by reference the key word for this
is by reference okay
so when you are passing an argument
by reference the keyword should be by
ref
whereas uh
by value you're specifying a value and
the keyword is by
val value okay so these are the two ways
that you can pass an argument in vba
so when you pass an argument by
reference in a procedure the variable
itself okay the variable itself is
accessed by a procedure and it is to the
location or the address in the memory
okay the value of the variable is
changed permanently by the procedure in
this case all right okay so to pass an
argument by reference you should use
bira that is the key word before the
argument okay so in this example it is
clearly shown what is the keyword that
is being used okay and by reference is
the default in the vba unless you
specify something else which in this
case is by value okay and as i said the
keyword for by value
passing the argument by value is by dal
okay
so
when you set the keyword by val
the variable uh what happens is the
by value argument function or argument
[Music]
is passed through by value okay the
number function is called here which
means it assigns a value to the variable
x here okay because the variable was
passed by value
in the function any change to the value
okay any change to the value
of the variable is only the current
function so it ends after it performs
the
function okay then it revert back to the
value when it is declared again where it
is set to zero
so if the variable has been passed by
reference in the function then the
variable would have permanently assumed
the new assigned value so this is the
basic difference by reference and by
value
so now we move on to the next one
so there might be a question that you
will be asked that how do you find the
last row or a column in a vba okay so to
find a
last row sometimes you have long list of
uh data and it has
like n number of rows and n number of
columns so
instead of scrolling down all together
to find the uh
last row you can use this uh vba code
you can write this code it's a very
simple one and it will give you the
last row you will find the last row with
a single click okay let's see it in the
vba so here i have a sheet which you
know it has long list of
rows and instead of scrolling down i can
just find out the
last row with this vba code okay i just
click on this and
as seen in the slideshow i have just
returned it
and
you will speed it you just run it and
you will see the number of rows it will
give you the last row
in the sheet okay similarly we can do
this for the column as well okay in case
if you have a long list of
large number of columns instead of
scrolling right
you can just uh run this vba and you can
see you can know the
last number of columns okay number of
columns so as we've seen in the last row
now we'll see the code for the final
last column it's the same thing
instead of row you will see it has
column
all right and it when you run it you
will get the
it will give you the last column okay
now let's move on to the next one so you
might be asked this how do we check
whether a file exists or not in a
specified location
there is a code simple vba code that you
can write and you can run you can use
this utility to find out whether the
file exists or not okay and
you need to check whether the file
exists and if it does it will give you a
message that the selected file exists
and if it doesn't it will pop up with a
message box saying that the file
selected file doesn't exist so what you
need to do is you have to specify this
function okay and
check file exist this is what
it does okay you have to specify a
variable that is the store file name
where you will give the location the
location of the file and the name of the
file okay and then you will also specify
whether the file name is there or not
now
so it runs this and it will see
either the file name exist or the file
actually exists or not
and it will give the appropriate message
box we can run the same thing in my pc
and we can check it
so here we are i have put this and i
have done the same thing and what i'm
looking for is this book two okay let me
maximize it this is what i'm looking for
and the location is desktop okay so let
me run this and you will see whether it
exists or not okay
and it says this to a selected file
exists so it goes and checks whether the
file exists and then it will give you
the message so this is how we check
using the vb
so the next one is uh
you know there is a powerful tool called
debug and you need to
you might be asked questions about how
debug works or how
you check the debug okay to debug a vba
code line by line you can use the f8 key
okay you can also create a breakpoint to
terminate the execution so for this if
you go to your
vba you will see the option as debug
okay you can use this
by clicking on debug or by pressing the
f8 key okay so what debug does is it
will show you the step-by-step execution
of your
steps okay it will check each and
everything and if there is an error it
will pop up okay
and the what is breakpoint is at some
point of time
you can check one particular step okay
you can stop the if suppose if there is
a thousand line codes and you want to
check on one particular step like maybe
800 step so just go to go to that
particular step and you can enter a
break point and it will show you what is
actually happening
at the that point that particular step
and you can see this in the locals
window or the watch window okay so let
me show you some simple example of how
this debug can be
used to check our codes okay
so here i have written a simple code for
this and it is basically
let me show you how debug works okay
this is the
let me maximize it and we'll see
okay so this is the debug option that
you can run and you will see what
happens okay this can be done by
clicking
f8 all right
so step into is the option and you can
check
f8 and you can press f8 again it will go
to the next step all right and it will
show you what's happening actually uh
you can see this in the uh locals window
what's actually happening let me see
let me maximize it a bit
so that you can actually see okay so
when i press f8
okay
step into
you will see what happens in the next
step okay this is what is happening a is
empty
b is zero i is zero okay i step into it
uh the next step again so it goes here
you can see what changes happen
i press
f8 again
so this is what is happening
all right so it is checking each and
every step so debug is the tool that you
can use to check the course whether this
is a very simple program but then you
will have some different codes where you
pro
functions or routines that you can have
where you have thousand line codes and
you need to check each and every step or
some particular step so this comes in
very handy
okay let me press f8 and it shows what
happens in which
you can step into each and every step
and
see what happens okay and now if i show
there is something called as toggle
break point okay this one particular is
used by uh
pressing the f9 key wherein you will see
what is actually happening at some
particular step okay so how you do that
is you just need to go to a particular
step and click on the bar here and it
will get
highlighted into red so this is what is
happening okay so in the watch window
you will see that particular step will
be
magnified or you can see what is
actually happening in that step okay so
let me start it again
see what happens
i press f8 again
so here it sees
it actually shows you can toggle and you
can see what is happening in the watch
window at that particular step so module
1 abc the variant is empty so expression
is b this is what is happening at this
particular step okay so this is how
debug can be used
so now as we move on to the next one
well you might be asked to create a bar
chart with the given data using vba so
you will have some data
and
you can create a bar chart or a
any kind of chart
with the vba we have done it with the
pivot tables and all but then we can do
the same with the vba so it's a simple
thing a simple sub that you can run
and create embedded chart using chart
object this is the
sub that you can use okay you are
specifying a variable here
and m budget chart you need to specify
the
embedded chart and which sheet you are
using and this is very basic and the
chart a chart objects like the length
the dimensions of the chart okay
and you need to specify the source okay
the source sheet for
range so and so you can specify the
range here so uh let's go and do the
same thing in the vba
so here i have the data and
let i've already copied the
vba for it and let me simply
run it
okay
see
it creates a chart so this comes in very
handy
and you can see the
as i have mentioned in
you have to specify the source the
dimensions of the chart and so on so and
so on okay you are specifying where it's
picking up the data from
and the columns i mean the range and the
dimensions of the chart okay you can
play with this and you will generate a
chart so
well this ends our presentations
and
so
this is how it looks like and we've seen
that so next question is about
a vba code again to calculate the area
of a rectangle using the vba function
how do you include a function to
calculate the area of a rectangle we all
know that the area of a rectangle is
length into width
okay that is the formula we can execute
it with the way by defining a function
in the vba
and we'll define the same function
function is equal to area and it is area
as length into bit in this scenario i'll
again show it to you
how we do this in excel and
let's go ahead and do this
so here we are i will just go to the
developer tab and open the vpn and i
insert a module okay
so here we will define the function okay
function
as area okay
this is my function
and now i'm going to define the
variables okay
length as
double because
we
want to make sure that it takes the
decimals as well okay
and width
okay now what is the uh area
formula for example a equals to
length
into event
okay
very simple
okay now
i go to my excel and
i'll define the area function okay
let's take the
length to be put in
a1 and the width to be put in b okay now
if i just put the value here
it will take 12 and my width is 36
3 and it shows the area to be 36 okay
11
so this is the area if you just go and
define it i mean try to enter area a1
and b1 it will not so we have to define
the function here we're using the vba
code okay now let's go back to the slide
and we'll discuss so here uh it has been
shown as if you know we have a
rectangle when the wind width is not
provided that is if the
rectangle is a square they will not be
given the width so we are defining again
length as double optional optional is we
are giving an argument that it is
optional width as a variant width as a
variant means it can be zero okay so we
are defining it as if missing width then
the area should be length into length
okay else the area is length into width
as we have seen okay so this is one way
to define a function for the area of a
rectangle
okay let's go to the next slide
so
you might be asked about a vba function
to check if the number is prime or not
we all know what a prime number is a
prime number is divisible by 1 and
itself
for example 2 3 5 7 11
13
17 and so on and these are the prime
numbers and anything which is divisible
by any other number like 8 or 4 or 16
which has a divisor is not a prime
number so uh we all know this and we
will write a
vba code to
check if the number is prime or not so
this is the one that is given and we
will do the same in the vba okay before
moving ahead i will just uh
explain these uh the code and what we
are doing here is basically we are
defining three variables okay we are
declaring three variables one integer
variable
okay
and we call it as divisors all right and
then the next one is the one long
variable long
as the number and i as long okay here
long specifies
variables
because uh it has got the larger
capacity than the integer values okay
the divisor will be zero we are
initializing the
variable divisor with the value of zero
okay the next thing is we use a input
box input box to get the number from the
user that is you will input a
number when you're asked to
uh for the input box okay so this is the
so when the number is entered we want to
check whether this number is prime or
not okay so how do we check that okay as
we all know the condition for prime
number is it has only two number
divisors that is one and itself so what
we do is we start a next loop okay
for i equals to one 2 numbers all right
so this is the start of the loop we will
define the conditions here
so now how do we actually perform the
operation of dividing we use the
mod operator okay this is one of the
important
operator to check here the mod operator
will give you the remainder of a
division for example you have 7 or 8 or
mod by 2
is equal to 1 because 7 divided by 2
equals 3 with the remainder of 1
okay so only if the
only
if a number mod
i equals to 0 i is the advise divisor of
a number okay so in this case we want to
increment it by variable divisors by one
so this is what we defined it as okay
now
so here a check is performed like
i equals to 1
and then
plus
1 i equals to 2 then plus 1 i equals to
3 and then plus 4 i equals to
so as it goes on until it reaches the
number okay because for i equals to 1 to
number okay
so this is what is starting of the loop
now you have to close the loop so how we
do that is next i okay this is closing
the
loop
so this is what the loop does now we are
we have defined the check now we have to
define the result what happens if the
devices is equals to 2 then the message
box number should say is a prime number
all right otherwise it should say
message number should pop up and say it
is not a prime number so this is how
we define it in the vba let's go ahead
and do this
so here we are i have already set it up
and this is the vba so let's run it okay
and it will ask you this is the module 2
because i defined it as module 2.
so the message box opens up and it asks
you to enter a value now
let's see
two
is a prime number okay
i run it again by pressing the
fake key okay
12
is not a prime number so this is how we
have name
we have coded a
maybe a code or function to check
whether the number is prime or not
so this ends our presentation or
about the interview questions now with
that we have come to an end of this
session on advanced excel full course i
hope the session was interesting and
informative if you have any queries
regarding any of the topics covered in
this session or if you require the
resources that we used in this session
then please feel free to let us know in
the comment section below and our team
of experts will be more than happy to
resolve all your queries at the earliest
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you